Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie steht es um deine Opferbereitschaft?
Sehr, sehr schlecht.
Das ist schlecht, denn dein Vizekanzler braucht dich.
Ja, für Deutschland, für ein starkes Deutschland.
Ein starkes Deutschland. Und der Vizekanzler spürt es auch, dass die Leute bereit sind. Es ist ein bisschen wie, wir haben das schon gehört, die Leute sind geil auf Wohlstand. Ja. Und die Politik macht das jetzt.
Ich bin so gespannt.
Aber es kostet Opfer.
Das heißt, wir verarmen uns selbst und stärken damit Deutschland.
Aber das mit der Verarmung ist natürlich nicht laut ausgesprochen. Ich weiß nicht, woher du diese Info schon wieder hast.
Das tut mir leid, dass ich so...
Als hättest du die Ausgabe heute schon fertig gehört.
Ja, dazu kommen wir heute noch.
Dazu kommen wir heute noch. Erstmal müssen wir Alexander Kluge hier verabschieden.
Ja.
Jürgen Habermas ist gestorben und wir konnten uns ein bisschen amüsieren über seine Jünger.
Das war Alexander Kluge ein bisschen anders.
Ja. Alexander Kluge hat ja übrigens direkt noch nach dem Tod von Habermas ein Interview der Zeit über sein Verhältnis zu Habermas gegeben. Und wenige Tage später stirbt dann Alexander Kluge, der große Filmemacher, Freigeist, Schriftsteller und ja Fernsehproduzent dieser unglaublichen Nachtausgaben, die wir alle auf YouTube uns ansehen können. Das ist ja etwas, was Roger Schawinski damals, als er bei Sat.1 war, versuchte zu verhindern. Aber Kluge hatte da sehr gute Kontakte ins Ministerium hinein, dass das weitergehen konnte. Also eine Sternstunde des Fernsehens. Aber ja, Kluge ist jemand, der sicherlich einer der flexibelsten Denker überhaupt war in der Bundesrepublik und den wir ja hier auch mehrmals gewürdigt hatten. Nämlich im Zuge des Krieges in der Ukraine hatte sich Kluge ja sehr interessant geäußert, dass man den Krieg ins Stolpern bringen muss. Er hat das dann ausgeführt. Wir haben auch in einem Salon kurz mal über seine Kriegsfibel gesprochen. Also er spielt hier auch für uns eine Rolle.
Ja, eine sehr große Rolle. Also Alexander Kluge hatte im Deutschlandfunk, nee nicht im Deutschlandfunk, den Tagesthemen so einen kurzen Hinweis mitbekommen. Das große Publikum hat er nie gefunden. Und da möchte ich gerne anmerken, ja, der hat in der Zukunft gelebt. Er war zu einer Zeit schon Personal Media, als alle dachten, die große Fernsehshow kann auch jemand anders moderieren. Hauptsache, es ist wetten das. Und er hat gezeigt, nee, die Leute wollen schon ihn sehen, egal in welchem Format. Damit vorbildhaft für unsere ganze Podcastereihe, muss man wirklich sagen. Und ja, diese ganzen Filme und Kram, die du jetzt angesprochen hast, die fanden natürlich in diesen alten Medien statt. Sind dort hoffentlich auch so konserviert, dass wir es noch mal wiederfinden.
Wo du das aber gerade so sagst, wenn man sich diese DCTP-Sachen da ansieht, also wo er zum Beispiel mit prominenten Geisteswissenschaftlern über Themen spricht oder Helge Schneider schlüpft in die Rolle von irgendwelchen Nazis oder Peter Bärling. Wenn man sich das ansieht und wenn man auch hört, wie dort gesprochen wird, mal von diesen Einspielern, die es dazwischen gibt, die mitunter auch vielleicht ein bisschen nervig sind. Wenn man das mal wegnimmt, dann hat man da eigentlich so eine Podcast-Situation. Kluge ist der interessiert nachfragende, aber permanent auch mitspricht mit den Antworten der anderen. Also der immer sagt, ja, und das war doch dann auch, ja, ja. Diese besondere Atmosphäre, die da für die Nacht entstanden ist, ist eigentlich eine, die wir heute aus dem Podcast sehr gut kennen. Insofern war er Protopodcaster.
Ja, Protopodcaster. Und ich würde sagen, er hat uns jetzt eine letzte Aufgabe mitgegeben, denn in seinem ganz kurzen, ich will gar nicht sagen Nachruf, aber Textchen zu Habermas Tod in der FAZ. Hat er darauf hingewiesen. Jemanden wie Jürgen Habermas bräuchten wir jetzt, um das Dark Enlightenment an der amerikanischen Ostküste zu verstehen. Und jetzt würde ich sagen, naja, Habermas hätte ich dafür nicht gebraucht, aber Alexander Kluge. Jetzt müssen wir diese Denkleistung die nächsten Monate erbringen. Wir werden uns auf jeden Fall diese Neuen Dunklen Mächte da mal angucken.
Und das machen wir im Salon im Übrigen, wo du das gerade sagst. Wir sprechen über Adrian Daupp, was das Valley Herrschen nennt. Wir haben schon von Adrian Daupp, was das Valley Denken nennt, gelesen. Jetzt kommt der nächste Teil, was das Valley Herrschen nennt. Und Peter Sloterdijk beschäftigt sich mit den großen Männern, der Fürst und seine Erben, über große Männer im Zeitalter der gewöhnlichen Leute. Wir sind sehr gespannt, was wir da über die neuen Regierungsmodi erfahren und die vermeintlich großen Männer.
Genau.
Das alles kann man dann also im Salon hören. In etwa einer Woche nehmen wir den auf. Aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich über das sprechen, worüber sehr viel jetzt geredet wird, nämlich über den Fall Collien Fernandes. Und ich sage bewusst den Fall Collien Fernandes, weil wir tatsächlich hier nicht noch einmal wiedergeben, was Collien Fernandes vorwirft und was die Spiegelrecherchen ergeben hat. Das wissen auch alle. Das kann man auch sonst noch mal alles nachlesen. Collien Fernandes gibt ja auch bei Instagram sehr ausführliche Statements ab. Jedoch werden wir uns nicht daran beteiligen, das zu reproduzieren, aus ganz einfachen Gründen. Wir wollen nicht auch vor Gericht landen und irgendwas mit Anwälten zu tun haben. Denn das ist wirklich in einer massiven Art und Weise, wie man hört, dass da also Leute, die darüber berichten, unter Druck gesetzt werden, mit einem Anwalt schreiben, sodass wir uns dem jetzt nicht aussetzen. Aber wir können ja in anderer Weise darüber sprechen. Nämlich interessant ist ja, dass wir jetzt gerade eine solche anwaltliche Macht erleben und es da um H kleine Formulierungen geht. Und wir jetzt auch sagen, dann sind wir mal lieber vorsichtig.
Also über diese anwaltlichen Macht können wir natürlich sprechen, schon allein, weil es Spaß macht. Von daher, der Fall selber ist natürlich drastisch. Und es ist ein bisschen wie bei dem französischen Fall zu Perico, dass man sich so fragt, Einzelfall oder was? Und wir wissen nein. Aber es werden keine weiteren Namen genannt, weil keine Ahnung, bei anderen Fällen ist halt nicht so viel Öffentlichkeit im Spiel. Da wird nicht gleich eine Demo anberaumt. Und da ist man dann auf sich allein gestellt.
Und bei Pelico gab es ja jetzt auch schon Verurteilungen. Das ist ja auch eine andere Dimension.
Was auf jeden Fall ein wirklich immenses Problem ist, ist, dass auf der einen Seite man selber im Internet alles machen darf, weil Elon Musk eine Maschine gebaut hat, die es für einen erledigt. Also dieses Prinzip. Ich habe ja nur einen Tweet geschrieben, in dem ich Croc erwähnt habe. Das Bild selbst hat er dann Croc erzeugt und in einem von Croc autorisierten, sondern geschriebenen Tweet veröffentlicht. Nur gegen Elon Musk ist halt keine Handhabe. Und zwar ausschließlich, weil die europäischen Politiker keinen Arsch in der Hose haben. Gleichzeitig funktioniert das Gegenmodell dazu, dass dann Beschwerden darüber einfängt. Wunderbar. Also du buchst diesen Scherz und dann ist wirklich jede Kommersetzung streitbar. Und das ist grotesker. Also Opfer, feuerfrei, vermeintliche Täter, mutmaßliche Täter, Unschuldsvermutung. Als ob die Unschuldsvermutung das höchste Gut ist und man nicht sich sowieso das Maul zerreißt. Es ist wirklich eine ganz groteske Lage.
Ja, die Unschuldsvermutung ist ja auch das eine. Das andere ist ja das Reden darüber, was vorgeworfen wird und das Wiedergeben, dass das also problematisch wird, das überhaupt zu diskutieren. Das ist ja nochmal ein ganz anderer Fall, als jetzt diese Unschuldsvermutung, die natürlich gilt. Und was wir aber sehen, ist ja, dass es neben der Unschuldsvermutung auch eigentlich so ist, das hat man ja doch jetzt in vielen Berichten gehört, dass man bei Opfern häufig so dehnen von Seiten des Gerichts beispielsweise oder der Ermittler so eine, sagen wir, Schuldunterstellung gegenüber an den Tag legt, was dann auch für die Opfer natürlich ein großes Problem ist oder auch die Angst ist, sich überhaupt zu äußern, weil wird mir jemand glauben. Was ich dabei jetzt interessant finde bei diesen ganzen Diskussionen.
Ich will nur kurz die Unschuldsvermutung. Du hast es gesagt, die Unschuldsvermutung gilt für den vermutlich Täter.
Genau.
Für das Opfer, dessen Bilder einfach überall rumkursieren und das dann im ganzen Freundeskreis, man weiß nicht mal wo, und ich rede jetzt nicht von Collien Fernandes, sondern so von grundsätzlich allen, von schulpflichtbetroffenen Kindern in Deutschland und so. Die müssen ihre Unschuldsvermutung im Sinne von, das bin gar nicht ich auf dem Bild, mühsam einfordern in so einem Klassenverband, in der Schule, in der Stadt, was auch immer. Also da gibt es eben genau gar keine Unschuldsvermutung. Und die Politik tut, also eher noch die Spanische und so weiter. Ich würde sagen, nein, in Europa, das liegt alles brach. Also es ist einfach ganz schlimm.
Ja, da gilt eher die Schuldunterstellung, dass man jedem, der da zum Opfer wird, erst mal sagt, na ja, aber hast du da nicht auch? Bist du da nicht auch im Bikini irgendwo gewesen? Und ist das dann nicht auch logisch das? Also es wird da werden Argumentationsketten aufgemacht, bei denen man gar nicht glauben kann, was da alles passiert. Es zeigt sich ja auch interessanterweise, wenn man sich das bei Instagram ansieht, dass es nicht nur jetzt Collien Fernandes und Aktivisten gibt, die sich dazu äußern, sondern es gibt ja einfach Medien wie Focus Online oder Gala oder irgendetwas. Medien, die jetzt einfach nur so einen Post absetzen, Collien Fernandes wirft vor Doppelpunkt und dann steht da so ein Satz. Mehr steht da nicht. Ich finde überhaupt diese Art des Kacheljournalismus schwierig. Man muss dann schon diese Kacheln auch entsprechend gestalten und füllen und auch Kontexte liefern, nicht einfach so einen Satz hinschreiben, den man dann den Leuten zum Fraß vorwirft. Ich weiß, dass das Prinzip ist. Wenn man dann in diese Kommentarspalten blickt, dann gibt es selbstverständlich viel Solidarität, und auch gute Argumente, was jetzt zu tun wäre. Aber was doch auffällt, gerade bei diesen so Durchlaufmedien, wo man mal so irgendwas anklickt, mal draufschaut, ist, dass wir ja die ganze Zeit mit so einer Kachel offenbar bei Leuten auslösen. Ich muss mich unbedingt dazu äußern. Also man muss ja auch nicht kommentieren. Ich kommentiere zum Beispiel so gut wie nie irgendetwas. Aber es gibt eben Millionen Menschen, die das gerne tun, sich laufend dort produzieren, den Kommentaren. Und erstaunlich ist dann, wie sehr dort ein Hass Collien Fernandes Frauen im Allgemeinen entgegenschlägt. Und zwar von Männern natürlich am meisten. Aber interessanterweise, wenn man sich das mal ansieht, man müsste eine Erhebung machen mit viel AI, um das mal wirklich zu entschlüsseln, wenn man sich mal so 100 Posts, 100 Kacheln ansieht und die Kommentare, dass auch sehr viele Frauen da in keiner Weise solidarisch sind. Und dass dort auch die ganze Zeit so eine Schuld unter Stellung stattfindet, beziehungsweise Bilder rausgekramt werden von Collien Fernandes, wo sie irgendwie aufreizend in die Kamera blickt, als sei das irgendeine Rechtfertigung für irgendetwas, wo wir sehen, dass dort Leute in sehr barbarischer Weise sich äußern, und zwar mit einem Klarnamen. Und ich will hier sagen, ich rede jetzt nicht von den extremen Beleidigungen, die dann auch justiziabel wären, sondern ich rede wirklich von so einer Enthemmung, die da generell stattfindet, dass man sagt, also Kommentare wie, ach, sie muss wohl Geld verdienen, hat sie ein Buch veröffentlicht oder warum kommt sie jetzt damit. Also nur in diesem Modus wird auf all das reagiert, dass man sagen kann, da ist die Verrohung schon sehr weit. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem. Da sind wir nämlich genau bei solchen Sätzen, nicht bei der Frage, wie können wir das in irgendeiner Weise einschränken oder ist das Hass im Netz oder so. Nee, das ist in dem Sinne, ist es natürlich Hass, aber nicht ein Hass im Netz, wo man sagen kann, da müssen mal die Ermittlungsbehörden hin. Also das ist mir aufgefallen.
Also da können wir durchaus eine Kommentarlese hier machen. Wir sind ja ein KI-affirmatives Büro hier.
Ja, ich bin sehr interessiert daran, wie man das mal auswerten könnte, weil das doch mir sehr aufgefallen ist. Und das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das auch hier ein solcher Kulturkampf draus wird. Was ich wichtig finde, ist, dass jetzt in den Forderungen, die es gibt, Gott sei Dank sich diese kurzzeitig mal aufschwimmernde Idee der Klar-Namen-Pflicht nicht durchgesetzt hat. Also es gibt jetzt doch nicht die Forderungen von Aktivisten, dass wir eine Klar-Namen-Pflicht brauchen. Ich war allerdings ein bisschen irritiert, als ich gestern die Justizministerin Hubech bei Karamjowska sprechen sah, die an sich auch viel Richtiges gesagt hat, die aber dann vorschlug, dass man IP-Adressen drei Monate lang vorsorglich speichert und Ronen Steink hat dann auch gleich das Wort Vorratsdatenspeicherung da eingeworfen gesagt, das könnte problematisch werden.
Das habe ich anders gehört, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich habe es gerade eben noch gehört, aber jetzt keine Clips. Also für mich wirkte das so, als ob Karamjowska, sie hat ja auch die eine Jurastudentin mehrfach darauf angesprochen, was mit Klar-Namenspflicht ist, und sie sagte dann, nein, dann können wir uns ja gar nicht mehr hier austauschen als Betroffene, weil wir können ja jetzt nicht alle mit Klar-Namen unsere Geschichten reinschreiben. Und unsere Justizministerin hat für mich, ich habe natürlich in zweifacher Geschwindigkeit gehört und nur einmal, sehr deutlich gesagt, wir gehen nicht hinter europäische Rechtsprechung zurück.
Nein, das nicht.
Und das heißt keine Vorzahnspeicherung. Und danach wurde sie auf Quick Freeze angesprochen von der Jurastudentin mit der Frage, wenn ich einen Vorfall melde, könnten dann aus den 48 Stunden Überwachungsvideomaterial einfach länger werden, aber es muss halt angemeldet werden. Und daraufhin gab es einen kleinen Wortwechsel, aber ich habe jetzt...
Aber es gab auch diese Idee der drei Monate, ob die Plattformen dazu verpflichtet werden könnten, dass die IP-Adressen...
Also ich komme gerade aus dem Hörerlebnis der Sendung und war froh darüber, nicht Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehört zu haben. Dass es die Diskussion gibt, ist klar.
Ja, der Brunnensteinke hat das eingeworfen. Also nicht Hube ich gesagt, wir brauchen eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Aber wenn man sagt, wir würden IP-Adressen erst mal für drei Monate containen, dann würde man ja eine Art Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen. Das wäre ja dann noch nicht die gleiche Entschlüsselung, dass da immer die Klarnamen sind. Aber man hätte das dann erst mal so gespeichert. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist es ein sehr sensibles Thema, wenn man jetzt in diese Richtung geht, dass man da nicht plötzlich sagt, wir haben dann ein gutes Einfallstore, um Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so etwas vorzunehmen. Zumal wir ja auch hier unterschiedliche Debatten führen müssen. Denn wenn wir jetzt den aktuellen Fall sehen, dann geht das ja zum Beispiel auch nicht nur um Deepfake, sondern es geht ja auch um Dinge, die auf andere Weise angebahnt werden, über Telefongespräche, über E-Mails, die geschrieben werden im Namen von. Also man kann sagen, das ist auch eine Art von Deepfake, aber das ist ja nochmal ein anderes Deepfake, wie wenn ich jetzt ein Foto von dir nehme und damit dies und das mache. Und das wird ja dann sehr interessant sein. Und da hoffe ich, dass wir da tatsächlich eine sehr aufgeklärte Debatte bekommen, wie eigentlich dann so eine Trennung aussieht, nämlich von dem, was erlaubt ist, also was zu Meme-Kultur dazu gehört und wo man sagen kann, aha, da geht es aber um etwas anderes. Da ist die Intention eine andere, zum Beispiel eine virtuelle Missbrauchsintention. Und das ist ja gar nicht so leicht, bei allem voneinander zu trennen. Denn sagen wir mal, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie von uns beiden sagen würde, da wird jetzt irgendein Meme veröffentlicht, wo jetzt unsere Köpfe auf Leute draufgemacht werden, die jetzt mit freiem Oberkörper muskulös posieren, um den Diskurs aufzunehmen, dass wir uns hier über Fitnessstudio unterhalten haben, dann würden wir sagen, das ist jetzt nicht ein Missbrauch unserer Person. Aber wo würde das genau, wo ist also die Grenze erreicht, wo man sagen würde, nee, da wird aber schon aus einer ganz anderen Intention der eine Kopf auf den anderen Körper gesteckt.
Also da gab es ja Auseinandersetzungen im Sinne von Scherz, hat es ja explizit geschrieben. Christian Ullmann hat keine Deepfakes hergestellt und dann hat Fernandes nochmal...
Ja, lass uns das jetzt nicht nochmal alles wiederholen.
Nein, du hast so eine Angst. Wir müssen die gar nicht haben.
Ich finde schon.
Nein, nein, ich habe die nicht. Also der Scherz hat geschrieben, im Namen von Ullmann, mein Mandant hat keine Deepfakes hergestellt. Daraufhin sind alle nochmal in diesen Spiegeltexte gegangen und haben herausgelesen, das steht da auch nicht drin. So und Fernandes hat auch nochmal im Nachgang gesagt, das war nicht die Behauptung. Was für mich bedeutet, das erste Scherzstatement ist aus meiner Lesart ein Schuldeingeständnis für das, was ihm im Spiegel vorgeworfen wurde, weil das, was er explizit diese Widersprüche lese, ich dann nicht.
So, was mich jetzt interessiert an dem Fall ist aber, Naja, nur weil man dagegen das eine widerspricht, kann man auch das andere, also wir sollten das hier nicht bewerten.
Will ich auch nicht. Ich habe nur diesen einen Punkt genannt. So, was mich interessiert ist, wie überhaupt jemand im Namen eines anderen online kommunizieren kann. Und zwar sogar in privaten Kreisen. Wir haben zum Beispiel eine Mail bekommen, nachdem ich hier Webseite und so weiter gemacht habe für den Podcast, dass man unseren Server gerade ein bisschen überrumpeln konnte, indem man eben, also jemand anders nimmt unsere E-Mail-Adresse und schreibt, mit unserem Absender. Also mailetneuezwanziger.de. Und das war jemand von einem Lehrstuhl-Mitarbeiter, dessen Professor selbst mal an die Bundeskanzlerin in ihrem Namen eine E-Mail schickte, um die darauf hinzuweisen. Und am Ende nur eine kleine Server-Einstellung, der habe ich jetzt bei uns auch geändert. So. Jenseits aller juristischen Dinge müssen die Leute jetzt so langsam verstehen, wie die Technik funktioniert. Also, wenn man eine E-Mail bekommt von irgendwer oder eine Nachricht oder was auch immer, dann muss man auf der Höhe der Zeit sein und die Technik so weit verstehen, dass man grundlegend einschätzen kann, womit man es hier zu tun hat. Das Leute monatelang glaubten, sie chatten mit Collien Fernandes, finde ich einfach, das ist grotesk. Das darf überhaupt gar nicht passieren. Vor allem nicht in so einer krassen Parallelität, dass das gleich zehn Leute auf einmal machen. Wie die sich dann psychologisch verhalten.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Mit ihr an einem Abendessenstisch sitzen und das nicht ansprechen, weil sie glauben, sie sind gerade in so etwas Intimen, tata, tata, aber das ist ja gerade nur eine private Veranstaltung. Das ist auf so vielen Dimensionen so merkwürdig, dass ich mich wirklich wundere. Von daher, diese technische Diskussion, die muss jetzt auch mal geführt werden. Wir haben diese Chatkontrolle, das ist ja auch so ein riesiges Ding. Wir haben den Signal-Messenger, der einem ganz viel von dieser Arbeit einfach abnimmt, wenn man einfach mal weiß, wie man ihn bedient. Aber die Leute hängen offenbar weiterhin in ihren WhatsApp-Gruppen rum und wissen überhaupt nicht, was ihnen da geschieht.
Aber das wissen wir ja schon lange, dass das so ist.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist jetzt wirklich mal das Zeitalter angebrochen.
Wenn jemand von jemandem eine E-Mail bekommt, dann stellt er doch nicht gleich in Frage, ob die wirklich von dem ist.
Ne, aber wenn du nackt Fotos von einer nahen Freundin bekommst plötzlich, dann vielleicht schon. Also dann würde ich mich doch mal dafür interessieren, von welcher E-Mail-Adresse kommt denn das gerade und ist das zu erwartenbares Verhalten oder was auch immer. Und da muss ich sagen, hat dieser Fall doch einige. Aber es ist wie bei Perlico, also du hast 50 Leute, die irgendwie angeklagt und verurteilt werden und 5.000, die davon mitbekommen, dass deine Frau angeboten wird und kein einziger, redet mal mit irgendjemanden darüber.
Das ist das Erstaunliche, über das noch viel zu reden sein muss, wie so ein Netz da überhaupt so lange aufrechterhalten werden kann. Was sicherlich auch wichtig ist, ist zu beachten, wie wird eigentlich umgegangen mit Opfern. Und ich will mal hier einen Clip vorspielen von Alina Kuhl, die ist bei Instagram, heißt dort The Monday Talks. Und sie spricht Folgendes an, was mir auch nicht klar war.
Wenn man eine Vergewaltigung anzeigt, wird einem geraten, keine Therapie zu machen, bis das gesamte Verfahren abgeschlossen ist, was ja mindestens mehrere Jahre dauert. Und es hat mich damals so schockiert, als ich noch in England bei einem Hilfetelefon für sexualisierte Gewalt war, da war das tatsächlich auch verboten, eine Therapie zu machen. Da durfte man nur bis zu neun Sitzungen machen, wo man aber nicht über das Trauma spricht, sondern nur über Bewältigungsstrategien, um zum Beispiel aus einer Panikattacke wieder rauszukommen. Das hat mich richtig schockiert. Darum war damals auch das Hilfetelefon, wo ich war, dadurch, dass es anonym war, der einzige Ort, wo die Frauen überhaupt über das erlebte Trauma sprechen konnten, über das, was ihnen passiert ist. Als ich dann zurück nach Deutschland gekommen bin, habe ich mich sehr überrascht, dass es hier auch so ist. Aber die meisten wissen das nicht. Kaum jemand weiß das, weil es ist hier zwar nicht verboten, eine Therapie zu machen. Es wird einem aber davon abgeraten, weil es wird einem oft als Suggestion ausgelegt, also dass die Aussage verfälscht wurde durch die Traumatherapie. Und darum ist deine Aussage dann nichts mehr wert. Was denn in dem Verfahren, wo Außergegen Aussage steht, natürlich eine absolute Katastrophe ist. Und es gibt auch genug Forschung, die zeigt, dass das Quatsch ist. Natürlich ist es super, super wichtig, für die betroffenen Frauen Zugang zur Therapie zu haben. Je früher man so einen Trauma angehen kann, desto besser kann man es verarbeiten. Und nicht erst durch die ganze Unsicherheit von so einem Prozess, weil es ja auch mit so viel Unsicherheit verbunden ist. Es dauert Jahre, bis man überhaupt weiß, ob es zur Anklage kommt. Das heißt, vielleicht hat man auch die ganze Zeit keine Therapie gemacht und es wird nicht mehr als Anklage erhoben. Es kommt nicht mehr zu dem Strafprozess. Darum ist es eine super schwierige Entscheidung. Hinzu kommt auch, wenn die Polizei einmal von der Vergewaltigung erfährt, kann man das nicht wieder zurückziehen. Man ist in dem Prozess nur Zeugin. Man ist nicht Klägerin. Man kann als Nebenklägerin auftreten. Man kann sich selber auch als Anwältin engagieren und als Nebenklägerin dabei sein. Aber eigentlich ist man nur Zeugin und man kann es nicht wieder zurückziehen. Das heißt, wenn man an dem Punkt ist, wo man denkt, fuck, ich darf jetzt die ganze Zeit keine Therapie machen, ich hänge hier seit Jahren, dann im Zweifel muss ich sogar noch dem Täter was bezahlen, dem Mutmaßlichen, weil die ja in der Regel immer wegen Verlumdung erst mal klagen und dass man nicht darüber sprechen darf. Und dann hat man das noch an der Backe. Und dann kann man die ganze Zeit nicht mehr als bei das Thema verarbeiten. Und man kommt auf gar keinen Fall wieder aus diesem Prozess heraus. Es ist einfach, das deutsche Rechtssystem, wenn es um Vergewaltigungen geht, ist eine absolute Katastrophe.
Du kannst eh keine Therapie machen, nur weil du akut betroffen bist.
Weil du keinen Platz bekommst? Genau. Aber das, was sie hier anspricht, ist ja unglaublich. Weil genau in dieser Situation dann ist, dass man sagt, naja, also, dann können wir die Aussage nicht mehr glauben, vielleicht. Und man darf eine machen, aber möglicherweise ist das dann später vor Gericht etwas, was dir eher negativ ausgelegt wird. Also, dass überhaupt diese Gemengelage entsteht. Da sehen wir ja, dass da erhebliche Probleme sind.
Ja, also es gab im FAZ-Einspruch-Podcast eine Auseinandersetzung, ein Gespräch mit einem Richter, der verantwortlich auch für so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, aber wie so Gerichte arbeiten. Und die Frage kam auf, ob es bald KI-Richter gibt. Und es wurde gar nicht so hart zurückgewiesen, wie ich dachte, weil sehr viele Fälle doch einfach verhandelt werden, weil man eine dritte Instanz braucht, ohne dass jetzt viele am besten Spielräume oder so weiter. Leute brauchen einfach mal eine Urteil, damit so ein bisschen Frieden herrscht. Und das fand ich ganz interessant, denn sehr viele Fälle, gerade im Strafrecht, die ja vor Gericht verhandelt werden, es gibt super interessante Soziologie zur Frage, was ist, wenn in Amerika vor einer Jury verhandelt wird und dann schlägt jemand hinten die Tür auf, rennt rein und beschuldigt nochmal den Angeklagten so richtig krass und alle fragen, wer sind sie denn? Na, ich bin auch ein Betroffener und so weiter. Und das hat wirklich krasse Auswirkungen. Also die Jury lässt sich davon sehr beeindrucken, wenn plötzlich noch jemand auf der, dasselbe und so weiter. Weshalb wohl relativ viele Mafia-Prozesse damals so abliefen, dass immer hinten Theater stattfand. Einfach nur um die Jury zu beeinflussen. Große Soziologie zum Thema, wann sind eigentlich die Urteile besonders wohlwollend und wann nicht. Und stellt sich raus, ja, vor der Mittagspause sieht es halt nicht so gut aus, weil die Richter schlecht drauf sind. Und lauter solche Sachen. Von daher würde ich sagen, dass in Deutschland offenbar weiterhin gilt, dass das Opfer auch wie ein Opfer erkennbar sein muss. Also leidend, fordernd, bippernd. Statt einfach, nein, da erzählt jemand stolz seine Lebensgeschichte zu, der gehört mal dem Nachteil gewesen zu sein. Und jetzt möchte man gerne eine Aufarbeitung dazu.
Und Recht haben.
Genau. Das scheint offenbar so nicht vorgesehen zu sein. Und das finde ich auch nicht gut.
In diese Richtung argumentiert Ronan Steinke gestern bei Karen Mioska.
Zunächst mal ist die entscheidende juristische Frage ganz oft, wem glaubt man? Also es steht Aussage gegen Aussage. In ganz vielen Fällen gibt es keine objektiven Beweise. Und wir haben keine wissenschaftliche Methode, mit der man das dann klar auflösen kann. Es gibt keinen Lügendetektor oder so was, sondern es gibt Menschen, die sich hinsetzen, sich das anhören von der einen, von der anderen Seite und sich dann Gedanken machen. Was halten sie für plausibel? Und das eröffnet einen Raum für Lebensweisheit von Richterinnen und Richtern, Menschenkenntnis, aber auch für Vorurteile. Und da erleben leider noch zu oft Frauen, dass ihnen gesagt wird, naja, du hast ja danach dich nicht getrennt von deinem Partner, wie kann denn das sein? Ach so was trennt man sich doch. Na das klingt uns, kommt uns spanisch vor. Oder es wird gesagt, wenn jemand berichtet, sie hat bei Tinder, also bei der Dating-App jemanden kennengelernt und dann kam es zu einem Ereignis, was sie als Vergewaltigung wahrgenommen hat. Na ja, und wie kommt es, dass sie danach weiter Dating-Apps nutzt? Das ist ja seltsam, müsste man sich da nicht von abwenden. Und dann sagt die Frau, nein, ich bin ganz stolz, dass ich mich nicht klein machen lasse und von so einem Menschen nicht mein ganzes Leben kaputt machen lasse. Und dann wird dir gesagt, nee, also das macht keinen Sinn aus unserer Sicht. Also es werden ganz viele so Rollenerwartungen, Bilder, die in Kopf vorherrschen, davon, wie Sexualität funktioniert, wie man sich zu verhalten hat als Opfer von sexueller Gewalt, den Frauen entgegengehalten.
Ich glaube, es wird eigentlich ein Theater aufgeführt und dann schaut man, ob das in den Kategorien des bürgerlichen Trauerspiels funktioniert. Und wenn nicht, dann ist irgendwas komisch, und zwar bei dem Opfer. Er sagt noch weiter. Und da kommen wir schon fast an diese KI Nähe, dass nämlich wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse vielleicht mal mit aufgegriffen werden und dass man mit dieser allgemeinen Lebensweise gar nicht so weit kommt.
Ich glaube, dass da die Rolle der Politik nicht sein kann, Regeln aufzustellen, wer recht hat. Ich meine, das ist am Ende immer eine Frage, die sehr mit Fingerspitzen Gefühle meint. Aber es kann schon eine Menge helfen, wenn man sensibilisiert. Wie gesagt, bereits im Studium finde ich das Thema anstelle von zum Beispiel Urkundfälschung und anderen schweren Straftaten, die wir also in Extenso büffeln müssen. Und es kann auch helfen, wenn man insgesamt im Dialog mit Polizeibehabten, mit Richterinnen und Richtern daran arbeitet, auch ein bisschen Dinge zu enttabuisieren, entmystifizieren, vielleicht mehr in Dialog mit der Wissenschaft zu kommen. Weil am Ende entscheiden immer diese Erfahrungs-Sätze, also diese Vorstellungen, die man im Kopf hat, von was macht Sinn und was macht nicht. Und wenn man das ein bisschen kontern kann, mit wissenschaftlich seriösen Vorstellungen, statt so Mythen, das wäre, glaube ich, das Beste.
Ich war ja, habe ich ja kurz angesprochen, in einem kleinen Auto-Unfall verwickelt, bei dem ich dann eine Zeugenaussage machen musste gegenüber einem Polizeibeamten, der mir gegenüber einfach als Richter auftrat. Mir sagte, wer hier überhaupt nur schuldig sein kann und so weiter. Und ich soll jetzt mal nicht hier und so. Das wäre alles kompliziert. Und da denke ich mir, ja, also ich war wirklich, also ich saß schon in einem Auto, das einen Unfall hatte, aber ich war im Grunde Zuschauer einer Situation. Wenn ich da jetzt emotional in meiner Intimsphäre betroffen wäre und das wäre mein Polizeikontakt, wäre das vielleicht sogar noch schlimmer als die Tate. Also zu erleben, wie man danach ausgeliefert ist. Von daher, ja, das sind alles riesige Baustellen, die alle nicht, also in keinem guten Zustand sind.
Ja, aber jedenfalls kann man ja sehr konkret über diese Dinge reden und muss sich gar nicht in irgendwelche abstrakten Kämpfe hineinbegeben, sondern muss sich jetzt konkret ansehen, was muss verbessert werden und wo ist dann auch jetzt gerade natürlich ein politisches Interesse da, vieles zu verschlimmen, besser, weil man sagt, ja wunderbar, das ist doch ein willkommener Anlass für, da muss man natürlich dann sehr vorsichtig sein, dass man da keine falschen Freunde mit dabeinnimmt, mit dazuholt, um das eigentliche gute Anliegen dann durch schlechte Politik zu unterminieren.
Die heutige Episode wird präsentiert von Incogni. Das ist ein virtuelles, digitales, irgendwie unscheinbares Produkt, das ich aber aus eigener Anschauung empfehlen möchte. Ich bin nämlich selbst seit langem Kunde. Worum geht's? Wir alle hinterlassen im Internet Spuren, Namen, Adressen, Telefonnummern, Geburtsdaten. Das alles liegt dann irgendwo da draußen auf Seiten, von denen wir noch nie gehört haben. Und das ist nicht bloß unangenehm, sondern das ist ein echtes Sicherheitsrisiko. Identitätsdiebstahl, Betrugsversuche, Mahnungen für Verträge, die man nie abgeschlossen hat, Konten, die in deinem Namen eröffnet werden. Das passiert Leuten, die denken, ihnen kann das nicht passieren. Und es fängt fast immer damit an, dass persönliche Daten frei verfügbar im Netz herumliegen. Und jetzt ist ja so. Die Datenschutzgrundverordnung nervt uns alle im Alltag ein wenig. Wir klicken endlos Cookie-Banner hier, Einwilligungsdialoge da. Aber sie hat uns ein wichtiges Recht gegeben, das die meisten von uns nie nutzen, das Recht auf vergessen werden. Wir haben einen rechtlichen Anspruch darauf, dass die eigenen Daten aus dem Netz entfernt werden. Das Problem ist nur, diesen Anspruch selbst durchzusetzen, bei Dutzenden oder Hunderten von Seiten. Das ist kompliziert. Incogni schickt mir also monatlich Berichte, aus welchen Datenbanken ich wieder gelöscht wurde. Deren Namen habe ich, so wie sie mir aufgezählt werden, alle noch nie gehört und ihr kennt sie sicherlich auch nicht. Und genau da hilft euch Incogni. Incogni kennt die dunkle Seite des Netzes und setzt dein Recht dort für dich durch. Man bekommt also regelmäßig Updates. Hier wurde etwas entfernt, dort läuft ein Auftrag auf Löschung. Was ich besonders gut finde, ist das Feature Custom Removal. Man kann neben den großen Datenbanken, die dort automatisch gelistet sind, nämlich noch ganz gezielt bestimmte Seiten angeben, auf denen man seine eigenen Informationen gefunden hat und von denen man runter will.
Also die DSGVO gibt dir das Recht und Incogni sorgt dafür, dass es auch tatsächlich passiert. Wenn ihr das ausprobieren wollt, geht auf incogni.com 20er und gebt den Code 20er ein. Damit bekommt ihr 60% Rabatt auf den Jahrestarif. Nochmal incogni.com 20er Code 20er. Der Link ist auch in der Episodenbeschreibung. Kommen wir jetzt zum Krieg im Iran, beziehungsweise wir sprechen jetzt konkret über die Auswirkungen. Hier, es sind enorme Energiepreise schon jetzt. Gerade wenn man zur Tankstelle fährt, dann sieht man das direkt. Wir können nur ahnen, wohin die Richtung geht. Wenn es tatsächlich dazu kommt, dass Trump Bodentruppen entsendet, dann wird das noch sehr lange weitergehen.
Die sind schon unterwegs?
Die sind schon unterwegs. Wir werden sehen, wohin uns das führt. Ich habe tatsächlich den Eindruck, wir schlittern in eine katastrophale Weltwirtschaftskrise hinein. Es ist erstaunlich still momentan gerade noch. Es gibt mahnende Töne, aber es ist noch alles relativ ruhig. Wir reden noch viel über Tankpreise und Tankrabatte und so etwas. Aber wir sind da sehr schnell bei einer ganz anderen Dimension. Wenn man es global sieht, dann sowieso. Wir haben von Welthungerhilfen schon Berechnungen, wie viele Millionen Hungernde es mehr geben wird, dadurch, dass kein Dünger geliefert wird, dadurch, dass Energie so teuer ist, dass sich viele Länder das dann nicht mehr leisten können. Und wir reichen, wir kaufen dann den Markt leer. Also das, was noch da ist, wir werden es mit realen Knappheiten zu tun haben und nicht einfach nur mit ein bisschen Spekulation. Es sieht dramatisch aus.
Aber jetzt sagst du, die mahnende Stimmen sind nicht da. Also mir geht es ja bei solchen Sachen immer so, das schlägt sich ja mal zuerst auf den Energiepreis nieder. Der mir so ein bisschen egal ist, weil ich nie tanken fahre. Ich hab ja kein Auto, kein Führerschein und so weiter. Ich bin ja da mehr so Zuschauer. Und ich sehe aber auf Instagram Christine Lagarde. Und ich kriege wirklich Schauder, wenn ich den Tonfall auch höre, wie sie da sagt, was jetzt droht. Und das schlägt für mich wirklich das komplette Fernsehprogramm. Also ein Clip, eine Minute Christine Lagarde ist für mich Alarmstoff rot.
Was ich damit meine, ist, also genau, ich habe diesen Clip auch gesehen von Christine Lagarde und habe auch anderes dieser Art gesehen, international. Was ich nicht begreife, ist, wir haben da jemanden sitzen, sie kennt sich aus, sie kann das sehr gut antizipieren, was passieren könnte. Und sie muss, das wissen wir ja auch, sich immer noch sehr vorsichtig ausdrücken, weil sie EZB-Chefin ist. Also könnte sie völlig frei reden, würden wir nochmal einen ganz anderen Ton wahrscheinlich hören. Also wir müssen das ja immer dann noch ein paar Schippen drauflegen. Aber selbst so ist schon gruselig.
Ja, wirklich dramatisch.
So. Zugleich haben wir in Deutschland eine Debatte. Wir kommen ja dann noch dazu, dass es vielleicht eine gute Idee wäre, jetzt mal die Mehrwertsteuer um zwei Prozent zu erhöhen. Also dann hat man ja wirklich den Knall nicht gehört. Also wir könnten auf einen extremen Preisschock zusteuern mit der entsprechenden Inflation, dann mit all dem, was wir schon haben, wieder die Zinsen nach oben. Da werden ja auch dann wieder die alten, nicht funktionierenden Rezepte noch einmal neu ausgegraben. All das werden wir erleben. Und dann sagt man, es wäre eigentlich ein guter Zeitpunkt, jetzt mal die Mehrwertsteuer zu erhöhen. Also wir hatten ja Zeitpunkte, in denen man sagte, es ist dramatisch, wir senken mal für eine Weile die Mehrwertsteuer. Und jetzt in der Krise sagt man, es wäre vielleicht eine gute Idee, sie zu erhöhen. Und das meine ich damit, dass offenbar der Knall bei vielen noch nicht angekommen ist. Und damit meine ich vor allem die, die regieren. Ich will einen Clip spielen von Claudia Kempfert, die zum fossilen Wirtschaften befragt wird zur Energiekrise. Wir hören da mal rein.
Ja, wir müssen deutlich energieeffizienter werden. Der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien gehört da ganz zentral dazu. Und es rächt sich in der Tat, dass wir über Jahre die Branche nicht gut behandelt haben, dass die Rahmenbedingungen schlecht geworden sind, viele Arbeitsplätze verloren gegangen sind. Und wir jetzt eben auch abhängig sind von den Weltmärkten. Die Lieferkettenproblematiken sehen wir jetzt sehr, sehr akut. Also das war tatsächlich ein Fehler. Wir zahlen jetzt den Preis der verschleppten Energiewende in vielerlei Hinsicht, nicht nur aufgrund der hohen Preise für fossile Energie, sondern eben auch aufgrund der Tatsache, dass die Branchen der erneuerbaren Energien, dass es denen schlecht geht, dass wir Arbeitsplätze verloren haben und auch weiter verlieren. Da sind wir im internationalen Wettbewerb nicht mehr ganz vorne mit dabei. Und das muss sich dringend ändern. Also da brauchen wir dringend ein Umsteuern. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir ein Notfall, ein Boosterprogramm machen jetzt für die erneuerbaren Energien, damit wir da wieder schnellstmöglich rauskommen.
Ja, das war bei Phoenix. Wir hören Sie jetzt beim Deutschlandfunk nochmal.
Aber wir brauchen Solarenergie auf möglichst allen Dächtern. Und das wird schnell wie möglich. Das ist die einzige Freiheitsenergie, das haben wir ja gelernt, die es gibt. Gesicherte Freiheit und Frieden. Und deswegen muss man da auch schneller werden. Und alles dafür tun, damit das passiert. Und diese Bremsen dann auch wirklich gelockert werden. Und wir schnell vorwärts kommen.
Ja, diese beiden Ausschnitte der Ökonomin Claudia Kemfert sind alt. Das sind gar keine neuen Clips, die ich hier gespielt habe. Sondern das waren Clips aus dem Jahr 2022. Und das sind Clips, die entstanden sind im Zuge des Krieges in der Ukraine. Aber wir merken, wenn jetzt Claudia Kemfert heute eine Anfrage bekommt, kann sie eigentlich denen sagen, spielt einfach das Interview von vier Jahren noch mal.
Ich meine, 2022 ist für sich schon 20 Jahre, nachdem wir hier Weltmarktführer in Solar und Windkraft waren, alles verspielt. Also das ist halt diese Idee von Zukunft, dass man mal in einer Gegenwart gelebt hat, bei der es hieß, in 25 Jahren werdet ihr angstvoll bibernd in Deutschland sitzen, weil euch ein bisschen Gas fehlt. Das hätte man sich 2002 nicht vorstellen können. Die Zukunft war anders geschrieben.
Und dann hat man 2022 diesen Schock in mehrfacher Hinsicht, hat wirklich flächendeckend, genau diese Stimmen, Claudia Kemfert ist ja nur eine von sehr, sehr vielen, die sagen, jetzt ist es wirklich an der Zeit zu erkennen, dass radikal ausgebaut werden muss. Und das passiert dann nicht in radikaler Weise. Was macht man damals, als es akut ist? Nun, man versucht es mit Katar.
Für all das begleitet den Minister eine große Wirtschaftsdelegation.
Ja, die große Wirtschaftsdelegation ist dabei. Wir wissen noch, Robert Habeck reist nach Katar. Wir haben ja gehört einen Tagesschaubericht vom 21.3.2022. Dort sind auch die Vertreter von RWE und ThyssenKrupp. Die sagen Folgendes zu dieser neuen Allianz mit Katar.
Die Region und Katar sind ganz besonders. Sie sind ein extrem wichtiger Standort für Energielieferung für die ganze Welt und damit natürlich auch für Europa. Da wir in Deutschland diversifizieren wollen, wird die Bedeutung sicher noch mal zunehmen.
Ich denke, das ist der Aufbau von einer intensiveren Beziehung zwischen Katar und Deutschland.
Das kann man ja noch sagen, wenn man sagt, wir mussten da mal ganz schnell eine Brücke schaffen. Aber das stimmt ja gar nicht, dass wir da ganz schnell eine Brücke geschaffen haben. Denn noch ist ja gar nichts angekommen, dazu kommen wir gleich. Das heißt, es war ja nicht so, dass man dorthin gereist ist und konnte gleich im Kanister irgendwas mitnehmen oder jetzt wurden dann die Schiffe losgeschickt. Das ist ja nicht der Fall. Schon damals sagten ja die Menschenrechtsorganisationen wie Amnesty International, das ist vielleicht kurzfristig machbar, aber keine wirklich gute Idee. Habeck konterte dann damals so.
In allen Gesprächen habe ich das Thema Arbeitsbedingungen, Menschenrechte, Schutz vor Ausbeutung angesprochen. Und die katharische Seite hat gesagt, wir erstens wissen, dass wir da was tun müssen. Es ist inakzeptabel, dass Menschen hier in Armut leben und ausgebeutet werden.
Ja, wir wissen, das spricht man so an und dann verpufft das wieder. Hier ist es auch für mich noch mal entscheidend zu sagen, mir geht es jetzt nicht darum zu sagen, Habeck hat das alles da falsch gemacht. Sondern ich würde sagen, Habeck ist einfach der typische Vertreter des Politikers, der sagt, deutscher Standort.
Ich glaube, wir müssen es ab sofort viel deutlicher machen, immer sowas. Wir dürfen es nicht einfach nur andeuten. Robert Habeck hat, nachdem Jürgen Trittin die Vorarbeit geleistet hat und Merkel alles eingerissen hat mit Peter Altmaier und Dietmar Gabriel als Wirtschaftsminister, wieder versucht anzuknüpfen in einer Stresssituation, in der völlig klar war, aus seiner Sicht, absolut nachvollziehbar, wir müssen hier einen Brückenschlag machen. Das ist Brückentechnologie. Und das ist was substanziell anderes, als wenn Katharina Reiche heute sagt, wir müssen grundsätzlich Gaskraftwerke überall hinbauen. Ja. Und so. Ja, also diese... Das ist so dramatisch, was wir hier erleben. Das ist unglaublich eigentlich. Das ist Deutschland und unserem Selbstverständnis und auch unserem politischen Kompetenzzuschreibung, die wir immer einfach so machen. Wir kommen nachher nochmal drauf. Wirklich nicht würdig, nicht angemessen, was wir hier gerade erleben. Von daher, Robert Habeck ist schon dafür entschuldigt, dass einfach ein halbes Jahr nachdem die Fortschrittskoalition mit sehr guten Sachen im Koalitionsvertrag, und man muss sie ausdrücklich dafür loben, dass zumindest der Koalitionsvertrag gut war, weil nicht mal das haben wir gerade.
Nee, der ist schlecht.
Mit Merz und Reiche und so. Dass man hier dann notgedrungen, wie du sagtest, das Autokratenportfolio etwas vergrößern musste. Schon allein, weil Robert Habeck schon gemerkt hat, parallel dazu dann später den Deutschen zu sagen, ihr müsst jetzt wirklich mal eine neue Heizung, also wenn ihr eine neue Heizung kauft, dann bitte so eine, weil es ja einfach Magie ist. Und er wahrscheinlich schon geahnt hat, dass es nicht geht, dass die Deutschen da nicht mitziehen, sie wollen ihr Gas, sie wollen ihr Öl. Also sorgt man jetzt für Sicherheit und kauft halt kurzfristig was rein.
Mit der Heizung war das dann auch noch so, dass ja Förderungen einfach auch ausgefallen sind. Und ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Das hat auch dann Habeck versammelt, indem er nicht die entsprechenden finanziellen Anreize dafür bot, weil niemand sagte, ich gebe mal 10, 15.000 Euro mehr aus. Ich bin jetzt 60 Jahre alt und dann gebe ich 15.000 Euro mehr aus für eine Heizung. Also die amortisiert sich für mich nicht mehr.
Das würde ich auch nicht machen. Aber weißt du, was heute dafür sorgt, dass die Wärmepumpe die am meisten verkaufte Heizung ist? Genau diese staatlichen Anreize, diese Zuschüsse, die durch Habeck eingeführt wurden, die man reiche Hände ringend abgerungen hat. Bitte bleiben sie dabei. Sie können nicht schon wieder als CDU eine ganze Wirtschaftssektion, nämlich Wärmepumpe Magie, einfach abwürgen. Von daher war nicht gut kommuniziert.
Nur hätte man ja einfach von der Ampelregierung auf Erneuerbare viel stärker setzen können. Das hat man nicht gemacht. Also man macht es natürlich, man machte es besser als die Regierung jetzt. Das fällt ja auch nicht schwer. Aber wenn man jetzt bedenkt, wie sehr man, und da waren ja doch die Grünen sehr stark daran beteiligt, eine Front gegen China aufmachte, wo man hätte günstig Photovoltaik importieren können, da merkt man schon, also das war dann vielleicht doch gar nicht nur so als Brücke gedacht häufig, sondern man sagte also mit den Chinesen aber auf keinen Fall, man hätte aber jetzt mit diesen Photovoltaikanlagen auf dem Dach diese Freiheit, von der Claudia Kämpfer da anfangs gesprochen hat. Die ARD-Korrespondentin Julie Kurz wird dann auch zu diesem Beitrag über Habeck im Katar befragt.
Auch so, dass wir ja Flüssiggas einkaufen wollen, wir aber in Deutschland noch gar kein Flüssiggasterminal haben. Das soll ja erst geplant werden in Brunsbüttel, das wird wahrscheinlich zwei Jahre dauern, bis überhaupt in Betrieb genommen werden kann. Also so ganz schnell wird das sicherlich nichts werden.
Sagt sie 2022, das wird so etwa zwei Jahre dauern. Jetzt hören wir einen Bericht vom 29.11.2022, wir sind also schon ein halbes Jahr später. Tagesschau wieder.
Weil Deutschland dringend Gas benötigt, um ausbleibende Lieferungen aus Russland zu ersetzen, will Katar jetzt mit flüssig Erdgas einspringen. Die Lieferungen sollen im Jahr 2026 beginnen. Ein Vertrag sieht Mengen von jährlich zwei Millionen Tonnen LNG vor und das für mindestens 15 Jahre. Abgewickelt werden soll der Deal über das US-Unternehmen Conoco Phillips. Geliefert werden soll nach Brunsbüttel.
Wir haben uns also dann interessante Abhängigkeiten begeben, nämlich das wird dann auch noch über US-Konzernen laufen. 2026 wird da gesagt. Man hat also schon gesehen, es dauert alles ein bisschen länger. Wir hören jetzt aus diesem Tagesschaubericht vom November 2022, wie ein Energieexperte gefragt wird.
Und wie groß ist aus Ihrer Sicht die Gefahr, politisch erpressbar zu werden bei den Energielieferungen aus Russland? War die Gefahr ja zu lange ignoriert worden?
Wir haben hier natürlich den wesentlichen Unterschied, dass wir von Russland vor allem über Pipelinesysteme verbunden wurden. Die sind naturgemäß etwas starrer als LNG-Lieferungen. Das heißt, auch wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Lieferungen aus Katar ausfallen sollten, ist es natürlich den Kapazitätsinhammern an diesem LNG-Terminal, zum Beispiel in Blutsbüttel, diese Mengen auch anderweitig zu beschaffen, beispielsweise aus den USA oder eben aus anderen Regionen der Welt. Dafür gibt es einen weltweiten LNG-Markt, an dem man sich dann bedienen kann.
Sagt Sebastian Gulbis vom Energieberatungsunternehmen Enervis. Herr Gulbis, vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Tja, jetzt erleben wir aber die Straße von Hormus ist nicht so befahrbar. Amerika verdient gerade sehr viel Geld damit, das teuer zu verkaufen. Da hören wir gleich noch kurz Isabella Weber. Die Abhängigkeit ist also groß. Es ist gewiss nicht so starr wie mit den Pipelines aus Russland. Aber wir sehen, okay, wenn eine reale Knappheit da ist, dann geht es trotzdem, läuft es darauf hinaus, dass man in enormen Abhängigkeiten ist, die so stark sind, dass die Wirtschaft ja so überhaupt nicht in Gang kommen kann, sondern wir eher wieder in eine tiefe Krise reinschlittern. Das heißt also, diese Idee, man diversifiziert und wird dann wirklich unabhängig, die stimmt einfach nicht, wenn man bei fossilen Energien pleiht. Das ist so. Wir hören jetzt die Tagesschau, wir springen jetzt weit vor, November 25. Katharina Reiche.
Auf ihrer Reise will Wirtschaftsministerin Reiche vor allem potenzielle Investoren anlocken. Denn anders als Deutschland verzeichnen die Emirate gerade ein immenses Wirtschaftswachstum. Von diesem Aufschwung will auch Deutschland profitieren. Reiche wird deshalb von gut 20 Unternehmensvertretern begleitet. Mithilfe der Ministerin sollen die vor Ort wertvolle Kontakte knüpfen und wenn möglich gute Verträge abschließen. Bei den politischen Gesprächen dürfte es vor allem in Katar dann auch um wichtige Gaslieferungen gehen. Das Land hatte noch vor wenigen Wochen mit einem Lieferstopp von Flüssiggas nach Europa gedroht. Sollte die EU ihre strengen Importauflagen zur Nachhaltigkeit nicht abschwächen. Welche Folgen diese Drohung hat, kann die Ministerin nun direkt vor Ort klären. Aus Abu Dhabi, Yannick Pence.
Das hatten wir auch ganz vergessen. Dass also Katar jetzt plötzlich schon noch lange vor dem Krieg Deutschland gedroht hat. Ihr habt aber viel zu hohe Umweltauflagen. Und da ist Katharina Reiche natürlich gerne dabei, nochmal nachzuschärfen bzw. zu lockern. Also wir sehen auch hier die Brückentechnologie oder die Brücke zur erneuerbaren Energie. Die ist eine, die es schmutzig gerne machen will. Und wir sehen diese Abhängigkeit, dass die sagen, wenn ihr das nicht ändert, dann machen wir das und das. Und da sind wir noch gar nicht beim Krieg. Und wir sind auch noch nicht beim Krieg. Am 4. Februar 2026, wir hören jetzt einen Beitrag von NDR Info. Es geht um Brunnsbüttel.
Hier soll ein 16 Meter tiefes Becken ausgehoben werden, eine sogenannte Liegewanne. Damit Tanker wie diese hier anlegen können. Um die 100.000 Tonnen Schlamm und Schlick fallen dann an, die entsorgt werden müssen. Wie, das war lange Zeit die Frage. Die German LNG Terminal GmbH und das Wasserstraßen Schifffahrtsamt sind sich nun einig, das Baggergut wird Richtung Helgoland transportiert und dort verklappt. Wie auch schon der Hafenschlick aus Hamburg. German LNG und das WSA haben entsprechende Verträge gerade erst unterschrieben.
Man braucht natürlich in Deutschland, und das ist ja auch richtig und gut so, das ist also jetzt der Herr von LNG Deutschland. Genehmigung, um Baggergut in der Nordsee zu verbringen. Eine der Voraussetzungen ist rein operativ, dass man eine Nutzungsvereinbarung mit dem entsprechenden Amt schließt. Das ist in unserem Fall das Wasserstraßen- und Schifffahrtsamt. Und das haben wir jetzt in den letzten Tagen dingfest gemacht.
Das allein reicht aber nicht. Für die Genehmigung muss German LNG ein weiteres Dokument vorlegen. Einen Plan für die Überwachung der Verklappung, denn die ist umstritten. Denn hier, 1500 Meter vom geplanten Terminal entfernt, wurde bereits gebaggert. Und das Baggergood bei Helgoland verklabt. Das ist mit Stickstoff, Phosphor und Schwermetallen belastet. Mit Folgen für das Wattenmeer.
Es würden Schadstoffe freigesetzt, die den schlechten Zustand der Nordsee weiter beeinträchtigen würden. Es würden Nährstoffe freigesetzt, die eben zu einer Eigenblüte führen können. Und Eigenblüte bedeutet, dass dann große Eigenteppiche an die Küste geschwemmt werden.
Diese Bedenken teilten die Behörden aber nicht. Vom Umweltministerium wurde auf der Grundlage detaillierter Antragsunterlagen ein fachliches Einvernehmen erteilt. Nach Angaben von German LNG sollen die Baggerarbeiten hier im Herbst beginnen. Eigene Bodenproben hätten keine Belastung ergeben. Bis zu 10 Milliarden Kubikmeter Erdgas sollen von hier aus ins Netz eingeschweißt werden. Mehr als 10 Prozent des prognostizierten Gasbedarfs. Im kommenden Jahr soll das Terminal den Betrieb aufnehmen.
Wir sind also inzwischen im Jahr 2027 angekommen dann, wenn das alles funktioniert. Wir sehen also diese kurzfristige Sache mit Katar ist dann doch eine sehr langfristige Sache und auch keine besonders umweltfreundliche. Und jetzt kommt der Krieg.
Ja, aber da wurde ja gesagt, 15 Jahre ab 2026.
Ja.
Also 22. Von daher, für mich ist in Sachen riesige Energieinfrastrukturen so 15 Jahre immer noch Brückentechnologie. Denn das ist ja von 2010 bis 2025 so.
Ja, aber ich denke einfach daran, wie schnell China von Jahr zu Jahr Solar- und Windkraft ausbaut und denke, wo sind hier die Windkraftanlagen und wo sind die Solaranlagen. Also da geht es ja wesentlich schneller mit. Also wir reden ja jetzt hier von einem Planungszeitraum von fünf Jahren und jetzt kommt dummerweise der Iran-Krieg und sorgt dafür, dass zum Beispiel diese weltgrößte Anlage für verflüssigtes Erdgas im katarischen Ras Lafan nach Angaben des Betreibers schwer beschädigt wurde. Und das bedeutet, dass Qatar Energy mit einem Umsatzverlust von 20 Milliarden Dollar rechnet. Die Reparatur, wie lange dauert die? Was schätzt du?
Sieben Jahre?
Kürzer, drei bis fünf Jahre.
Und die zwei wurden auch nie in Betrieb genommen und zehn Jahre lang gebaut.
Ja, ja. Also wir haben hier nur so Zahlen. Wenn wir sehen, was alles betroffen ist durch diese Angriffe, dann sehen wir, okay, das betrifft Flüssiggas, Helium. Helium ist wiederum wichtig für die Chip-Herstellung. Die Erdgaspreise sind ja ruckzuck um 25 Prozent nach oben geschossen. Eigentlich soll ja jährlich bis zu zwei Millionen tollen Flüssig-Erdgas geliefert werden aus Katar. Aber das steht jetzt wirklich in den Sternen. Interessant ist ja auch nochmal diese Meldung, die jetzt kam, dass ab 2027 die EU den Import von Gas aus Russland vollständig verbietet. Also dann sieht man ja auch, wie lange wir da eine Abhängigkeit hatten. Hier eine Tagesschau-Meldung. Die EU will bis spätestens Ende 2027 vollkommen unabhängig von russischem Erdgas sein. Das sieht eine Einigung zwischen Vertretern der Regierung, der Mitgliedstaaten und des Europaparlamentes vor. Demnach soll die Einfuhr von russischem Gas über Pipelines auf Grundlage von langfristigen Verträgen bis spätestens 1. November 2027 komplett eingestellt werden. Das heißt, so lange ist noch diese Abhängigkeit die ganze Zeit da, während gerade die neue Abhängigkeit, die entstehen wird, schon zerbricht durch den Krieg im Iran.
Ja, ist alles sehr merkwürdig.
Ich will einfach, dass jetzt eine Million Solaranlagen von Mai bis Juni installiert sind. Ja, also wir können jetzt nicht darüber reden, ja, wir warten mal da und so weiter zu. Also wir haben ja hier von dem Betreiber von Qatar Energy die Nachricht, ja, das wird so drei bis fünf Jahre dauern, dann ist doch damit der Tropf gelutscht.
Also dass wir diese Solaranlagen nicht bauen, nicht installieren, sind ja schon gebaut, ist ja totale Überproduktion in China.
Ja, man muss sie kaufen.
Ja, und es kostet dann im laufenden Betrieb vier Cent pro Kilowattstunde, unschlagbarer Preis. Also man muss sich echt nochmal diese Kräfte anschauen, die dafür sorgen, dass wir weiter für 38 Cent pro Kilowattstunde oder mehr da einfach Quatsch machen. Es ist nicht zu verstehen, außer mit großer Obskurität beim Publikum. Und nee, dann verlasse ich mich lieber auf die Wirtschaftskompetenz von Friedrich Merz. Der wird schon dafür sorgen, dass und ja, und dann ein Öllaster halt alle zwei Jahre kommt und die Bude vollpumpt. Es ist einfach alles sehr ungut.
Wir hören kurz Isabella Weber. Die schätzt bei Tilo Jung die Situation so ein.
Das globalen Ölverbrauch geht durch die Straße von Humus. Also all das ist jetzt sozusagen erstmal nicht mehr auf dem Markt. Und insofern sind die USA jetzt der Producer of last resort. Also sozusagen diejenigen, die weiter produzieren können. Und wenn die Preise enorm hochgehen und ich nicht mehr produzieren kann, dann hab ich natürlich nichts davon. Aber wenn die Preise enorm hochgehen und ich weiter produzieren kann, dann bin ich eben ganz vorne mit dabei. Und tatsächlich hat Trump das auch schon gesagt.
Die Frage ist nur, wie lange geht diese Rechnung von Trump auf? Denn mag sein, dass die jetzt gerade damit viel Geld verdienen können. Aber wenn jetzt im Ganzen die Weltwirtschaft schwächelt, dann ist das auch ein Problem für die KI-Blase, die ja doch bitte weiter bestehen soll, all das. Deswegen sind auch diese kurzfristigen Gewinne durch Inside-Handel, wie gesagt, nur kurzfristig. Noch einmal Isabella Weber.
Dass sie sozusagen von den Profiten, die von dem tatsächlichen Verkauf von Öl profitieren, sondern wir haben auch gesehen, dass es unregelmäßige Geschäfte auf den Ölmärkten gab, als Trump gesagt hat, dass er auf einen schnellen Friedensdeal hinarbeitet und dann die Ölpreise erst mal kurzfristig nach unten geschnellt sind. Und dann sozusagen kurz bevor das passiert ist, gab es eine sehr große Transaktion auf dem Ölmarkt. Man weiß nicht, wer es gewesen ist, aber es muss irgendjemand gewesen sein, der eben Insiderinformationen hatte und wusste, dass dieser Post von Trump kommen muss, weil es einfach komplett, also eine ganz eindeutige Unregelmäßigkeit ist, die Bloomberg auch in Analysen zum Beispiel dargelegt hat. Was würde ich sagen?
War das Barron oder Melania?
Das ist einer der größten Mysterien für mich. Ich habe auch die CNN-Grafik gesehen mit den Ausschlägen an Handelsvolumen durch faktische, was weiß ich, die Versicherungen werden teurer, die Schiffe werden echt beschossen, Fotos gehen rum und so weiter. Dann gibt es diesen einen Peak einfach 15 Minuten vor Trumps Ansage. Und der Peak ist aber halb so hoch wie ein echter Ausschlag durch die ganze Welt, das ist jetzt in Gefahren so. Und wieso weiß man nicht, wer das war? Wie kann man denn so und so viele Milliarden in einem Trade, also das sind doch Kontonummern.
Ja, also da gibt es ja Klarnamen.
Genau, sonst geht es ja nicht. Das Geld muss ja ausgezahlt werden. Die Clearing-Stelle weiß doch, wohin sie das Geld überwiesen. Das ist mir völlig unklar, wie alle so rumrätseln können. Und auch jemand einfach das macht und weiß, bleibt geheim. Also es ist wirklich crazy.
Es geht eigentlich nur, wenn man offenbar mit Behörden zusammenarbeitet, die dann auch gespürt sind.
Da muss man Ansagen an Behörden machen, was jetzt nicht gewusst werden darf.
Ja, also anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, wie das gehen soll.
Das ist ganz crazy.
Du bist ja ein Fan der CO2-Bepreisung. Du hast hier manchmal gesagt, genau, man könnte es ja mal genauso machen, wenn die FDP sich in ihrem Programm auf die CO2-Bepreisung zielt, dann sollte man es wirklich mal so machen, nämlich was es kostet. Aber wir haben ja gesehen, mit der CO2-Bepreisung ist das so eine Sache, nämlich immer dann, wenn die Preise hochgehen, dann sagt man, naja, jetzt ist der CO2-Preis aber schlecht, jetzt dürfen wir die Industrie nicht abwürgen und so. Isabella Weber ist da auch sehr skeptisch und ich bin ja auch nie ein großer Fan gewesen, weil ich immer sagte, naja, es gibt ja politische Macht.
Dadurch, mich hier so ins Feuer stellt. Ich möchte anmerken, wie die Pointe war. Gut, denn im Koalitionsvertrag für die Ampel, also im Wahlprogramm der FDP vor der Ampelwahl, als sie wussten, wir sind hier gegen die Grünen aufgestellt und es hat sich bei den Erstwählern dann auch gezeigt, 50-50, hat die FDP nur eine halbe Seite Klimapolitik reingeschrieben und hat einfach gesagt, dieser Handel mit den Zertifikaten ist es. Daraufhin kamen Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und haben durchgerechnet, ja, man kann das durchaus so machen, aber dann...
Wäre aber dann fünfmal so hoch.
Ja, fünfmal ist schön. Also wir wissen ja, wo wir eingestiegen sind, so bei 20 Euro, 50 Euro. Und dort wären so 680 Euro oder so fällig gewesen. Ich habe mich darüber lustig gemacht, indem ich gesagt habe, das machen wir jetzt all in. Ja, soll doch die FDP merken, was das bedeutet, wenn man den Leuten einfach sagt, Liter Benzin 7 Euro.
Jetzt kannst du es spielen.
Das Problem ist natürlich, dass man, wenn man sich nur darauf verlässt, die Dinge teurer zu machen und damit die politische Unterstützung für eine grüne Transformation verliert und damit letztlich vielleicht auch dazu beiträgt, dass so eine Partei wie die AfD stärker wird, man letztlich sozusagen die politische Basis, die man braucht, um so eine Transformation umsetzen zu können, mit dem Instrumentarium, das man an Land bringt, unterwandert. Und das ist natürlich nicht besonders nachhaltige Transformation strategisch.
Mir scheint das ein völlig falsches Konzept gewesen zu sein, um das hier ganz klar zu sagen, wenn ich das nochmal hier höre, wenn ich sehe, welcher politischer Druck entsteht, wenn die Preise etwas steigen, dass man glaubte, man könne das über diese Art des Zertifikatehandels, also einer künstlichen Verknappung durch den Preis schaffen, dass damit eine Klimatransformation stattfindet, wo man ja die andere Möglichkeit hätte des investierenden Staates, der einfach sagt, hier ist die billige Energie, greif zu. So wie man ja auch im Supermarkt die Alternativen kaufen kann. Sie stehen einfach da, man nimmt sie aus dem Regal, wo diese aber noch nicht da sind. Man sagt, wir erhöhen den Preis, versuchen so, dass die Leute energieeffizienter werden, auch die Unternehmen energieeffizienter werden. Und dann kann man darüber an der Seite noch herbeiführen, so eine grüne Technologie, das halte ich für falsch. Und ich glaube, dass da diese ordoliberale Idee, dass man das über Märkte und Preise regelt, nicht funktionieren kann. Weil, wann immer der Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland in Gefahr ist, man natürlich sagt, ja, jetzt ist gerade schlecht mit dieser CO2-Bepreisung. Jetzt seien wir mal vorsichtig. Also, jetzt können wir nicht zu stark anheben. Und genauso vor Wahlen wird man immer sagen, ja, wir können jetzt nicht diese extremen Energiepreise haben. Und ich bin auch nicht für diese extremen Energiepreise, weil sie natürlich immer Druck sind, vor allem auf die, die wenig haben. Deswegen halte ich dieses Konzept für, so kann man es, glaube ich, jetzt festhalten, wirklich gescheitert. Also, das ist nicht mehr zu retten.
Ja, das sagst du und es klingt nach einer singulären Vernünft. Nur der reichste Mann der Welt, Elon Musk, ist genau damit der reichste Mann der Welt geworden. Dass er nämlich den Leuten gesagt hat, ich baue coole E-Autos. Und den Investoren hat er gesagt, für jedes E-Auto überweist mir Mercedes 50.000 Euro, weil Zertifikate handeln. Und aus Elon Musks Sicht ging das sehr gut auf. Und von daher, ja.
Wir hören noch ganz kurz Friedrich Merz. Der war hier in Frankfurt bei der FAZ.
Ich bin gar nicht hingefallen, um ihn auszubuhnen. Mein Fehler.
Berthold Kohler hat dort gesessen. Das Gespräch war denkbar uninteressant. Deswegen bringe ich jetzt insgesamt nur eine Minute daraus mit drei Clips. Es geht hier ein bisschen um den Iran. Wiederholte einfach nochmal, ne, das ist nicht unser Krieg. Aber dann, wenn Frieden ist, dann könnte man schon...
Es ist keine schlechte Ansage zu sagen, es ist nicht unser Krieg. Das hat Trump sehr geärgert.
Er hat sich aber dann relativiert, also er will gar nicht sagen, es ist nicht unser Krieg, sondern es geht uns ja schon etwas an. Aber wenn Frieden ist, dann könnte man mit der Marine natürlich schauen, ob man irgendetwas absichert. Aber erst dann, wenn Frieden ist, er ist da sehr auf Distanz geblieben, hat dafür auch Applaus auf der Bühne bekommen. Interessant fand ich, dass er dann eingegangen ist nochmal auf die Ukraine. Und da ist doch eine ganz erstaunliche Äußerung. Und wir kennen hier, wir haben sie auch abgebildet im Podcast, diese wirklich aufgekratzten Debatten zum Thema Taurus-Lieferung. Olaf Scholz, der Zögernde, wie kann er nur? Jetzt höre ich einen Friedrich Merz, der das mal gerade so loslässt.
Also man kann nun wirklich nicht behaupten, dass der Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine erfolgreich wäre. Es ist ein brutaler Stellungskrieg geworden, in dem Russland nicht weiterkommt und gleichzeitig zerstört die Ukraine zurzeit Energieversorgungsanlagen weit im Hinterland Russlands mit Raketensystemen, die sie erst während des Krieges entwickelt haben. Also zehnmal besser als Taurus und alles, was wir da früher mal diskutiert haben.
Was?
Zehnmal besser als Taurus? Ich habe von dem Rheinmetall-Chef gehört, dass da nur Hausfrauen am 3D-Druckerwaffen bauen.
Habe ich auch genauso gehört. Dafür hat er ganz schön Kritik bekommen. Aber was ist das jetzt plötzlich? Dass er sagt, die sind zehnmal besser als Taurus.
Aber das ist doch gut vermehrt. Dann ist er aus der Diskussion raus.
Ja, aber so muss man es vielleicht einfach machen. Vielleicht hätte Scholz sagen müssen, ne, die haben ja Waffen, die sind zehnmal besser als Taurus. Die brauchen das Ding gar nicht. Und damit ist das aber dann gut. Da wird auch nicht nochmal nachgefragt. Also bei Olaf Scholz, ganz monatlang nur Taurus. Und hier sagt er, die haben ja selbst da Waffen, die basteln die zusammen, die sind zehnmal besser fertig.
Vielleicht hat der Rheinmetall schafft, das so geärgert.
Möglicherweise.
Dass der Kanzler plötzlich sagt, es gibt eine Waffe zehnmal besser als Taurus.
Wir glauben das nicht so ganz. Weil es gar nicht der Taurus herstellt. Das ist Rheinmetall. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie zehnmal besser dann genau aussieht. Aber ja, das lassen wir mal so stehen.
Naja, also wir wissen alle, zehnmal besser heißt zehnmal billiger.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. März über das Kriegsende in der Ukraine.
Und ist in der Lage, bis zu 40 Prozent der russischen Energieversorgungsanlagen zu beschädigen. Also das ist schon ein bemerkenswerter Erfolg. Und ich bleibe bei meiner Einschätzung, dieser Krieg endet nicht militärisch. Nach meiner Einschätzung, ich mag mich irren, aber er wird enden, wenn Russland wirtschaftlich so erschöpft ist, dass sie ihn nicht fortsetzen können. Und die russische Wirtschaft, das Land, ist in einer denkbar schlechten Verfassung. Hohe Zinsen, hohe Schulden, Putin muss Geld einsammeln gehen bei allen möglichen Despoten auf dieser Welt.
Das Kriterium stimmt, aber der Maßstab ist halt schief. Es ist halt ein autoritäres Regime, das wie im Iran auch alles diesen Kriegszielen unterordnet.
Zumal Putin ja durch diesen Krieg im Iran gerade in einer besseren Position wieder ist, denn plötzlich ist sein Öl, ist sein Gas wieder gefragt. Hat man ja auch schon wieder Lieferungen möglich gemacht, die vorher unmöglich waren, seitens der Amerikaner, damit der Weltmarkt nicht so sehr unter Druck gerät. Das heißt, Putin kann sich ja gerade wieder bereichern dadurch. Was wir andererseits erleben, ist, dass Europa oder die europäischen Länder, die europäischen Volkswirtschaften immer weiter geschwächt werden. Und jetzt noch mal gerade so diese Kredite für die Ukraine genehmigt. Aber die Frage ist, wie lange wird das dann gehen und wie lange halten das auch die Kapitalmärkte durch, bzw. wie lange werden die Kapitalmärkte ruhig bleiben angesichts all dessen? Das heißt, diese Rechnung, die er da aufmacht, bedeutet ja auch, das Sterben geht jetzt erstmal weiter, bis wir irgendwie Russland wirtschaftlich so geschwächt haben, dass Russland sagt, wir geben auf, wir haben kein Geld mehr. Das ist eine ganz irrige Vorstellung, bei der man auch wieder sagen muss, das geht alles auf Kosten von Menschenleben. Man weiß gar nicht, was in diesen Köpfen davor geht. Deshalb ruft März dann auch nochmal uns zu und den Ukrainern.
Wir müssen das durchhalten. Und das tut mir leid. Ich weiß, dass das in der deutschen Bevölkerung auch nicht überall auf Zustimmung stößt. Aber an dieser Stelle wird sich herausstellen, ob wir bereit sind, die Freiheit Europas wirklich zu verteidigen. An dieser Stelle, das ist der Lackmustest für unsere Verteidigungsbereitschaft. Und ich bin entschlossen, das so lange wie es geht auch aufrechtzuerhalten.
Also er ist dafür, dass die Ukrainer weiterhin ihren Kopf hinhalten. Da ist er ganz fest entschlossen. Das ist eigentlich die Aufsage, die er hier trifft. Kommen wir zur Innenpolitik.
Innenpolitik. Es gab Wahlen. Und ich will es ganz pedantisch machen. Also nicht, dass es Wahlen gab, sondern das ist alles jetzt Pre-Talk für Lars Klingbeil hat eine Rede gehalten, die, wie ich finde, der SPD das Genick inhaltlich schon bricht. Jetzt müssen nur die Verbandsleute, die da noch was zu sagen haben, diesen Schritt auch vollziehen. Aber wir nähern uns dem langsam. Denn wir können, glaube ich, jetzt mal vorschlagen, ein Fazit oder eine Konsequenz ernst zu nehmen, die wir hier schon häufiger angesprochen haben, nämlich zu sagen, Deutschland ist gespalten in zwei Lagen. Auf der einen Seite Leute überlegen, ob sie jetzt doch noch mal SPD machen, sie dann doch nicht oder die Grünen oder die Linken oder Volt oder was auch immer. So ein irres Angebot. Hier in Frankfurt gab es ja Kommunalwahl. Da sitzen jetzt irgendwie 14, 15 Parteien oder so in diesem 93-sitzigen Stadtparlament. Also da ist es richtig bunt. Deshalb sage ich, wir müssen jetzt mal die Komplexität reduzieren, indem wir sagen, es gibt nur noch zwei Lager. Immer dieses Parteidenken ist völlig überholt. Was bedeutet, dieses Lager besteht zum einen ganz einfach aus CDU und AfD. FDP eigentlich auch noch, aber das können wir ja ein bisschen vernachlässigen, weil die sind ja nicht mehr existent.
Ich lasse dich jetzt erstmal reden und komme nachher dann mit.
Ja, wenn wir uns also die Landtagswahlen in Baden-Württemberg anschauen und sagen, es gibt dieses rechte Lager und ich mache hier nur einen Denkvorschlag. Die Leute können jetzt im Forum dann natürlich, so wie ich sage, was ich will, schreiben, was sie wollen. Aber bitte, also mich würde sehr interessieren, wie man argumentiert, dass Alexandra Dobrindt nicht bei der AfD ist oder AfD-Politik machen. Also das ist sozusagen der Test.
Dem stimme ich ganz zu. Mich wundert das auch.
In Baden-Württemberg ist also diese eine Gruppe CDU-AfD auf 48,5 Prozent bekommen, was bedeutet, die restlichen Parteien laut Wahlstimmen 47,8. Also diese Lager stehen sich auf Augenhöhe gegenüber.
Passt wie in den USA, wenn du so ein Zweiparteien-System hättest.
Genau. Da wir aber eine 5-Prozent-Hürde haben, ist es die FDP schon mal nicht, die Linke auch nicht, Freiwähler auch nicht, BSW auch nicht. Also im Parlament selbst sind es sozusagen 48,5 zu 35,7, die dann aufgefüllt werden auf die Sitze. Also klarer Überhang. In Rheinland-Pfalz, CDU, 31 Prozent, AfD, 19,5. Also da sind wir auch bei 50, quasi 50-50. Und wenn man sich diese Landtagswahlen dann anschaut im historischen Vergleich, und da kannst du jetzt mal mit einem Blick drauf werfen, weil wir ja immer so, ach, aktuell die AfD überall drückt und bald ist die Demokratie im Arsch. Also wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, ne, eine Gruppe ist CDU und AfD, dann haben wir hier so eine lila Linie. Und alles das übrigens im Forum verlinkt, für den ich da selber klicken will. Und das zweite Lager ist dann mal SPD, Grüne und Linke. Dann sehen wir, das ist jetzt eine historische Kontinuität dieser Lager. Da gab es zwar sehr große Austausche, aber man würde jetzt nicht unbedingt hier sehen, da gab es jetzt eine große Zäsur oder was auch immer, sondern ja, die CDU wurde halt geschmälert und die AfD ging hoch und die SPD und die Grünen haben sich so ein bisschen hin und her getauscht. Die Linke kam noch dazu. Nun würde ich sagen, also dass die Linke eigentlich ein Teil der SPD ist, die wurde halt von einem SPD-Chef gegründet. Da liegt es auf der Hand. Bei den Grünen würde ich sagen, ja, ein bisschen früher und dann auch sehr marginalisiert. Aber das grüne Thema ist im Grunde eins, dass bei der SPD nicht abgedeckt wurde, was den Erfolg erklärt. Und bei der AfD und der CDU halt dasselbe. So, also das ist einfach eine historische Kontinuität, dasselbe eben in Rheinland-Pfalz.
Und dann merkt man, dass diese beiden Lager mal hat das eine, mal das andere die Oberhand, wenn du das so durchgehst.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel 2016 CDU und AfD, 44,4, SPD, Grüne, Linke, 44,3. Eine Wahl später 2021, CDU, AfD, 36, SPD, Grüne, Linke, 47. Jetzt hat sich es wieder gedreht. Jetzt ist wieder CDU, AfD, bei 50, SPD, Grüne, Linke, bei 38. Also zwar schon große Sprünge, aber es ist eine Kontinuität. Also es ist einfach ein Wechsel aus hü und hot. So, und wenn man sich jetzt die Kommunalwahl anschaut, das ist in Bayern super interessant. Also wir haben zum einen, wenn wir alle zur Wahl stehenden Oberbürgermeister, Bürgermeister und Landräte jetzt nehmen und nur die CSU nehmen, also großer Überhang. Da wurden 142 von 174 oder so Ämtern bestellt. Das heißt, alle anderen kommen nicht auf Augenhöhe mit der CSU, außer man macht eine interessante Rechnung. Die findet ihr dann ganz unten. Wir nehmen jetzt nur die 25 Oberbürgermeister der kreisfreien Städte und der eigenständigen Landräte. Wir lassen also die 163 ersten Bürgermeister kreisangehöriger Gemeinden außen vor, weil die sind ja eh abhängig von. Also ist ja sozusagen, da ist ja nur politische Verwaltung, die dann noch mal so stattfindet und auch ein Wahlamt ist, aber jetzt nicht so aussagekräftig. So, und wenn man jetzt nimmt die CSU auf der einen Seite, die also 48 dieser 96, also genau 50 Prozent dieser Wahlämter besetzt hat und das vergleicht, indem man die Gruppe aus Freie Wähler, SPD, Grüne und Sonstigen nimmt, die AfD hat ja da kein Wahlamt in Bayern, kommt man auf 48, 48. Also die CSU ist schon eingeholt.
Ja, also das leuchtet mir ein, was du jetzt für die Landtagswahlen gesagt hast. Bei den Kommunalwahlen würde ich gleich da widersprechen, wo du die Freien Wähler mit hinzunimmst, denn die sind nun jetzt wirklich nicht im linken Lager.
Also ich meine, das Lagerdenken war jetzt für Rheinland-Pfalz und Baden-Württemberg. In Bayern ist es halt super interessant, dass wir, so wie wir die AfD immer als, das ist ganz gefährlich und ganz wichtig und ganz bedeutsam, ganz relevant, was da passiert. Da muss man sofort zehn Sendungen drüber machen. So ist es ja ein bisschen bei Markus Söder. Markus Söder sagt etwas, ganz wichtig. Alle müssen stramm stehen, alle müssen sich dazu verhalten.
Und die ist auch im neuen Horst Schlemmer-Film mit.
Ja, sehr gut. Das ist ja ein weiteres Aushängeschild für diesen Film. Was eben bedeutet, in Bayern, 2008, hatte die CSU damals 59 zu 37, dieser wichtigen Wahlämter.
Ah ja.
2014 waren es 62. Die CSU war sogar im Aufwind. Also wir haben hier keine große historische CSU verliert, sondern erst 2014, Markus Söder macht sich warm, übernimmt so langsam den Laden. Und dann 2020, die CSU verliert auf 57 und jetzt aktuelle, sie geht runter auf 48 dieser Wahlämter.
Dramatisch eigentlich für die CSU, was gar nicht so kommuniziert wird.
Genau, weil die CSU ist jetzt wirklich nur noch in dieser kreisabhängigen Fläche präsent, wo es im Grunde egal ist, wer regiert, wo verwaltet wird.
Wo man einfach sagt, ich will was in der Verwaltung tun, also gehe ich in die CSU.
Genau, so typischer, wie wir es mal aus den ruralen Orten in Amerika, da gibt es nur eine Partei. Also da ist einfach völlig klar, das sind halt die Komplikaner. Genau, wenn man ein Anliegen hat, das anders ist, muss man halt so rhetorisch verstecken und so weiter. Aber die CSU hat jetzt da verloren und dass sie in diesen großen Städten mittlerweile nicht nur nicht gewinnt, sondern jetzt in München, wo ja seit ewig, der Running Gag war, es ist der SPD regiert. Ja. So und das aber selbst Platz zwei dort nicht die CSU ist, sondern plötzlich jetzt ein schwuler, junger Jahrgang, 87 oder so Oberbürgermeister kommt von den Grünen, der gegen die SPD und gegen die CSU, ja natürlich, so gewinnt. Das sind schon, also für die CSU wird es wirklich eng und Markus Söder muss sich so die ein oder andere Frage jetzt einfach stellen. So, jetzt sind wir also in diesem, für die CSU sieht es nicht gut aus, sie verliert auch viel gegen die Freie Wähler, also das Argument muss man durchaus gelten lassen, wobei die Freie Wähler in der Fläche eben eine Kümmerer-Partei ist, die jetzt nicht unbedingt alle die größten Eilwanger-Fans sind, also das auch sorgt für viel Ärger, aber ich möchte, dass diese Sehgewohnheit, okay es gibt Lager und die sind auch relativ konstant und es gibt so ein progressives Lager, nehme ich natürlich die Grünen mit rein, die sind jetzt nicht zwingend immer auf so einer Hard-Linken, aber es ist nun mal nicht die CSU, nicht die CDU, nicht die AfD, das kann man ja glaube ich sagen. Unter dieser Maßgabe müssen wir jetzt diese Rede von Lars Klingbeil hören, denn da kommt einem das Schauder.
Darf ich da erst noch einhaken bei dieser Lagerbildung, das leuchtet mir erst mal ein, das so zu sehen, vor allem auch, weil es eine gewisse Gelassenheit mit sich bringt. Wir wollen ja nicht die ganze Zeit nur diese 5 vor 12 Meldungen hier abfeuern, sondern wir können einfach sagen, ach da gibt es ja Kontinuitäten, das ist ja interessant, wie sich dann manches verschiebt. Und nein, wir wollen jetzt nicht die AfD verharmlosen dadurch und wollen auch nicht die CDU im Ganzen demonisieren. Wir sehen natürlich bei der CDU, wenn man jetzt sagt, also wenn man dieses Lager jetzt denkt als Koalition, dann wissen wir natürlich, das könnte so jetzt gerade wie die CDU konstituiert ist und wie die AfD konstituiert ist nicht stattfinden. Also es gibt keine Koalition mit Wüst-Günter, CDU und einer Höcke-AfD.
Um das mal ganz klar zu sagen.
Manfred Weber und dann aber bitte mit Alice Weidel und nicht mit Höcke, weil Höcke dann doch ein bisschen problematisch ist. Also das soll jetzt nicht bedeuten, dass wir sagen, wir haben da jetzt einfach die Koalition, die es gibt, sondern man geht in dieses Lager. Mir scheint es erstmal wichtig zu sein, diese Lagerbildung zu machen, deshalb, weil wir ja gerade so aus einer links-liberalen Seite bis hin zu Mark-Uwe Kling dann in seinem Känguru-Buch, soweit geht zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal alle eingemeinten, die nicht AfD sind. Und der geht dann auch dazu, die CDU mit reinzulegen.
Das ist der große Fehler.
Und das ist der große Fehler, weil dann ist die Alternative immer die Alternative für Deutschland. Das sollte man auf keinen Fall machen. Deswegen hilft diese Lagerbildung weiter. Das Problem bei diesem linken Lager, das du da jetzt gebildet hast, aus Grün, SPD und Linke, ist natürlich, dass die sich immer schlechter, wo die Konkurrenz dann hart ist, immer schlechter miteinander ins Benehmen setzen können. Das geht jetzt so weit, dass beispielsweise ein Kevin Kühnert, der ja momentan keinen Posten zu verlieren oder gewinnen hat, auf dem Podium sitzt bei dem Stern und angesprochen wird, ob er noch immer für Rot-Rot-Grün ist, wo man ja jetzt gerade sagen müsste, ja, wenn sich eine Wirklichkeit böte, natürlich, und sagt dann als erstes, ja nee, also da sind ja auch manche Linke, die haben da mit Waffenlieferungen die ukrainienigere Schwierigkeiten. So und solange das natürlich stattfindet, und ich habe eher den Eindruck, das verschärft sich gerade, als dass es sich abschwächt, ist dieses Lager super, um zu analysieren, wie die gesamte Gesellschaft sich so bewegt, in die eine oder andere Richtung, oder auch sehr kontinuierlich sich verhält. Aber das will ich nur hier unterstreichen, damit jetzt nicht so Leute sagen, wir wollen die und die Koalition, das ist gerade so als realpolitische Koalition sehr weit weg. Aber ich finde, es ist eine sehr wichtige Beobachtung.
Also mir geht es bei dem, was wir jetzt machen, hier wirklich im Detail um eine im Zentrum wieder Herr Hegemann-Diskussion.
Hegemon. Was Hegemon gesagt hat?
Hegemon, ja. Der Herrmann Hegemon. Nach vorne haben wir Herr, Rückname Hegemon. Denn wir müssen uns hier wirklich über Bande spielen, aus dieser amerikanischen Beobachtung, wo es ja Zweilager gibt. Und wir wissen, wenn man eine inhaltlich vernünftige Diskussion führen will, geht das nur innerhalb der Demokraten, aber dann die ganze Bandbreite. Während bei den Republikanern völlig klar ist, da wird ein Sing-Sang betont, they are eating our cats and dogs und so. Und da lohnt sich es eigentlich nicht. So, gleichzeitig sind die Republikaner extrem zerstritten. Also wir kriegen jetzt wieder die Berichte, wie die Magas jetzt gar nicht mehr cool finden, was der Trump macht und so weiter. Während die Demokraten immer die ganze Zeit, wir müssen es gemeinsam, die Einheit und versuchen, alles so zu machen, sage ich ja, das muss ja gar nicht sein. Also auch Kevin Kühnert, das muss doch gar nicht sein. Also wir sind einfach nicht CDU, AfD, das reicht doch völlig als Identitätsstiftung. Ich bin nicht Alexander Dobrindt, fertig. So, ob dann noch wer Waffen da und da und so, das ist ja alles egal. So, unter dieser Maßgabe gucken wir jetzt diese Rede von Lars Klingbeil, bei der wir eine kleine Präampel noch voranstellen. Was ist, und es ist eine Rätselfrage, ich kann auch nur kurze Versuche liefern, ja, aber du kannst ja miträtseln, warum wird der CDU so viel Wirtschaftskompetenz unterstellt und warum ist das in Deutschland so wichtig, wer hier als wirtschaftlich kompetent gilt, wirtschaftspolitisch kompetent? Es gibt mehrere Ansätze. Das eine ist einfach Issue ownership. Die reden die ganze Zeit vom Wachstum, also meinen sie es wahrscheinlich gut und würden dann sofort für Wachstum sorgen, wenn sie könnten. Und wenn es dann nicht läuft, dann schade, aber eigentlich sind sie auf dem richtigen Weg.
Dann ist höhere Gewalt.
Genau, dann ist einfach Krieg und...
Wenn eine SPD-Regierung Krieg, Corona und alles hat, dann sagt man, die schaffen es nicht, die haben keine Ahnung von Wirtschaft. Wenn die CDU Krieg hat, dann sagen die, ja, es ist Krieg. Wir können da natürlich jetzt auch gerade nichts ändern.
Human hat vorhin noch mal chat.gbt gefragt, offenbar doch noch ein kluger Antwort gegeben. Shijek würde wohl so über auch so eine Hegemon-Diskussion machen mit, naja, andere unterstellen der CDU-Wirtschaftskompetenz. Dem will man ja nicht widersprechen, sonst müsste man ja Argumente liefern. Also geht man lieber mit dem Flow und dann wird das also über Bande gespielt. Ich möchte folgende Beispiel oder folgende Erklärung anbieten. Wenn wir zu einem Arzt gehen, Zahnarzt, alle haben Angst davor, dann wissen wir, wenn er irgendwas findet, wird das wehtun, aber danach ist gut für uns. Also vertrauen wir dem Arzt, dass der Schmerz jetzt sein muss. Und dieses Vertrauen kann nur über eine Sache mobilisiert werden in uns, der ist halt kompetent, der weiß, was er tut. Und umso mehr Schmerz ich fühle, umso kompetenter muss ich ihn halt mir einreden, damit er Sinn hat. Und ansonsten wäre er total bescheuert.
Das denkt man, man hat einen Stimphörder.
Genau. Also ist die CDU gilt deswegen als wirtschaftskompetent, weil sie uns eben nicht Honig ums Maul schmiert, sondern die ganze Zeit sagen, wir müssen härter arbeiten, hier, das muss wehtun, Opferbereitschaft, bla bla bla.
Zumutungen akzeptieren.
Also das läuft überbandet als wirtschaftskompetenz.
Das ist exakt der Diskurs, wie du es jetzt beschreibst, was ich jetzt in den letzten Wochen gehört habe in den verschiedenen Podcasts, die das Handelsplatz so rausbringen. Vom Morning Briefing angefangen bis sonst wohin. Da geht es immer darum, dass die schärfste Zumutung, die größte Opferforderung, die so auf den Tisch kommt, immer als ein besonderer Ausweis von Kompetenz gesehen wird.
Da sagt uns jemand die Wahrheit.
Also zwei Prozent Mehrwichtsteuererhöhung, großartig, endlich ist die Kompetenz zurück, ist der Reformwille da. Würde da noch jemand kommen, der sagt fünf Prozent Erhöhung, noch besser, noch härter?
So, was bedeutet die CDU, also Wirtschaftskompetenz ist sowieso schon mal ein Phantasmal. Das ist einfach eine Semantik. Und über Mehrfachbande wird sie jetzt der CDU untergeschoben und die CDU mobilisiert dieses ganze diffuse Geraune und Gefühle, indem sie nochmal besondere Härten ankündigt.
Man kann ja auch sogar so weit gehen. Momentan würde ich sagen, es ist tatsächlich eine Inkompetenz in jeder Hinsicht bei der CDU da. Ich würde auch sagen, dass sie jetzt gerade noch nicht mal verstehen, was für die deutsche Industrie gut ist. Also wenn ich jetzt nur CEO-Interessen vertreten würde, dann finde ich die bei der CDU eigentlich nicht genügend. Aber jetzt mal davon abgesehen, kann man natürlich sagen, das Problem bei dieser Kompetenzzuschreibung, da ist jemand wirtschaftlich kompetent, meint ja immer, man sagt, wenn Deutschland stark ist, starkes Deutschland ist ja gerade so das, was in aller Munde ist, dann geht es mir gut. Aber der deutschen Wirtschaft oder dem deutschen Wirtschaftsstandort geht es zum Beispiel sehr gut, wenn ich zu einem geringen Mindestlohn arbeite. Und zwar länger als acht Stunden am Tag. Das ist für den deutschen Wirtschaftsstandort tatsächlich sehr gut. Das heißt, eine Wirtschaftskompetenz, die in diese Richtung geht, ist eine Kompetenz, nur ist es nicht etwas, was mir im Ganzen irgendwie hilft, sondern es hilft dem Standort, es hilft den Kapitalinteressen. Und das kriegen die Leute aber nicht voneinander getrennt. Woher sollten sie es auch? Die Nachrichten funktionieren ja immer nur so. Wie geht es der deutschen Wirtschaft? Ja, der deutschen Wirtschaft geht es gut, wenn man Niedriglohnsektor schafft. Der deutschen Wirtschaft geht es gut, wenn die Leute später an Rente gehen. Natürlich geht es der deutschen Wirtschaft gut.
Na ja, man will halt so den diffusen Schutzschirm. So, und das ist halt der gute Aktienkurs, der gute DAX-Wert.
Der diffusen Schutzschirm, der zugleich für mich aber keinen Schutz bietet. Ich muss sehen, dass ich irgendwie über die Runden komme, ob ich mir die Miete noch leisten kann oder doch ausziehen muss. Da fällt jeder Schutz weg, aber im Ganzen funktioniert es dann gut.
Und unter dieser Maxime gucken wir jetzt diese Lars Klingbeiräte, denn er möchte hier der CDU einfach diese Art von Wirtschaftskompetenzunterstellung streitig machen.
Und zwar bei Bertelsmann.
Bei Bertelsmann, wo sonst? Gut, finde ich jetzt gar nicht so problematisch, die Bertelsmann-Studie macht, sie haben gute Studien.
Es ist einfach so lustig, dass er natürlich noch bei Bertelsmann dieses große Reformprogramm vorstellt. Er sagt ja sogar eingangs, dass er sich schon lange viel Gedanken gemacht hat und Sachen aufgeschrieben hat, aber hier wäre jetzt mal der gute Ort, das zu machen.
Genau, also das ist sowieso ganz wichtig. Er möchte die Rede verstanden wissen, als er hat wochenlang darüber nachgedacht und die sollte auch über Jahre jetzt wirken. Also das ist schon für ihn eine wichtige Rede. Und gleichzeitig gab es dann so den Tenor, ja das war natürlich schon mit der CDU so weit abgestimmt, dass Merz am Bundestag seine Regierungsbefragung macht und Aussprache blablabla und er dann gleichzeitig ein paar Meter weiter drüben einfach diese Rede hält. Also wir fangen mal hier an.
Also in dem Thema.
Wir alle wissen, Deutschland braucht grundlegende Reformen. Und mein Gefühl ist auch, dass die Menschen in unserem Land bereit sind, Opfer zu bringen, dass sie bereit sind, Veränderung zu akzeptieren, aber sie wollen eben, dass es gerecht zu geht und dass sie keiner Willkür ausgesetzt sind. Das muss die Messlatte für unsere Reform sein. Das Tempo von Krisen verändert sich. Die Logik der Weltwirtschaft verändert sich. Die Konkurrenz zwischen den USA und zwischen China prägt diese Entwicklung. Und das alles hat sehr konkrete Folgen, die wir spüren.
So, da ist der Ton gesetzt. Also jeder weiß jetzt, was wir hier meinen mit Wirtschaftskompetenzunterstellung. Man muss das große Leiden ankündigen und so weiter und so fort. Können wir jetzt also inhaltlich werden?
Und er spürt, dass wir das doch wollen. Da frage ich mich immer, mit wem hat er gesprochen?
Naja, du musst ja natürlich dein Publikum jetzt ausdenken. Das heißt, jemand, der dazuhört und nicht will, muss sich sofort als isolierter Einzelgänger, aber nicht als Concherian, sondern wirklich als Opfer Einzelgänger, der noch nicht spurt fühlen.
Du armer Mensch, du hast es noch nicht ganz verstanden, aber wir wissen es schon.
Ich trinke meinen Saft jetzt auch aus einem Papierstrohhalm. Mach du das doch auch, sonst geht die Welt unter.
Das ist das Interessante. Wenn jetzt darüber so geredet wird im Wirtschaftsjournalismus, dann reden da ja auch immer Leute alle nur von Zumutungen, die sie selbst nicht erleben.
Ja, das ist das Prinzip.
Das ist ja durchgehend so.
Beginnen wir mit 20 Clips. Du darfst ja mit auf meinen Notizzettel gucken, denn ihr solltet euch das dann auch angucken. Also ist alles schön grafisch aufbereitet. Wir beginnen hier.
Der Staat ist für vieles in den letzten Jahren eingesprungen und hat hunderte Milliarden in die Hand genommen, um die Auswirkungen von Krisen abzufedern, soziale und wirtschaftliche Folgen zu lindern. Das war richtig, aber es hat eben auch den Blick auf tiefer liegende Probleme verzerrt. In 2026 wird das nicht mehr funktionieren. Wir können nicht jede Krise und jedes Problem einfach mit noch mehr Geld beantworten. Der Staat hat eine Schutzfunktion, die wird er ausüben. Niemand in unserem Land wird auf sich alleine gestellt sein. Das gilt erst recht in Krisen, aber wir überfordern uns selbst, wenn wir jedes Risiko und jedes mögliche Problem am Ende vom Staat regulieren oder mit Steuergeld lösen wollen.
Wir waren ja in einer Oper, fünf Stunden am Samstag. Tristan und die Solde, ein sehr dialogisches Stück, bei dem mir schon meine KI's vorhersagten, stell dich auf präzise gesungene Phrasierungen ein und so weiter. Diese Kritik müsste man hier auch mal, diese Ästhetikkritik, wie er diese Sätze baut. Und das man jetzt auch und hier und überhaupt und so. Das ist alles ganz schlimm. Also er hat jetzt gesagt, der Staat lässt niemanden alleine und er ist ja die letzten Jahre immer eingesprungen mit vielen Milliarden bei Krisen. Das wird nicht mehr weiter möglich sein. Wahrscheinlich ist er Topfwitzleger oder was auch immer.
Austrietezpolitik.
Genau. Wir können das noch mal historisch aufschlüsseln. Also wir haben ja verschiedene Krisen gehabt. Corona-Krise, Energiekrise durch Angriff auf die Ukraine. Wir haben hier Balken, die wir sehen. Der grüne Balken hier unten ist direkt an die Bürger. 25 Milliarden Euro, also 300 Euro Energiepauschale, 9 Euro Ticket, Heizkostenzuschuss. Dieser ist so verschwindend gering im Vergleich zu Sondervermögen direkt auf die Privatkonten der Rüstungsindustrie. Corona-Unternehmen, wir haben Sonderhaushalte, 440 Milliarden, die natürlich ausschließlich als Wirtschaftshilfen direkt an die Unternehmen gezahlt wurden. Und sei es um, ach so, ihr könnt grad die Löhne nicht zahlen, na dann geben wir euch jetzt Geld, damit ihr es den Bürgern dann gibt. Muss ich fragen, das kann der Staat auch direkt machen. Kurzarbeit, Geld und so. Wir haben die Gas- und Strompreisbremse, 200 Milliarden Euro. Wo er heute sagt, Übergewinne, wo man sich fragt, also die Übergewinne, die du damals denen gegeben hast, die 200 Milliarden, willst du jetzt zurück haben? Also kommt ja eh nicht dazu. Aber selbst wenn wir es zurückfordern, also wenn wir es einfordern als Übergewinne, Abschöpfung, ist es unser Geld von vornherein gewesen. Also völlig absurd.
Man hat den Eindruck, wir haben im Schlaraffenland gelebt und jetzt ist mal Schluss damit. Dabei haben die, zu denen er da spricht, eigentlich im Schlaraffenland gelebt. Aber die bekommen jetzt noch mal gesagt, ja, denen da unten müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen weniger geben.
Deshalb sitzt ja auch diese BDI-Vorstandsvorsitzende oder Chefin oder im höheren Kreis, da wird da und sagt dann in ihrem Schwäbischen, aber wir können es nur gemeinsam machen. Jetzt kein Klassenkampf. Deutschland muss es jetzt gemeinsam machen. Das ist ja, glaube ich, 17-mal das wird gemeinsam untergebracht in der Aussprache. Gut, also beim Thema Geld schon mal vollfähig.
Aber wir halten hier schon mal fest, der Finanzminister ist ein absoluter Anhänger der Autoritätspolitik. Möchte also nicht aus den Lehren der Schuldenbremse, dass man da zumindest mal kurz noch mal eine Sondervermögenschaft aus dieser gemeinschaftlichen Verschuldung der EU, aus all dem, was wir so diskutiert haben, möchte er keine weiteren Schlüsse ziehen, sondern sagt nein, wir gehen jetzt ins Jahr 2019 zurück und wir tun einfach so, als wäre auch Wolfgang Schäuble noch unter uns.
You never walk alone, also niemand wird in unserem Land auf sich alleine gestellt sein, heißt bei ihm. Warte mal, wir haben dir deinen Laden zugemacht vor fünf Jahren und also der war einfach drei Monate zu und dann noch mal, kannst du das Geld bitte zurückzahlen? Ja, bis heute, eine Rückzahlungsbürokratie bei dem Corona-Scheiß, wo er kommt, also wir haben so viel Geld, das wird jetzt nicht mal künftig gehen. So und dann denkt sie so, ich zahle es doch gerade zurück, also ich jetzt nicht privat, aber ich kenne sehr viele Leute, die es immer noch zurückzahlen.
Und die auch sehr viel Geld beim Steuerberater lassen mussten, damit sie mal das beantragen konnten, was dann nichts bringt.
So was mich natürlich hier triggert, ist schon ab Clip drei Demografie.
Die demografische Entwicklung ist eindeutig. Ohne Zuwanderung wäre die Zahl der Erwerbstätigen auf dem deutschen Arbeitsmarkt schon seit Jahren rückläufig. Die Migration der letzten Jahre stabilisiert die deutschen Sozialsysteme erheblich, auch wenn manche den Eindruck erwecken, das Gegenteil sei der Fall. Studien auch von der Bertelsmann Stiftung zeigen, wie sehr wir wirtschaftlich von Migrationen profitieren.
Ja, wenn man als Finanzminister in einer Koalition mit der CDU ist, in der Dobrindt wirklich alles komplett nicht in diese Richtung regelt, sondern sagt, bloß keine Migranten, Migranten, die da sind, sollen auf gar keinen Fall deutsch sprechen können und dürfen niemals arbeiten, weil die nehmen den Deutschen die Arbeitsplätze weg. Dann muss man einfach sagen, selbst die deutsche Rentenversicherung sagt, Zitat, der Rückgang der deutschen Aktivversicherten wird durch den Anstieg ausländischer Versicherter mehr als ausgeglichen. Also alles, worüber wir uns freuen, nämlich 40,1 Millionen Aktivversicherte, die derzeit weiterhin nur 18,6 Prozent für ihre Rentenvorsorge zahlen. Das wäre ohne diese Migration überhaupt gar nicht denkbar. Und ich finde, da sollte man dann auch irgendwann diese Zahlen mal nennen, denn wir wissen ja, wie der öffentliche Diskurs läuft. Ja, genau andersrum. Also wir brauchen diese Menschen Hände ringend. Wenn man sich das anschaut, im Vergleich zum Vorjahr 232.000 neue ausländische Beschäftigte. Das heißt, unter Neueinstellung ist die Hälfte schon ausländisch. Im Gesamt, in der Gesamtbelegschaft Deutschlands sind es schon 15 Prozent. Das ist doch eine Tendenz klar ersichtlich. Wir können uns das gar nicht leisten, als ein Land, das fünffach über dem weltweiten Durchschnitt an Migranten hat, zu sagen, wir mögen keine Migration. Also es ist einfach, ja. Und ich finde, da kann man ja auch irgendwann mal einen Kontrapunkt setzen. Und einfach in so einer Rede sagen, jetzt mal die Zahlen auf den Tisch. Jeder ausländische Beschäftigte bei uns bringt 7.000 Euro mit in die Sozialversicherungskassen. Also wir haben in Sachen Rente, Krankenpflege, es wäre einfach schon vorbei. Das einzige Problem, was wir haben, ist ein großes Fürsorgesystem, Grundsicherung und diese Beiträge für Flüchtlinge, die halt, wenn sie ankommen, erstmal nicht arbeiten dürfen, aber versorgt werden müssen, weil Bundesverfassungsgericht usw. haben wir alles gehört. Nur die kann man ja auch einfach, das sind ja junge Leute, die sind ja mehr als zehn Jahre jünger als der Bundesschnitt und die bringen immer Kinder mit. Also das wäre sozusagen eine siebenjährige Sekundarstufe-2-Ausbildung und die wären fit für den Arbeitsmarkt. Und dann wären die sofort auf der 7.000-Euro-pro-Jahr-Einzahler-Seite für 40 Jahre. Wird einfach hier gar nicht thematisiert. Na ja, mal gucken, wie es weitergeht.
Mit fast 40 Prozent hat Deutschland eine der höchsten Teilzeitquoten in Europa. Das betrifft vor allem Frauen. Und während jede zweite Frau in Deutschland fast in Teilzeit arbeitet, sind es europaweit nur jede vierte. 60 Prozent der Rentnerinnen und Rentner gehen frühzeitig in Rente, weil Arbeit bis zum regulären Renteneintrittsalter sich nicht lohnt. Und wir sehen eben auch, dass es für ein Ehepaar mit zwei Kindern fast keinen Unterschied macht, ob das gemeinsame Arbeitseinkommen bei etwa 3.000 Euro im Monat oder bei 4.500 Euro brutto im Monat liegt. Durch die sogenannte Transferentzugsrate bei Wohngeld und beim Kinderzuschlag kommt unter dem Strich fast das gleiche verfügbare Gesamteinkommen heraus. Wir lassen also Potenziale liegen.
Das stimmt ja so.
Das gehen wir gleich im Detail durch.
Die Sache ist ja, die Löhne müssten höher sein, damit das nicht mehr stimmt. Wir haben eigentlich ein System geschaffen, neben dem Bürgergeldsystem, dass die, die tatsächlich arbeiten, Laufentransferleistungen bekommen müssen, damit sie überhaupt weiter in Deutschland überleben können. Das heißt, das ist ein staatlich geschaffenes Förderprogramm für die deutschen Unternehmen. Das heißt, das muss der nicht jetzt an Bürgergeldempfänger adressieren oder schauen, wo kann man was wegkürzen, sondern der muss sagen, ihr Unternehmen, ihr sorgt dafür, dass wir einspringen müssen, und das sorgt dann für diese sehr eigenartige Rechnung, die aber im Ganzen stimmt, dass es tatsächlich dann für Familien kaum einen Unterschied macht, ob dann noch die zweite Person arbeitet oder nicht.
Er kommt ja auf die Sachen gleich noch ausführlich zu sprechen. Wir machen das dann Schritt für Schritt, um auch diese Zahlen dazu zu nennen. Hier hat er ja erstmal das Tor aufgemacht zu Teilzeit zum einen und dann diese Transferentzugsrate. Das sind ja schon zwei verschiedene Themen. Bei der Teilzeit, also 71 Prozent der Frauen, 35 bis 45, arbeiten in Teilzeit, weil sie Betreuungsaufgaben haben. Richtig. Und da würde ich ja sagen, in Sachen Care-Arbeit haben die halt auch noch einen Vollzeitjob. Ja. Kann man nicht zwei Vollzeitjobs haben. Der Tag hat ja nur 24 Stunden. Es fehlen in Deutschland derzeit 300.000 Kita-Plätze und mehr als drei Millionen Menschen pflegen Angehörige und zwar alleine. Also wenn man da für Synergieeffekte sorgte, indem man zum Beispiel sagen würde, ja, vielleicht hat man doch mal so eine Stadtteilpfleger, wo es einfach eine Anlaufstelle gibt, statt dass der Pflegedienst immer zu jedem Einzelnen nach Hause muss und dann halt immer nur eine halbe Stunde Zeit hat pro Nase. Bleiben halt sehr viele Stunden am Tag übrig, in der das dann die Familie machen muss, sofern man sich überhaupt eine ambulante Hilfe leisten kann. Und nicht einfach nur sagt, na zumindest für die sechs Wochen im Sommer holen wir uns mal eine polnische Oma oder so, die dann schwarz bezahlt wird, was alle in Predoje bringt, weil ja das Bundesarbeitsgericht sagte, aber eigentlich ist hier Mindestlohn. Man ist ja nur unter Druck die ganze Zeit. Also Teilzeit ist hier kein Lifestyle, sondern es ist einfach ein Pflegebedarf. Das zweite, was er hier anspricht, diese Transferentzugsrate kann man kurz durchrechnen. Also es gibt diese Zuverdienst-Falle, eine Familie mit zwei Kindern, die ihr Bruttoeinnahmen durch Arbeit von 3 auf 4.500 Euro steigert, also beispielsweise 1.500 Euro Bruttoeinnahmen mehr verdient, kriegt dann weniger Wohngeld, weniger Kinderzuschlag, weniger Steuern. Das kann durchaus, also es sind wenige Fälle, aber es kann durchaus 100% Entzug sein. Also dass es genau aufgefressen wird. Normal sind so schon ab 50%. Also man verdient wirklich nur die Hälfte von dem, was plus man hat dann Arbeit. Man muss ja dann sozusagen seine Lebenszeit wie diese Arbeit aufbringen. Das ist schon ein echtes Problem. Jetzt gehen wir hier mal in die Details.
Ja und das liegt daran, dass man diesen Sektor geschaffen hat.
Ja und von wem?
Von ihm.
Von ihm und dem Sein. Das war Gerhard Schäuder. Ja.
Und ich will, dass das Ehegattensplitting in seiner heutigen Form für zukünftige Ehen abgeschafft wird. Eine Reform könnte zur Besetzung von zehntausenden Vollzeitstellen führen. Und ich habe ja diese Woche vernommen, dass die Kollegin Nina Waken, unsere Gesundheitsministerin, einen Vorschlag macht, die beitragsfreie Mitversicherung von Ehepartnern in der Krankenversicherung abzuschaffen. Das werden wir uns natürlich genau anschauen, wie sich das in einer Koalition gehört. Aber ich sage Ihnen auch, beide Reformen zusammen könnten Fehlanreize am Arbeitsmarkt beseitigen.
So, beide Reformen zusammen. Wir entfalten das wieder, das Ehegattensplitting. Wenn, sagen wir jetzt mal Stereotyp, der Mann 80.000 verdient und die Frau 0 Euro, dann veranschlagen ja beide für sich jeweils 40.000 Euro und liegen damit weit unter irgendwelchen Spitzenverdiener-Gefahren und so weiter. Sie sparen also 9.000 Euro, alleine dadurch, dass sie das splitten unter diesen beiden Ehegatten. Wenn man aber als, beliebt ist ja die Kassiererin, wie auch immer, man ist allein verdienend und der Partner pflegt sein eigenes Elternteil zum Beispiel oder die Kinder oder was auch immer, ist ja Standardfall. So, man verdient also nicht 80.000 und der andere 0, sondern nur so 30.000. Und dann kommt plötzlich diese Idee auf, wir machen jetzt kein Ehegattensplitting mehr, das sich ja hier eh nicht so auszahlt, aber ach, die Frau Waken hat ja noch gesagt, wir nehmen jetzt die Krankenversicherung, die Mitversicherung, die kostenlose raus. Dann hieß es ja, der nicht arbeitende, sondern pflegende und sich um die Familie kümmernde Ehe-Teil muss plötzlich einen Eigenbeitrag für die Krankenversicherung, also 225 Euro im Monat, also 2.700 Euro im Jahr zahlen. Das sind zwei Monatsgehälter dieser Familie.
Ja, das will man denen zumuten.
Und jetzt glaubt er, das ist ja ein Anreiz dafür, dass der mit Care-Arbeit Beschäftigte, der die Familie am Laufen hält, dann auch arbeiten geht.
Ja, weil er sonst gar nicht mehr anders kann. Das ist ja nicht ein Anreiz, das ist ja ein Zwang.
Genau. Das läuft dann unter Zwang. Oder ein neues Wort, was ich gelernt habe, Pönalisierung. Also von Strafe. Genau, wenn du bestraft wirst durch eine staatliche Maßnahme, obwohl du gar nichts falsch gemacht hast. Einfach nur durch, ja die Umstände sind, wie sie sind. Und jetzt dreht sich halt der große Wind. Das allerdings ist wieder, und da muss man halt wirklich sagen, hier muss einfach klassenspezifisch, ich sage es jetzt so deutlich, Politik gemacht werden. Denn jemanden, der arbeiten kann, der wirklich nur zu Hause bleibt, weil, was weiß ich, wenn der Ehegatter halt 250.000 Euro im Jahr verdient und dann einfach 50, 60, 70.000, also normales Jahresgehalt an Steuern gespart werden.
Ich habe in meinem Bekanntenkreis einen Fall. Da ist es auch die Rollenverteilung, also an sich emanzipiert, aber die Rollenverteilung ist so. Aber das ist in einem High-Level sind wir da. Und da kümmert sich die Frau eigentlich ein bisschen ums Haus, aber vor allem genießt man auch die freie Zeit und nutzt genau diesen steuerlichen Vorteil und ist dann auch noch mitversichert. Aber da reden wir jetzt wirklich von Leuten, die einfach so viel Geld haben, wo man sagt, na gut, warum soll sie jetzt auch noch arbeiten gehen?
Also da kann man durchaus sagen, ja, da gibt es einen Anreiz, nicht zu arbeiten, weil dir halt dein komplettes Jahresgehalt einfach abgezogen wird am Ende in der Familienverrechnung. Nur abgewissen werden gilt das einfach nicht. So und jetzt klar, Frankfurt, Rhein, Main, das ist eine reiche Gegend, also hier gibt es viele solcher Fälle, in der einfach einer reicht zu arbeiten, weil er einfach 300, 400, 500.000 ist. Es gibt hier 100 Leute, die einfach eine Million so verdienen im Stadtgebiet und im Umfeld nochmal mehr. Also das gibt es schon und da ist das auch genau so, wie Klingbeil sagt, nur in der Fläche gilt das halt genau nicht. Denn die Leute sind, und das ist halt sehr merkwürdig bei Lars Klingbeil, der hat halt so einen friktionslosen Arbeitsmarkt. Also eine Fiktion des friktionslosen Arbeitsmarkts, in dem alle einfach so Stellschrauben stellen können. Im Sinne von, ach so, die zahlen mir jetzt fünf Euro weniger, also muss ich dann 37 Minuten länger arbeiten, ja dann mach ich das morgen einfach. Nur so ist ja nicht. Nein. So funktioniert das nur in der großen Budgetplanung im Finanzministerium, aber nicht in der Familie. Die sind halt alle wirklich restrained durch Realität. Und das ist vor allem, weil der Staat eine Care-Infrastruktur nicht zur Verfügung stellt. Umso mehr er das machen würde, den Familien einfach Geld gibt, also Budget, damit die ihre Care-Arbeit auslagern können, ja dann können die auch mehr arbeiten. Also dann kann man das so verrechnen. Aber solange das nicht gegeben ist, geht das halt einfach nicht.
Ist diese Diskussion nicht ohnehin ein bisschen merkwürdig? Wir haben von der Agentur für Arbeit jetzt mehrmals Meldungen bekommen, dass immer weniger Nachfrage nach Arbeit ist.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Das heißt, wir haben zwar noch gewisse Fachkräfte, wo es einen Mangel gibt, aber wir haben ja im Ganzen nicht einen überhitzten Arbeitsmarkt, dass man sagt, wir brauchen dringend 500.000 Leute mehr in Arbeit, sondern wir sehen, dass die Arbeitslosigkeit moderat zunimmt und wir sehen vor allem, dass die Agentur für Arbeit vermeldet, ja da sind auch gar nicht so viele andere Stellen, da geht es gar nicht darum, dass wir nicht die richtigen Leute haben, die wir vermitteln können, sondern es sind einfach die Stellen nicht da. Das heißt, klar, es klingt, weil es geht doch hier von einer Wirklichkeit aus, wo wir sagen, es findet eine weitere Deindustrialisierungswelle statt. Wir sehen, wie hier die Binnenkonjunktur weiter geschwächt wird, wenn das mit Mehrwertsteuererhöhung kommt oder auch eben solche Sachen, wie mit der Versicherung, die nicht mehr mitgeht, dann haben einfach Haushalte, du hast es ja durchgerechnet, über 2000 Euro weniger, dann geht der Konsum wieder radikal zurück, das heißt, das wird noch schlechter werden. Von welcher Not geht der da aus?
Ich kann dir das also genau sagen, denn es ist nicht schwer, das einfach zu reproduzieren, was sozusagen Grundlage dieser Rede ist, die halt sehr diffus ist, er nennt ja keine Zahlen und nichts. Aber die Rechnung hier ist Ehrgarten-Splitting durchgerechnet, mit denen durch die Finanzämter wissen ja, wie sie diese, also da werden ja Statistiken geführt, wie man diese Ehen veranschlagt und dann diese Gelder zahlt, kommt man in der Rückwärtsrechnung auf 500.000 Vollzeitstellen, Äquivalente. So, die werden jetzt eigentlich durch Ehrgarten-Splitting einfach so direkt ausgezahlt, statt das über Bande, Unternehmen in Lohnzahlung den Familien zur Verfügung zu stellen. So, diese 500.000 Arbeitsplätze auf der einen Seite und dann die Sozialversicherung, die sehen halt 2,46 Millionen mitversicherte Ehepartner. Und wenn man denen jetzt den Druck macht, ihr müsst im Monat 225 Euro selber mobilisieren, am besten durch Arbeit, wink wink, dann sieht man halt 2,4 Millionen Leute, die plötzlich arbeiten. So, und das ist aber eine Budget-Rechnung von oben.
Ja, denn die Arbeitsplätze entstehen ja dann nicht automatisch.
Das Zauberwort Matching, schon Leute, die in Teilzeit arbeiten, können nicht einfach aufstocken, nur weil sie das wollen. Da muss der Arbeitgeber darüber entscheiden. Dann gibt es eine wirtschaftliche Lage, die da mitspielen muss und so. Ja, also es geht alles nicht aus.
Das ist, Lars Klingbeil war ja immer nur in dieser Parteienwelt zu Hause und im Beamtenstaat. Da kann ich natürlich mit ganz anderen Möglichkeiten rangehen und sagen, ich will ab dann und dann gerne einen Tag mehr arbeiten oder sonst was.
Es gibt das, aber halt nicht.
Ich sehe das, ja, bei ganz, bei sehr großen Unternehmen gibt es auch eine viel größere Flexibilität.
Heute zwei Schichten extra und so weiter.
Ja, aber es gibt auch sehr viele Bereiche, wo das nicht geht und wo die ja auch das genau so geregelt haben, dass sie nicht einfach jemanden fünf Stunden mehr benötigen.
So, jetzt kommt, jetzt gehen wir langsam ins Eingemachte.
Und Fehlanreize bei den Sozialleistungen müssen weg. Mehr Arbeit darf nicht bestraft werden und es braucht gerade deshalb die beschriebene Reform der Transfer- und Zugraten. Mehr Arbeit muss sich immer lohnen, Schritt für Schritt, ohne harte Brüche und ohne neue Ungerechtigkeiten.
So, jetzt sagt er einfach mittendrin, es braucht gerade deshalb die beschriebenen Reformen der Transfer- und Entzugsraten. Also ich möchte anmerken, er hat keine Reformen beschrieben. Er hat nur kurz vorher gesagt, das musste man mal irgendwie mal und so. Also es ist ganz diffus, aber wir rechnen es mal durch. Also Transfer, Entzugsrate, 500 mehr brutto, bedeutet häufig minus 180 Euro beim Wohngeld, minus 120 bei Kinderzuschlägen, minus 100 durch Steuern und neue Sozialabgaben. Das bedeutet, da bleiben nur 100 von denen ursprünglich 500 brutto übrig. Also eine Transferentzugsrate von 80 Prozent. Jetzt möchte er das reformieren. Er sagt überhaupt nicht wie, also müssen wir rätseln.
Wir rätseln natürlich, dass er sagt, wir nehmen einfach die Transfers weg und dann musst du.
Also es gibt zwei Szenarien. Das eine ist Arbeitsanreize schaffen, in dem man sagt, ja, dann schwächen wir einfach die Transferentzugsrate ab. Also wer 500 Euro mehr verdient, kriegt halt nicht gleich 180 Euro Wohngeld weniger, sondern 130. So, nur das wäre halt die Rampel wird dann immer flacher, aber auch immer länger. Das wäre super teuer. Das würde er wahrscheinlich nicht meinen.
Nee, hat er gesagt, wir haben gar kein Geld.
Genau. Was er nämlich meint ist, und hier gibt es das Iron Triangle of Welfare Reform. Also du hast eine Grund, in Deutschland ein existierendes Grundsicherungsniveau. Dann hast du hohe Erwerbsanreize, die du herfördern willst. Und dann hast du diese Fiskalkosten durch diese Rampe. Und du kannst immer nur zwei der drei Sachen ansteuern. Also wenn du die Rampe länger machst und damit Anreize schaffst, mehr zu arbeiten, weil euch nicht so viel vom Welfare-State weggenommen wird, vom Wohlfahrtsstaat, der euch unterstützt, dann wird es einfach teurer. Was er aber will, ist ja, das Grundsicherungsniveau senken, also die Rampe von Anfang an niedriger bauen. Nur da würde ich ja sagen, das ist ja eigentlich ziemlich ausgereizt in Deutschland.
Karlsruhe hat dann Limit gesetzt.
Zum Beispiel.
Da können wir jetzt noch über 10 Euro diskutieren, aber das wird keine Finanzen ihm bringen.
Also wir sind ja schon ganz heikel, ganz nah dran an den Ewigkeitsklauseln Menschenwürde und so weiter. Da ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel zu machen. Nur das sagt er hier gar nicht.
Ja, aber man kann natürlich diese...
Oder nur durch die Blume. Es ist jedenfalls nicht anders zu verstehen.
Das wissen wir, das haben wir ja schon mit diesen ganzen CSU und CDU Leuten bei Markus Lanz gesehen, dass dann Lanz immer nachwarte, ja, aber wie viel wollen sie denn da wegkürzen? Wollen sie alles wegkürzen? Aber das geht doch nicht. Da merkt man einfach, da können sie nichts zu sagen. Jetzt ist ja diese Idee der großen Steuerreform, die da kommen soll, wer weiß, ob sie kommt, also was das Einkommen anbelangt, dass man die arbeitende Mitte entlastet. Und ich möchte hier hinzufügen, es geht eigentlich darum, dass CDU und SPD sich, glaube ich, sehr genau angeguckt haben, wer wählt uns eigentlich noch, wer ist noch so bekloppt und wählt uns. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, dass es noch Leute gibt, die so ein Haushaltseinkommen haben von, sagen wir, 60.000, 70.000 im Jahr. Und die wählen noch und die werden tatsächlich ja steuerlich recht stark belastet in Deutschland, ja. Und da hat man gesagt, denen müssen wir jetzt noch mal irgendwas Gutes tun. Aber die jetzt zu dem, zu den unteren 40 Prozent gehören oder zu den unteren 50 Prozent, die wählen uns nicht. Wenn die überhaupt zur Wahl gehen, dann wählen die die falschen. So, und da schaut man jetzt, ob man da noch mal denen etwas mehr zumuten kann, indem man diese Transferleistung, die sie momentan gerade erhalten und mit denen sie dann auch tatsächlich, wenn sie mehr arbeiten gehen, eigentlich nicht besser dastehen durch die Mehrarbeit, ob man denen noch mal mehr Druck machen kann. Weil bei den Bürgergeldempfängern ist das ausgereizt. Da ist ja nichts mehr zu holen. Und da kann man noch dann Menschen, die Asyl beantragen oder so, die kann man noch mal gängeln und ein paar andere. Aber da ist nicht viel zu holen. Das heißt, was man noch mal versucht ist, Leute, die zum Beispiel bei Edeka an der Kasse sitzen und wie du das beschrieben hast, dann zu Hause noch jemanden haben, der gepflegt werden muss, kann man diesen Leuten, die eh nicht mehr die SPD wählen. Das hat ja, das kann man sehr schön auch sehen, bei tageschau.de, bei diesen Grafiken für Rheinland-Pfalz, die Leute, die wenig verdienen und Arbeiterhintergrund haben und so, die wählen einfach immer stärker AfD. Und da sagt man jetzt, die geben wir auf, die sind eh verloren für uns, denen könnten wir das noch zumuten.
Ja, ich habe hier nochmal die Grafik für uns offen zum Thema, wer wählt uns eigentlich noch. Also Baden-Württemberger, CDU, SPD kamen in den 70er und 80er hier auf 90%-Werte zusammen. Die liegen jetzt noch bei 35%. Also die großen beiden GroKo-Volksparteien kommen in Baden-Württemberg auf 35%. In Rheinland-Pfalz natürlich ein bisschen besser, 56%, weil die SPD da noch ein bisschen stärker ist, aber der Trend ist seit Jahrzehnten völlig klar. Diesen Parteien geht quasi alles verloren.
Und die Arbeiter gehen immer mehr zur AfD, das ist ganz deutlich zu beobachten.
Die Arbeiter, die Arbeiter ist ein ganz diffuser Begriff. Man fragt sich so ein bisschen, was das sein soll. Also politisch ist das schon mal gar nicht gefasst. Juristisch, also abgeschafft, muss man so sagen. Man weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, was die Arbeiter sein sollen. Insbesondere bei einer politischen Wahl, bei der wir heute sehen, wie sehr Kulturkämpfe reinwirken, spielt natürlich der berufliche Hintergrund eine Rolle. Aber die Leute wundern sich immer noch, dass Stefan Homburger, der Professor, der doch damals uns angesehen von den Kollegen und so weiter, und jetzt macht er so AfD. Ja, vielleicht spielt das einfach mal gar keine Rolle, was man so beruflich und welche Kulissee und was auch immer. Aber der ökonomische Status spielt eine Rolle. Ja, der spielt natürlich eine Rolle. Aber ich würde jetzt von so begriffen, wie der Arbeiter so ein bisschen Abstand nehmen.
Eine ganz kurze Pause, weil ich will das nur rausholen. Ich habe jetzt mal mein Smartphone, mein iPhone in die Hand genommen, um gerade mal zu referieren, was die Tagesschau herausgefunden hat mit Infratest-Steam-Up zur Rheinland-Pfalz-Wahl. Da geht es um die Wähler. Also wer wählt wen? Da gibt es den Satz, ich mache mir große Sorgen, dass ich meinen Lebensstandard künftig nicht mehr halten kann. Das heißt ja erstmal Lebensstandard im Allgemeinen. Das kann auch derjenige sein, der den 5er BMW vor der Tür hat und sagt, das könnte nächstes Jahr schwierig werden. Das sagen 79% der AfD-Wählenden.
Ja, große Depressionen.
Und damit sind sie weit vorne und dann kommt mit 54% der Linke-Wählenden sagen, wir unterschreiben diesen Satz. Wenn wir bei SPD und CDU sind, wenn wir bei 37-40%, das heißt da gibt es das nicht. Wenn wir jetzt die persönliche Situation uns ansehen, dann kann man zwar sagen, ja bei der AfD sagen auch 48% meine wirtschaftliche Situation ist gut, aber 30% sagen meine wirtschaftliche Situation ist schlecht. Und auch damit ist die AfD wieder Spitzenreiter. Erst dann mit 21% der linken Wellenden sagen, meine wirtschaftliche Situation ist schlecht. Das heißt, wir sehen hier ganz deutlich auch, dass die Arbeiter sich anders entwickeln, nämlich hin zur AfD. Hier wird dieser Begriff Arbeiter noch verwendet. Da kann man natürlich sich fragen, wer es damit genau gemeint, Industriearbeiter oder so. Das müsste man noch mal im genauen sich ansehen. Da stellt man jedenfalls fest. 2016 haben diese Arbeiter zu 24% die AfD gewählt, 2021 zu 18%. Es ging also zurück, es war besser geworden. Jetzt sind es 39%. Die SPD und CDU kommen noch nicht mal mehr zusammen auf 39%. Die kommen zusammengenommen auf 37%. Das ist die Situation.
Ja, weshalb ich ja finde, warum sage ich es, sollte selbstverständlich sein, Lars Klingbeils Versuch zu glauben, wirtschaftskompetent gilt derjenige, der die Härten zumutet. Während wir sehen, dass die Leute, die die Härten fühlen, alle zur AfD rennen, ist halt nicht klug. Ja, weshalb will ich hier diese Rede so? Jaja, also das ist politisch gemacht.
Ich will das sagen, weil viele sehen ja jetzt, in diesen ganzen Mahnungen, unsere Demokratie ist in Gefahr, die sehen das immer so als eine Schicksalsstunde. Und dann würde ich sagen, nee, das ist nicht eine Schicksalsstunde. Gerade an diesen Zahlen, also Arbeiter, wie bewegen sie sich, auf welche Parteien zu? Da kann man sagen, ja, das war 2016 schon mal ziemlich AfD. Und dann wurde das um einige Prozent weniger, um einige Prozentpunkte ging es runter. Und dann hat es sich mehr als verdoppelt.
So, und jetzt kommen eben die großen Fehler von Lars Klingbeil. Jetzt schießt er so einen richtigen Bock.
Und natürlich müssen wir auch über die Beiträge zur Sozialversicherung entscheiden. Die hohen Kosten belasten Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitgeber. Und ich will, dass sie mindestens konstant gehalten werden. Und wenn wir mehr arbeiten und wenn wir Strukturreformen voranbringen, dann können wir sie perspektivisch auch wieder senken. Das muss unser gemeinsames Ziel sein.
So, Lars Klingbeil arbeitet viel mit Fachleuten. Aus Beiräten, Instituten, seinem eigenen Haus. Kein einziger davon würde jemals, nicht mal in einer privaten Sekunde, sagen, perspektivisch wird diese Belastung an Sozialbeiträgen sinken. Ist völlig ausgeschlossen, dass er das hier macht. Und noch verbunden mit dem, wenn wir mehr arbeiten, ist einfach Trumpesk. Also das ist wirklich wie, als würde Trumps sagen, they're eating our cats and dogs. Genauso auf der Ebene.
Ja, es sei denn, man lässt sie so lange arbeiten, dass sie dann auch direkt vom Arbeitsplatz auf den Friedhof gehen.
Nein, nicht mal das. Es ist völlig, also klar, wenn wir einfach sagen, wir schaffen die Rente ganz ab. Wir schaffen die Rente ab, aber bleiben beim Rentenbeitrag und widmen den um.
Ja, dann könnte man es machen.
Aber das ist dann nicht Sozialversicherung, sondern das ist dann irgendein anderer Föllefanz. Also wir haben eine Sozialversicherungslast, die wie folgt aussieht, 18,6 Prozent Rente, 16,3 Prozent Krankenversicherung, dann diesen kleinen Anteil Pflege und noch mal ein kleinerer Arbeitslosengeld. Wir liegen also bei einem Rentenbeitrag heute bei 22,3 Prozent. Nein, wir sind bei 18,6 und die Perspektive der deutschen Rentenversicherung ist, dass sie bis 2035 auf 22,3 steigt, allein durch Demografie. Das haben wir ja vorne schon bemängelt, dass er diese Zahlen nicht aufdröselt, obwohl er kurz andeutet, dass die Migranten ganz schön viel beibringen. Und wir haben gesagt, ja, 7.000 Euro pro Jahr in die Sozialversicherungskassen.
Und im Finanzministerium hat man ja eigentlich einen guten Zugriff auf solche Zahlen.
Ja, also bei Olaf Scholz wussten wir, er kennt die Zahlen und sagt im Bundestag trotzdem, da sitzt die AfD, ich verschweige hier, dass es Migration auch eine Lösung ist, sondern ich sage einfach der Frauenanteil in der Arbeit, was auch immer. Nur bei Lars Klingbeil bin ich mir diesmal wirklich unsicher, ob er die Zahlen kennt, weil es braucht schon ein besonderes Ausmaß an Chuspe, so öffentlich zu reden, während man ja eigentlich mit erhobenen Hauptes in sein Haus zurückkommen möchte, indem man Chef ist und danach wieder Dienstgespräche führt.
Sowieso.
Seine Leute hören ja diese Rede.
Leitet er diese Rede ein, das haben wir jetzt eben nicht gehört, dass er sich da lange ja Gedanken gemacht hat. Und jetzt ist hier der Zeitpunkt gekommen, dass ich es bei Ihnen sage, was ich mir da vorstelle. Er kommt also mit einem Auftritt an, der sagt, jetzt kommt hier der große Souverän. Dabei ist es ja eine wahnsinnig unsouveräne Rede.
Ja, also Krankenversicherung, wir zahlen heute alles so 1000 Euro ein. Und wissen nicht genau, also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich gerade den Staat 1000 Euro im Monat Krankengeld koste oder so. Aber ich weiß, es gibt Leute, die brauchen jetzt sehr viel Geld. Krebsbehandlung, was auch immer, da ist es ja richtig teuer. Bei der Rente ist ja sehr viel einfacher. Wir zahlen so ungefähr 1000 Euro ein und dann legt noch jemand was drauf. Und Arbeitgeber, wer auch immer. Und dann kriegen wir später so 1500 Euro zurück als Renten. Bei der Pflege wissen wir ja heute schon, das ist richtig teuer. Also da ist man einfach nur mit einer Rentenzahlung von 1500 Euro oder so. Das ist nicht mal die Hälfte des privaten Beitrags, die man leisten muss, obwohl es eine Pflegeversicherung gibt. So, die Pflege ist heute, du siehst es hier, so ein kleiner Beitragsteil. Diese Idee, dass hier noch mal irgendwas sinkt. Während wir genau wissen, wie sich die Pflege und auch das Krankensystem entwickelt und die Rente als Rente sowieso auch schon unter Druck stehen. Also hier ist einfach, das ist völlig absurd, so wie er das sagt. Es sei denn, man macht halt wirklich eine große Leistungskürzung und sagt einfach, ja, dann keine Zahnärzte mehr.
Ja.
Nur dann schafft man halt wirklich aus Deutschland den Zahnarztberuf ab. Weil die Leute gehen nicht. Das ist nicht wie in Amerika, wo man so sagt, ich muss jetzt mal eine Darmspiegelung machen, ist schon blöd für die 4.000 Euro, weil ich beiße mal in den sauren Apfel. Also das würde hier sieben Generationen dauern, bis die Leute, die eh schon ungern zum Arzt gehen und das eh ausblenden, was das kostet, sagen, ja, statt nach Mallorca mache ich mal eine Darmspiegelung. Also dann fällt das einfach aus. So, dann gibt es keine Darmspiegelung mehr. Dann gibt es keine Zahnärzte mehr. Was man natürlich noch machen könnte, ich möchte hier mal kurz erwähnen. Wir könnten diese Beiträge und die Rentenversicherung wissen wir ja heute, reicht eh schon nicht. Also sind ja 100 Milliarden aus dem Steuertopf, also er einfach verschweigt, Steuer und Schuldentopf. Wir könnten natürlich einfach sagen, diese 100 Milliarden, die wir aus dem Bund zuschießen, die refinanzieren wir einfach durch eine neue Art von Sozialversicherung auf Kapitalerträge. Also wie bei Arbeit auch. Man sagt halt, ja, 25 Prozent Abgeltungssteuer ist zwar zu niedrig, aber bleiben wir mal dabei. Aber es gibt halt auch einen Sozialversicherungsbeitrag. Und der kommt aber nicht einher mit Ansprüchen, die man später hat, sondern das ist wie bei der Pflege. Wenn man kein Pflegefall ist, stoppt man halt gesund, dann hat man das Geld umsonst für sich da eingezahlt. Und genauso könnte man auch mit Kapitalerträgen umgehen, dass man einfach sagt, ja, da gibt es neben dieser Pseudo-Einkommenssteuer, Kapitalertragssteuer, also Abgeltungssteuer im meisten Fällen, einfach eine Sozialversicherung. Aber was bin ich, so eine Idee hier in Deutschland zu verpflanzen?
Das glaubst du ja nicht, dass das irgendjemand von der SPD aufgreifen würde.
Leute, die mitentscheiden, haben schon solche Fragen, ob man das nicht mal und so weiter und...
Aha.
Weißt du, also mal sehen, wo diese Idee irgendwann mal auftaucht.
Dann brauchst du dann nur einen gewissen Freibetrag, um diese Idee umzusetzen. Also sonst, du kannst nicht den Leuten zum einen zurufen, bitte investiert jetzt auch mal ein bisschen Geld in eure private Altersvorsorge. Und dann musst du noch mal da... Also du hast ja eh schon dann Kapitalerträge, die versteuert werden müssen. Wenn du dann jetzt noch mal denen Packen drauflegst, dann unterminierst du das System, das du da eigentlich in Gang gesetzt hast. Du musst also irgendeinen Freibetrag schaffen von sagen, wir 100.000 oder was auch immer, damit das in irgendeiner Weise überhaupt dann aufgeht. Also nach dem Plan, der da verfolgt wird.
Da haben wir eine Erbschaftssteuerdiskussion haben, bei der immer jeder glaubt, mein Geld wurde doch schon versteuert. Ja, weiß ich, wie weit wir davon weg sind. Aber vernünftig wäre es trotzdem. Und da wir von wem haben es gelesen, in welcher Salon Lektüre, dass das BIP eines Landes innerhalb von drei Tagen in der Finanzwelt einmal durchgewälzt wird, da sind ja eigentlich genug Verbuchungen, wo man mal abschöpfen könnte, ohne dass jetzt jeder, der wieder, ich habe aber auch drei Aktien, da irgendwie den Kampf der Großen plötzlich führt. Ok, Rente.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, auch an die Rente müssen wir ran.
Jetzt können wir alle überlegen, wie denn? Mehr Rente oder was?
Mit der Aktivrente machen wir es jetzt attraktiver, nach dem Renteneintritt weiter zu arbeiten. Aber klar ist auch, wir werden die Frage beantworten, wie wir im Rentensystem insgesamt mehr Anreize dafür schaffen, dass Menschen später an Rente gehen.
Ja, also wäre die Rente nicht genau das Äquivalent, aber mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen zur Arbeit, würde ich sagen, irgendwo steckt eine Logik in dem Satz. Aber da nun mal Rente genau nicht Arbeit bedeutet, ist es auch irgendwie witzig, wenn er das so sagt, finde ich.
Das sind übrigens alles keine Anreize. Das sind alles Zwänge, die hier vorgeschlagen werden.
Über Anreize können wir jetzt mal sprechen. Wir hören uns mal diesen Einklep noch an.
Ich unterstütze deswegen den Vorschlag, dass wir bei der Rente viel stärker uns an den Beitragsjahren orientieren. Dass wir aufhören, ein früheres Ausscheiden aus dem Erwerbsleben zu fördern. Ich fände es sinnvoller, wenn wir längeres Arbeiten fördern.
So, er will also, dass wir später in Rente gehen. Was die Menschen aber tun, ist früher in Rente gehen. Wie sieht das in Realität aus? Menschen gehen im Schnitt, und wir sind ja gerade bei 67 Jahren, das heißt, die Januar letzten Jahres, das ist ja das Renten an 1,67. Die Leute gehen mit 64,7, also 2,3, fast zweieinhalb Jahre früher in Rente. Das ist ein großes Rätsel. Wir können es natürlich einfach deuten, indem wir sagen, Arbeit im hohen Alter scheint nie so cool zu sein. Weil die Leute verzichten ja durchaus auf lebenslange Rentenzahlungen, sie nehmen also Abschläge im Kauf. Im Durchschnitt gehen sie also 32 Monate, also mehrere Jahre früher in Rente, und verzichten auf den Rest ihres Lebens auf monatlich 149 Euro im Schnitt.
Und das nicht wenig.
So, für mich ist das ein mega Indikator dafür, wie scheiße Arbeit sein muss für über 60-Jährige. Die flüchten, das ist die eigentliche Fluchtdiskussion, die wir in Deutschland haben. Leute flüchten aus dem Arbeitsmarkt.
Das ist so. Ja, ich kenne auch genau Leute, die das so sagen.
Ich kenne ausschließlich Leute, die das machen.
Ich sage, ich verzichte lieber auf 200 Euro, als mir das anzutun. Jetzt noch die andere Seite, die sogenannte Arbeitgeberseite. Ja, da sind viele, die sagen, haben sie sich nicht auch mal überlegt, ob es nicht jetzt so langsam an der Zeit wäre.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Denn auch das zeigt sich, die werden abgeschoben, werden dann auch mit irgendwelchen Tätigkeiten plötzlich betraut, die sie vorher nicht gemacht haben, die sie nicht machen wollen. Weil der Arbeitgeber weiß, so können wir sie loswerden, dann ist das so eine Zermürbungstaktik, dass man sagt, gut, dann gehe ich eben zweieinhalb Jahre früher, verzichte auf 200 Euro, aber ich bin diesen bekloppten Chef los. Auch das ist eine Strategie, die angewendet wird. Also hier wird das immer von der Arbeitnehmerseite so gesehen, aber es gibt ja nicht wenige Chefs, die sagen, ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht so viele Leute über 60 da drin haben.
In dieser Kalkulation hier schlägt es natürlich richtig rein, also in dieser Budgetkalkulation, die so ein Finanzminister macht. Jetzt gehen ja Millionenjahrgänge in Rente. Und wenn 28,3 Prozent sagen, ich nehme Abschläge in Kauf, dann reden wir hier also über 280.000 Leute pro Jahr, die einfach sagen, ich spare mir jetzt ein weiteres Jahr.
Und jetzt denkt Klingbeil darüber nach, wie kann man einen Druck ausüben auf diese Leute, also ihnen das noch teurer zu stehen kommen lassen, damit sie nicht diesen Schritt gehen.
Man kann natürlich die Abschläge von 149 im Schnitt auf 200 Euro kürzen. Es findet ja, bevor man in Rente kommt, so Gespräche statt. Also die Rentversicherung lädt dann ein, sie nähern sich jetzt und so weiter. Hier sieht es so und so aus. Was ist denn ihr Plan? Können sie länger arbeiten? Wollen sie? Wie auch immer. Und jede dritte Frau sagt, nee, sorry, danke für das Gesprächsangebot. Aber wann kann ich denn frühestens in Rente gehen mit den und den Abschlägen? Und dann sagen die, ja, das wäre dann nächsten Monat statt in drei Jahren. Dann sagen die, sehr gut. So, da will jetzt Klingbeil sagen, hier Anreize, in Anführungszeichen setzen. Also es ist völlig schief. Was es auch noch gibt, ist Erwerbsminderungsrente. Die wird gezahlt, wenn Leute gar nicht mehr können. Was bedeutet? Wir haben es in Deutschland mit neue Anträgen auf Erwerbsminderungsrente, aktuell ist der Zahl von 2024, 360.000 Anträge in einem Jahr. Also wahrscheinlich geht das so jedes Jahr aus. Hier kommt nicht einfach der Wille mit, ich möchte früher in Rente, sondern hier kommt einfach ein Arzt, der einen Art Test vorlegt, es wird dann mit der Rentenversicherung direkt geklärt, kann nicht mehr. Also hier ist auch nichts mit Anreizen zu machen.
Nein Stefan, auch da muss ich dich korrigieren. Ich habe ja dem Kanzler zugehört beim FAZ-Empfang. Schade, dass ich den Clip jetzt nicht hier parat habe. Der sagt ja, und mir erzählen Betriebsärzte und Kollegen, da kommen kerngesunde Leute und die wollen dann einfach früher in Rente. Das geht doch nicht.
Also ich möchte dazu sagen, es gibt durchaus...
Das gibt es natürlich. Ich kenne auch sowas.
Ich war ja auch hier in Hofheim bei der Bundesagentur, die da eine große Filiale hat, die ja so hessenweit so ein bisschen auch Vorbild und so weiter. Und dann ging es um Wissenstransphäre. Wie kriegt man Leute, die abgeschoben werden, also wo der Betriebsarzt sozusagen im Sinne des Management sagt, können wir den mal loswerden, die Erwerbsminderungsrente, wie auch immer, dass man dann versucht, die noch mal so in Rehart zurück, also die Rentenversicherung auf die Unternehmen zu gehen und sagt, nee, hier noch mal ein Rehart-Programm auf Eurokosten, das ist noch kein Rentenfall. Das gibt es. Und ich werde das auch dieses Jahr noch mal in einer Keynote und so weiter bei so Betriebsärzten, Verbanddingern, also selber noch mal durchrecherchieren und dann auch das mal thematisieren.
Also natürlich gibt es auch Leute, die sich versuchen, früh krank zu schreiben, dass sie nicht mehr lange arbeiten müssen.
Genau, also hier sind durchaus Ärzte im Spiel, die auch ihre Reputationen aufs Spiel setzen und von den 360.000 Anträgen werden dann durchaus 170.000 bewilligt. Also das sind jetzt nicht im krassen Stile, sondern hier ist einfach jeder. Zweite Fall ist dann auch zurecht. Und da muss man einfach sagen, das ist crazy. Also ich will es noch mal sagen, 149 Euro pro Monat für den Rest des Lebens. Das ist der Verzicht, den die Deutschen eingehen, um zu sagen, bloß weg aus dieser Arbeitswelt. Und hier muss man sich wirklich noch mal, das ist ein bisschen wie beim Wohnen. Alle, die professionell damit zu tun haben, bauen natürlich am liebsten für den 25-jährigen Hipster, der gerade eine Familie gründen will. Aber wir brauchen jetzt auch mal ein paar Baufirmen und ein paar Leute, die sich um das Wohnen der Alten kümmern. Die also einfach ein Publikum, das nicht so attraktiv ist. Und bei dieser ganzen Arbeitsmarktbeobachtung, ja, das ist immer alles ganz toll mit den Fachkräften. Und dann kommt jemand aus Indien und kann voll gut Mathe und so. Aber was ist mit dem Typ, der die letzten fünf Jahre vor sich hat? Und den muss man sich dann auch noch mal inhaltlich kümmern einfach. Da finden kaum Programme statt. Es ist im Grunde einen Blödsinn nach dem nächsten. Jetzt geht es ja um die Superreichen.
Wer hart arbeitet, soll mit dieser Reform mehr Geld in der Tasche haben. Auch hier muss das Prinzip gelten, mehr Arbeit muss sich lohnen. Das ist das Ziel der Reform, die ich anstrebe. Und ja, diese Entlastung muss auch finanziert werden. Und für mich ist dabei völlig klar, dass die hohen Einkommen und die hohen Vermögen dazu einen Beitrag leisten werden.
So, das ist, bis auf kleine Ausführungen zur Erbschaftssteuer, die wir gleich als nächsten Clip ein bisschen aus der Chronologie raus nach vorne ziehen, der einzige Satz überhaupt, der man die Vermögen denn nennt. Und er macht das mit dieser Politik auf Flossgeld. Das ist für ihn völlig klar, das muss kommen. Also das Geldvermögen der privaten Haushalte, 9,3 Billionen Euro. Bei den obersten zehn Prozent liegen davon 5,6 Billionen. Der Bundeshaushalt ist also verschwindend klein dazu, knapp 500 Milliarden.
Interessant ist aber hier ja auch, dass er direkt Einkommen und Vermögen in einen Topf wirft.
Das geht nur, wenn das Publikum ganz unaufgeklärt ist. Wenn man als Finanzminister einfach denkt, ich bin zwar hier bei der Bertelsmann-Stößung, die machen eine Studie nach der anderen, aber die sind alle doof. Das ist die Unterstellung, die hier mitläuft. Wahrscheinlich hat er Recht aus seiner Sicht. In der Aussprache fand jetzt nichts statt, wo jemand da mal groß widersprochen hat.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Man darf die Blödetat der anderen nicht unterschätzen. Es ist ja so, wenn er die hohen Einkommen stärker bestreuen will, dann ist das ja tatsächlich ein Konzept, das es jetzt auch gibt, das ja auch von der SPD, von Teilen zumindest ventiliert wird. Da war ja dann eben diese Idee, man versucht diese arbeitende Mitte, ich will mal sagen, man versucht die SPD und CDU-Wähler zu entlasten, indem man denen da unten mehr aufbürdet, vor allem durch die Mehrwertsteuererhöhung bringt man natürlich die Leute, die ohnehin ihr ganzes Geld für den Konsum ausgeben müssen, weil sie mehr nicht zur Verfügung haben in entsprechenden Nöte. Und dann hat man sich gesagt, wir müssen aber, wenn wir diese Steuererleichterung der Mitte durchführen, und die soll ja dann etwa bei Haushalten zwischen 60.000, 70.000 Euro, so zweieinhalbtausend Euro im Jahr bringen können, dann muss man ja irgendwo das Geld von wem holen. Und dann kam nämlich nicht Vermögensbesteuerung, sondern man hat es versucht, über die Einkommensteuer zu regeln. Das heißt, der Spitzensteuersatz bzw. reichen Steuersatz, der soll dann viel früher greifen. Das heißt, die Leute, die mehr als 130.000 Euro im Jahr verdienen sollen, die sollen erheblich mehr belastet werden. Da das, und das ist ja das Verrückte, deswegen darf man das nicht in einen Topf schweißen. Da das aber ohnehin nur ganz wenige Leute sind in Deutschland, da reden wir von drei, vier Prozent, auf die das zutrifft, kann man das von denen ja nicht holen genug. Dann hat man wieder so eine bestrafende Steuer vielleicht. Also man kann, selbst wenn man dort den Spitzensteuersatz früher ansetzt und progressiver gestaltet, also bis 49 Prozent war ja dann sogar die Rede, wenn man das so macht, dann hat man dort bei weitem nicht die Einnahmen generiert, die man benötigt, um die SPD- und CDU-Wählerschaft zu entlasten, diese Mitte zu entlasten. Deshalb müsste man da eigentlich an die Vermögen ran. Weil man aber nicht an die Vermögen und an die Erbschaften so richtig rangehen will, sagt man, da müssen wir den Rest kompensieren mit einer Mehrwertsteuererhöhung. Und das ist die Absurdität. Die sollten gar nicht über Einkommen reden, sondern müssten über Vermögen gehen und über Erbschaften.
Beim DIW gab es im Auftrag der Linksfraktionen Nachrechnung. Wie sähe es aus, wenn man auf Vermögen eine Steuer legt, die pro Jahr zuschlägt, beginnend bei 1% und dann bis 12%, also so progressiv, je nach Vermögenshöhe, überhaupt erst ab einer Million Bar Vermögen und so weiter und so fort. Wie bei der Erbsversteuerung auch das Haus, in dem man lebt, jetzt mal nicht mit potenziell liquidiert und so weiter. Man käme laut DIW auf 100 Milliarden im Jahr. Und das ist eben hier in Frankfurt ja auch, da war ja auch ein Gespräch mit Kolja Müller. Es gibt ungefähr 150 Leute, die ein Millionen Einkommen haben, also pro Jahr mehr als eine Million verdienen, aber es gibt halt 80.000, die einfach eine Million haben. Natürlich sehr viel durch Immobilien, nimmt man wieder ein paar raus, aber ich finde in einer Stadt mit 800.000 Einwohnern ist 80.000, die potenziell über eine Million verfügen, schon viel. Da sind einfach Spielräume. Bei der Erbschaftssteuer, es sind 45 Großerben, die 2024 auf einen Erlass von 3,4 Milliarden Euro kamen. Ihnen wurde 95 Prozent erlassen durch Verscholungsbedarf, der da angemeldet wurde. Das sind einfach immense Zahlen dafür, dass er sie erstens gar nicht nennt und es auch in dieser Rede bei diesem Halbsatz belässt. Er kommt dann nur kurz auf, die Erbschaftssteuer zu sprechen.
Starke Schultern können mehr leisten und sie sollten das auch tun. Es sind jedes Jahr 400 Milliarden, die vererbt werden oder die verschenkt werden. 400 Milliarden. 13 Milliarden haben die Länder am Jahr 2024 davon eingenommen. Das sind 3,25 Prozent. Und ich halte es nicht mehr länger für vermittelbar, dass kleinere Erbschaften teilweise sogar stärker belastet werden als die großen. Das ist eine Schieflage und deswegen möchte ich, dass die Erbschaftssteuer reformiert wird. Dass zusätzliche Einnahmen gezielt in Bildung und in Chancengleichheit investiert werden, weil wir damit auch eine bessere Grundlage für unseren künftigen Wohlstand legen.
Ja, also wir haben hier eine schöne Grafik. Das sind die Paragrafen 13a, 13b, 28a des Erbschaftssteuergesetzes, also die sogenannte Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung. Die greift ja dann ab 26 Millionen oder so. Wir sehen also, wer 100.000 vererbt, bezahlt relativ wenig Steuern, 500.000. Das sind ja alles noch diese Freibeträge, die dann kaufen. Bei 2 Millionen bis 10 Millionen ist es richtig hoch. Ab dann greifen schon erste Spielereien und ab diesen 26 Millionen ist dann einfach völlig, also man bezahlt dann quasi keine Erbschaftssteuer mehr.
Das heißt finanzielle Unabhängigkeit gibt es in Deutschland ab 26 Millionen.
Das ist einfach ein perverses System und was ich mich natürlich jetzt hier frage, hat nicht im Januar Wiebke Esdar als Vizefraktionschefin der SPD ein Erbschaftssteuerkonzept vorgestellt, dass man vielleicht als SPD-Chef, gleichzeitig Fraktionschef und so weiter hier mal kurz zumindest andeuten könnte. Immerhin hat das einen coolen Namen, das heißt nämlich FAIRERBEN mit AI geschrieben. Also in der Ansicht, ich will es noch mal in Grundzügen nennen, unter einer Million, das ist der neue Freibetrag. Kein alle 10 Jahre 400.000 Schnickschnack irgendwas und so, das man dann schön verrechnet, aber immer schön im Kalender anmerken, wann man beim Steuerberater das gelten mag, sondern nein. Man hat einfach einmal den Freischuss, hier ist eine Million, lieber Sohn, ab 1.000.000, 1 Euro kostet er die Erbschaftssteuer. Zweitens, das Eigenheim, in dem man selber wohnt, ist einfach frei. Wenn die Eltern dir ein Haus geben, der Staat ist blind, er stellt sich blind, er will damit nichts zu tun haben, er will dich nicht aus dem Eigenheim vertreiben, was ja, wenn man das jetzt mal durchrechnet, bedeutet, 95 Prozent der Leute, die sich als die großen Diskutanten des Erbschaftssteuers, des Kurses aufspielen, sind damit raus. Es geht nicht um ihre 800.000 Euro, es geht nicht um das Haus ihrer Eltern. Fertig. Und das könnte ja eigentlich ein Türöffner sein für eine Diskussion.
Zumal sie auch das so konzeptioniert hatte, dass man sagt, das soll eine zweckgebundene Steuer eigentlich werden, die an die Bildung geknüpft ist, weil er jetzt auch hier die Bildung nochmal erwähnt. Warum greift er den konkreten Vorschlag nicht auf?
Ja, diese Frage habe ich dann auch mal der KI gestellt. Sie gibt mir Antworten. Es gibt die Vetospielertheorie von Zebelis. Ich lese mal vor. Der politische Handlungsraum einer Koalition, also die Schnittmenge der Präferenzen aller Regierungspartner, da die CDU und CSU bei Vermögens- und Substanzbesteuerung eine absolute Vetoposition einnimmt, würde die namentliche Nennung von vererben in einer Ministerrede sofort einen Koalitionskonflikt auslösen. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist halt das Problem. Wenn die SPD nicht parallel zum parlamentarischen Betrieb der Fraktion eine Eigenständigkeit hat.
Und sich dem Lager zuordnet, das du eben ausgemacht hast.
Genau, dass man dann nämlich einfach sagt, sorry, also wenn unser vererben Konzept hier von der CDU so abgelehnt wird, dann halten wir natürlich dagegen.
Die CDU?
Und die CDU übrigens, wenn es unsere SPD-Fraktion macht, halten wir auch dagegen.
Und die Union macht ja dieses Lager. Die lässt sich unter Druck setzen. Sie macht sich das Lager innerhalb einer Koalition mit wem auch immer. Rechnet die sich immer dem konservativen Lager zu oder dem rechten Lager zu?
Wir überspringen zwei Clips. Ich hatte Ex-Kurse vorbereitet. Zum einen Schulerik, der sagt, ja an die Rente müssen wir unbedingt.
Doch, spiel sie mal, damit ich mich ein bisschen aufregen kann. Ich sehe da schon einen zweiten Namen.
Also es ist sicherlich nicht... Das ist aus dem FAZ-Podcast vom 8.3. Nur die Rente, aber ganz zentral, wenn man auf die Höhe der Aufwendung guckt, ist das, wenn wir Platz im Bundeshaushalt machen wollen für Dinge wie Verteidigung oder Dinge wie Zukunftsinvestitionen und wir die nicht über Kredite finanzieren wollen, und das sind Sachen, die ich alle unterschreiben würde, dann gibt es eigentlich keinen anderen Bereich, an dem man Geld mobilisieren kann durch Umschichtung in den Ausgaben als im Bereich der Rente. Und das ist der Bereich, an dem die allerwenigsten Politiker wirklich gerne ran wollen. Und ich merke das auch selber in dem Moment, in dem ich irgendetwas zur Rente sage, am nächsten Tag habe ich so viel Fanposts, wenn wir das in Kiel, wie bei keinem anderen Thema.
Herr Schuhle, Rick, Sie verdienen ja viel Geld, dann geben Sie doch einfach die Hälfte ab. Dann ist doch gut, Sie bekommen doch den extremen Pensionsanspruch, den bekommen die normalen Leute doch gar nicht. Die Durchschnittsrente ist doch kläglich, dass man da sagt, ja, das ist der größte Posten, natürlich ist das der größte Posten.
Ich denke mir so, warum sagt er hier, er kriegt da am meisten Fan-Posten, weil niemand an die Rente ran will. Alle wollen an die Rente ran. Woran niemand ran will, ist Vermögen und Erben.
Ja, alle wollen die ganze Zeit über die Rente reden.
Alle wollen hier an die Rente ran. Ich meine, er hält die ganze Rede. Lars Klingbeil redet über Teilzeit, also was ist während der Beschäftigungslebenszeit, und dann Rente, was ist nach meiner Beschäftigungslebenszeit. Das sind die beiden Top-Themen. Und er sagt, da will mal keiner ran und so.
Er spricht sich nochmal für Austeritätspolitik aus, also auch da keine Schuldenbremsenreform oder soetwas. Wir tun das alles dann, um die Aufrüstung zu finanzieren. Obwohl man ja sagen muss, aber Sie haben doch da eine ganz andere Rechnung gemacht. Vor einer Weile war doch von Schularik im Spiegel so ein Aufsatz, wo er sagte, wenn wir jetzt extrem umstellen auf Aufrüstung, dann wird das die deutsche Wirtschaft unglaublich voranbringen. Das wurde ja dann von Patrick und von Tom Krebs mal durchgerechnet. Dann sagt er, nein, gar nicht. Jeder Euro in Bildung würde viel mehr bringen. Aber er hat ja das Wachstumsversprechen da gleich gezeichnet. Mit der Aufrüstung kommt das. Und jetzt heißt es plötzlich, durch die Aufrüstung haben wir gar nicht so viel Geld, also nehmen wir den Rentnern was weg. Was ja immer bedeutet, also die Rente wird ja zum größten Teil verkonsumiert. Oder an Enkel verschenkt. Das heißt, dieses Geld fließt ja sofort in die Volkswirtschaft. Es wird ausgezahlt und dann wird damit was gemacht. Bei ihm offenbar dann nicht. Also wenn man die Rente schwächt, dann schwächt man die Volkswirtschaft.
Ja. So, jetzt kommt Eifrecht von Lucke. Ich glaube, du hast die Vorfreude gerade. Die gilt ihm. Okay, er war bei Studio 9 zu Gast, wo ja immer der ganz Sonore, Corbinian Frenzel immer noch mal. Und der Wal kann er sich noch mal ein bisschen auskesen. Das ist schon schade, aber die Natur muss ja auch mal zu ihrem Geld kommen.
Und die große Frage wird sein.
Die große Frage wird sein.
Denn da wird es auch schmerzhaft für die Union. Ist sie tatsächlich so mutig? Den Bessersituierten, ich mache es sehr konkret, Rentnerinnen und Rentner, die es ja auch gibt, zuzumuten.
Also wer glaubt, die CDU bräuchte noch einen Mut, um irgend wem irgendwas zuzumuten? Nein, das ist deren Sport. Daraus zehren die ihre Wirtschaftskompetenzunterstellungen.
Was meint ihr überhaupt jetzt mit den Bessersituierten Rentnern?
Oh, ja, wir hören mal den Clip durch.
Dass sie beispielsweise mit Blick auf die große notwendige Reform in Anspruch genommen werden. Ich sehe bisher nicht die Übersetzung der Außenkanzler-Fähigkeiten von Friedrich Merz auf die Innenpolitik, wo er einmal auch den starken Schultern erklären müsste, wir sind in so harten Krisenzeiten gerade...
Ja, also die starken Schultern sind die Leute, die in Rentenanspruch knapp an 2000 Euro haben, nicht diejenigen, die 200 Millionen auf dem Konto haben. Das sind nicht die starken Schultern.
Also wir müssen jetzt von denen, die die 2000 haben, da müssen wir jetzt was, damit die auch schwache Schultern bekommen.
Die müssen jetzt solidarisch mit ihren Mitrentnern sein, während alle anderen, die von ihrem Vermögen hilf...
Wir sind in so harten Krisenzeiten. Gerade die starken Schultern müssen mehr tragen. Stattdessen führt Linneman eine Debatte über die Senkung des Spitzensteuersatzes. Das scheint mir ein Kardinalfehler zu sein. Vielleicht ist März an dem Punkt weiter, als ich ihm jetzt unterstelle. Immerhin hat er ja diesen doch ziemlich mutigen Vorschlag gemacht. Wir müssen in Zukunft Lebensarbeitszeiten bei der Rente in Rechnung stellen. Wir können nicht immer die Jahre nur in Rechnung stellen. Das trifft natürlich vor allem Kandidaten wie uns, die eine ganze Weile studiert haben. Aber das ist, glaube ich, ein richtiger Ansatz gegenüber denen, die hart gearbeitet haben, also sehr früh, und eben andere Rentenbedürfnisse haben, weil sie nicht mehr aufs Dach klettern können. Aber das wird man sehen. Und ich habe momentan den Zweifel daran, und das ist der einig springende Punkt, dass genau in dem Augenblick, wo das ja erforderlich sein müsste, mit Blick auf den Sommer, den Herbst, wo aber SPD und CDU beide die Sorge haben, dass ihnen gerade ihre Restwähler schafft, wenn ich das so nennen darf, nämlich die älteren Wählerinnen und Wähler, mit Blick auf die Wahlen in Sachsen-Anhalt, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Berlin, dann noch mehr von der Fahne gehen könnten. Ich habe die Sorge, dass sie genau diese Reformen dann in dieser Zeit eben nicht wagen werden. Das ist meine Befürchtung.
Albrecht von Lucke hat die Sorge des März, den Rentnern das Geld nicht wegnimmt.
Ja, Albrecht von Lucke hat seit Beginn des Riesens der Ukraine eigentlich jede Position von CDU und FDP übernommen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, warum der noch in irgendeiner Weise immer so als Linker irgendwo eingeladen wird, also so noch angekündigt wird. Das ist ja völlig verrückt.
Unklare Lage.
Also dann kann man auch sagen, und Wolfgang Kubicki ist grün oder so.
Ja, das ist halt Issue ownership auf Dampfplauderei. Und es geht halt automatisch einher mit hat sich Gedanken gemacht, ist ein Linker.
Ja, es ist zumindest dann nicht irgendwie so lebensweltlich noch rechts, weißt du?
So, zurück zu Lars Klingbeil. Jetzt wird mal thematisch. Man könnte so viele Scherze machen über, wie er in den ARD-Tagesthemen zugeschaltet ist. Und dann noch. Also er war heute schon halt unter dem Tagesthema. Und dann, was für ihn alles eine Rolle spielt. Europa hier und nix und da. Und ich so, das kann alles nicht vorne reden. Ich hab sie doch gerade eben gehört. Also wird auch von ihm selber sehr viele Lügen einfach verbreitet über die Story. Eine Sache, die müssen wir uns aber mal jetzt einfach vor Augen führen. Denn die zweite große Wirtschaftskompetenzvermutung bei der CDU läuft immer darüber. Das habe ich auch schon mal in einer Fernsehsendung, habe ich mich darüber lustig gemacht, dass Peter Altmaier irgendwie so ansetzt, blablabla. Und da habe ich auch so gesagt, naja, sie schreiben ja immer die Hälfte der Seiten in ihrem CDU-Wahlprogramm voll mit Cluster hier, Spitzenforschung da, irgendwas supergeil, also Issue ownership. Wir sind die Leute, die wissen, es wird bald solche Computer geben und das wird alles mit Kernfusion. Geier, mega, die europäische Cloud, es wird alles supertoll. Ja, also das ist ja auch so ein großer Strang. Weshalb sehe ich, dass der Lars Klingbeil dachte, 35 Minuten mehr Bock habe ich nicht. Ich baue jetzt mal hier Spitzencluster-Mega-Forschung ein.
Aber darüber hinaus geht es auch darum, dass wir den Fokus auf Zukunftsbranchen legen. Auf KI, auf Climate Tech, auf Life Sciences. Statt also weiter nach dem Prinzip Gießkanne zu fördern, wollen wir Programme zusammenlegen. Wir wollen sie auf Spitzencluster ausrichten. Das gilt sowohl für nationale als für europäische Programme.
Das finde ich sehr gut, denn ich habe es noch nicht selber gemacht, aber ich kenne Leute, die darunter gelitten haben, einen DFG-Forschungsantrag zu schreiben. Wenn man denen sagt, nein, Prinzip Gießkanne ist jetzt nicht mehr, denken wir sich auch so, die armen Leute, über die wurde nämlich die Gießkanne ausgeschüttet. So, er möchte das jetzt natürlich alles irgendwie finanzieren.
Vor allen Dingen ist ja eine Gießkanne, ich verstehe immer nie das Bild so richtig. Eine Gießkanne ist ja eigentlich was Positives, also mit einer Gießkanne kann man ja z.B. Blumen gießen.
Na ja, also wenn ich meine Blumen gieße, verschwende ich das Wasser natürlich nicht in die Erde. Ich gehe ganz gezielt mit so einer Pinzette an den Stamm, an den Stängel und dann nur dort.
Wie gesagt, ich hätte gerne die Alternative zur Gießkanne. Wie sieht die aus?
Wir brauchen unbedingt Climatech, damit es nicht mehr regnet, weil das Wasser verschwindet. So, das muss jetzt alles finanziert werden. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie er einfach in seinem Tenor bleibt. Er hat ja jetzt schon zehn Minuten lang über Geld und so geredet, aber nur über das Geld der Arbeitnehmer und so weiter. Leute, die vom Einkommen leben. Über das Geld, über das er nicht geredet sind einfach die neun Billionen, die so rumliegen. Sechs Billionen bei den superreichen Top Ten. Da wird ja ausgespart. Dasselbe erstaunliche, also das Muster wird ja einfach wiederholt.
Wenn ich immer wieder berichtet bekomme, dass Unternehmen, die in Deutschland gegründet wurden, die sogar mit Steuergeldern dann auch finanziert wurden, irgendwann in die USA abwandern, weil sie eben hier in Deutschland nicht das notwendige Wachstumskapital finden, so verschenken wir doch als Land ein unfassbares Potenzial. Und das ist übrigens kein Schicksal, das ist ein Fehler, den wir beheben können. Auf deutschen Sparkonten liegen 3600 Milliarden Euro.
Also ich habe gerade die Zahl vorgestellt mit so knapp 10 Billionen. Welche 3,6 Billionen meint er denn hier?
Das ist Geld, das wir mobilisieren könnten. Wir haben die Reform der privaten Altersvorsorge.
Ah, das ist das Geld, was die Leute aus ihrer menschlichen Arbeit separieren, viel später. Das ist natürlich witzig, dass man genau das, also die privaten Zusatzerträge, die man auf einem Sparkonto wirklich sicher anlegt, dass er jetzt plötzlich diese Risikospitzenforschung damit verwendet.
Ja, die Sorge jetzt auf den Weg gebracht, wird diese Woche im Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen. Die Einführung der Frühstartrente, die wir als Regierung auf den Weg bringen. Und ich werbe zusätzlich dafür, dass wir eine verpflichtende kapitalgedeckte Betriebsrente in unserem Land einführen, für die Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer ihren Beitrag leisten. Das stärkt alles den Kapitalmarkt.
So, du hast ja eben schon Gaia genannt. Man kann es ja jetzt weitergehen mit Kernfusionsforschung oder sonstigem Rahmen.
Auch eine schöne Sache, ja.
So, jetzt nimmst du die privaten Erträge im Sinne von, da hat jemand so 70.000 Euro gezielt für den Lebensabend. Ja. Also nicht jemand hat Spielgeld und sagt so, ich habe es mal versucht in die europäische Clouds, schieb mir damals coole Prospekte zu sein, hat nicht funktioniert, 70.000 sind weg, aber ich habe ja noch 700.000. Sondern Leute haben einfach so einen Betrag für sich. Und jetzt kommt er und sagt, ja, es gibt da ja so Technologie, klar, ist schon ein bisschen wacke als ich so, ob es jemals eine europäische Cloud geben wird, ob es jemals Kernfusions unserer Lebenszeit geben wird, daran hängen wir jetzt das Schicksal, ob du später eine Redite ausgezeichnet kriegst oder nicht. Das höre ich daraus.
Ja, ja und vor allem finde ich das erschreckend, wenn er sagt, das liegt jetzt gerade da so auf den Konten, ja, will er da jetzt ran, muss man jetzt voll verpflichtet werden, kann ich dann nicht mehr das auf dem Konto liegen haben, sondern muss dann so ein windiges Projekt investieren. Also wenn ich ja, wenn ich ja investieren wollte, dann würde ich ja, wir haben ja hier auch schon mehrmals zu sprechen, dann würde ich ja in ETFs investieren, aber bestimmt würde ich mir irgendwas aussuchen, wo Lars Klingbeil nicht mit drin hängt.
Du musst jetzt die Risikoforschung hiermit finanzieren.
Ich bin ja nicht irre. Also ich meine, wenn die privaten Investoren, die sich hundertmal besser auskennen, sagen, lieber nicht, mit Europa alles immer schwierig, dann wäre ich ja der Letzte, der das machen würde.
Jetzt wissen wir ja, es gibt ja eigentlich noch anderes Geld, das könnte man ja mobilisieren. Das wird von Klingbeil natürlich ausgespart, aber er macht einen ganz interessanten Satzbau, denn nicht nur kommt jetzt lediglich ein Wunsch zur Geltung, sondern grammatikalisch wird er noch, wie soll ich sagen, eingepfercht in ich würde mir wünschen.
Wenn deutsche Konzerne ihre neuen Fabriken und Standorte ausschließlich in Osteuropa bauen, dann frage ich mich schon, wo ist eigentlich der deutsche Standortpatriotismus geblieben? Ich würde mir wünschen, dass in vielen Vorständen auch über Heimat und über Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter nachgedacht wird und nicht nur an Margen.
Einfach mal nachdenken, so eine schöne Runde machen, über Heimat diskutieren, reicht doch.
Da würde ich sich wünschen, dass bei Unternehmern mal das Wort Heimat etwas bedeuten würde. Bei allen anderen bisher angesprochenen in der Rede ist das nicht mit ich würde mir wünschen, sondern wir nehmen dir mal alles weg. Vielleicht hat es dann einen Anreiz mehr zu arbeiten.
Aber hier ganz vorsichtig.
Das ist wirklich super vorsichtig. Vor allem, man muss auch ganz vorsichtig sein, denn das Kapital ist ein scheues Reh. Ich möchte erinnern an die Elefantenrunde vom 24.2., in dem H. J. Schumacher und vor allem Frank Staus mal kurz die Zahlen nennen.
Die DZ Bank, das ist eine Meldung aus dieser Woche, rechnet für DAX und MDax mit 63,7 Milliarden Euro an Dividenden. Das heißt, unsere lahmende, kranke, kaputte Wirtschaft mit ihren Lifestyle-Chefs. Schüttet 63,7 Milliarden Euro an Dividenden aus. Und was ist wichtig? Wer schüttet den größten Batzen aus? Automobil und Chemie. Genau. Die größten Dividenden zahlen die deutsche Autoindustrie. Und zwar mit 14 Milliarden sind das gut ein Viertel der Gesamtsumme.
Sehr gut, denn wir wissen ja, ausgezahlte Dividenden bedeutet, dass das Geld, das man abgibt, weil man es nicht investiert.
Genau.
Die Industrie selbst glaubt nicht an die Zukunft und zahlt deshalb lieber Dividenden aus.
Vor allem auch an die eigenen Leute.
Und natürlich an die eigenen Leute. Aber die Leute, die jetzt sich von ihrem Arbeitslohn ein bisschen was gespart haben, die sollen bitte innovativ werden.
Die müssen jetzt die Innovation. Also die Automobilindustrie hat es ja nicht hingekriegt, ihr Mobilität entsprechend zu entwickeln. Das schafft aber jetzt Enno. Enno, der seit 30 Jahren auf dem Bau, der macht das jetzt.
Dem kann man mal einen schönen Fond drehen.
So, hier so ein bisschen Tagespolitik.
Die falsche Politik von Präsident Trump hat Auswirkungen direkt auf die Geldbeutel der Menschen hier im Land. Auch, weil einzelne Unternehmen sich in dieser Krise bereichern. Ich finde das übrigens schäbig und unpatriotisch, was wir dort erleben von Konzernen. Und ich habe in den letzten Tagen ja verschiedene Vorschläge gemacht.
Es ist einfach schäbig, weißt du? Mehr gibt es nicht zu regeln.
Ja, aber was ist denn das über, also es sind doch internationale Konzerne, die können doch gar nicht patriotisch sein. Das ist doch ein Widerspruch in sich. Patriotisch mit wem?
Na ja, mit solidarisch mit den Jungen, die jetzt das Land verteidigen. Es ist halt eine große Solidarität.
Genau, die können ja noch patriotisch mit den USA dann sein.
Ja, wir haben hier immer mit Grundbegriffen, die gar kein empirisches Substrat mehr haben. Aber es heißt noch lange nicht, dass wir sie nicht verwenden.
Oder ist die deutsche Ölindustrie jetzt Preistreiber geworden? Ich glaube nein, die gibt es nämlich nicht.
Das stimmt. Also das ist doch unsinnig. Worüber du redest, das gibt es alles gar nicht.
Ich will hier gerne auch nochmal wiederholen, wie wir Preise absenken können. Erstens sollten wir die Übergewinne der Energiekonzerne abschöpfen.
Sollten wir die Übergewinne abschöpfen. Also das sind die 200 Milliarden, die 22, 23 direkt an diese Konzerne gezahlt wurden.
Zweitens werbe ich für verbindliche Preisgrenzen, die vorgegeben werden. Wir sehen in Nachbarländern wie Luxemburg, dass das geht.
Also Luxemburg würde ich es nicht als Nachbarland bezeichnen, in dem was geht, aber hier einfach so einen halb-marxistischen Planwirtschaftssatz einschmeißen, wo auch ich sage, ne, wir haben uns schon für Kapitalismus in dem Sinne entschieden. Und den kann man halt regeln.
Und drittens möchte ich auch, dass die abgeschöpften Gewinne an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zurückgegeben werden, etwa durch Entlastung bei den Mobilitätskosten oder durch eine befristete Senkung der Energiesteuer.
Das Klimageld steht überhaupt drin im Koalitionsvertrag. Hier wird doch schon wieder fantasiert, bei unserem Finanzminister. Hier kommt jetzt dieser Clip, den ich so interessant finde, weil er redet nur über einen Vorgänger im Amt. Man fragt sich so ein bisschen, welchen mein nervös, natürlich welchen er meint und dann die Logik.
Mehr Wind, Solar, der Ausbau von Stromspeichern, die Modernisierung unserer Netze. Einer meiner Vorgänger im Amt hat einmal gesagt, erneuerbare Energien sind Freiheitsenergien. Freiheit vor dem Würgegriff fremder Mächte und geopolitischer Krisen.
Das triggerte mich ein bisschen zu folgender Überlegung. Die Grünen kamen mit, wir müssen das machen, um den Planeten zu retten. Dann haben sich alle darüber lustig gemacht. Dann kam allerdings, ach so, wir sind voll abhängig von denen, die uns diese kaputtmachende Technologie zur Verfügung stellen, also Energieressourcen. Dann sollten wir das jetzt neu frameen. Wir retten nicht mehr den Planeten, sondern wir kämpfen für unsere Freiheit. Also man schwenkt schon das ganze Thema von Klima auf. Im Grunde ist es derselbe Sprech, den man auch findet, um die jungen Leute zu motivieren, fürs Land zu sterben. So, und trotzdem kommt die Reiche und baut es zurück. Das ist schon erstaunlich, also gegen die Grünen zu wettern, ja. Aber selbst eine Versicherheitslichung dieser ganzen Thematik und das trotzdem nicht hinzukriegen, jetzt einfach mal in Solarpanele, die, nein, die Förderung für die zwei Quadratmeter Solarpanele an deinem Balkon muss gestrichen werden.
Für ein starkes Deutschland und für das Gegenteil davon.
Es ist wirklich, das ist alles so schräg. Man hält es im Kopf nicht aus. Aber er möchte jetzt die Übergewinne abschöpfen, die er vor vier Jahren selber gezahlt hat. Also so ein bisschen, wir verstehen es nicht so ganz.
Soziale Gerechtigkeit ist in diesen Zeiten kein Nice-to-have.
Oh, jetzt kommt natürlich, diesen hören wir uns mal. Eigentlich müsste man ihn jetzt in halber Geschwindigkeit, aber dann klänge er wie betrunken. Das geht nicht. Wir hören uns jetzt in einfacher Geschwindigkeit und überlegen mal, ist er nicht trotzdem betrunken?
Kein Nice-to-have. Das ist für mich in meinem Selbstverständnis Teil eines starken Landes mit einer robusten und krisenfesten Gesellschaft. Gerechte Gesellschaften behaupten sich stärker gegen die Feinde der Demokratie und sind zugleich auch wirtschaftlich erfolgreich. Die hohe Inflation hat zwischen 2021 und 2023 zu massiven Reallohnverlusten geführt. Lediglich während der Weimarer Republik oder unmittelbar nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hat es massivere Einbußen gegeben.
Ja, oder während des Zweiten Weltkriegs, kann man ja auch mal kurz dazu sagen.
Und jede Krise, in der jetzt die Preise wieder nach oben schießen, führt zu steigender Unsicherheit, führt auch zu Verlustängsten. Und das trifft vor allem die Menschen, die in der öffentlichen Debatte am wenigsten vorkommen. Das sind Haushalte mit kleinen Einkommen. Das sind 40 Prozent der Haushalte in unserem Land, die keinerlei Ersparnisse haben.
Die, die er die ganze Zeit jetzt schröpfen wollte, die adressiert er jetzt noch mal und sagt, an euch denke ich.
Ja, die kriegen wir einfach noch mal. Also vorher wurde ja schon alles unter so einer Semantik versteckt.
Ja.
Und jetzt wird noch mal semantisch richtig gelogen.
Also sie wird noch mal so Honig ums Maul geschmeckt, damit man später dann in der Tagesschau sagen, ein Tagesthema im Gespräch sagen kann. Ja, aber ich habe heute in der Rede die Armen, die Bedürftigen, die aber das Land tragen, um die sich niemand kümmert. Also bin ich wieder da und so, ja.
Oder so eine Meldung. Er betonte auch dabei den sozialen Zusammenhalt.
Ja, es geht für ihn um diejenigen, die morgens fleißig aufstehen.
Wer jeden Tag früh aufsteht und am Ende des Monats trotzdem nicht weiterkommt, der hat nicht persönlich versagt. Aber diese Situation offenbart, dass das System so nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ja, aber warum machen wir dann das System 2.0?
Noch schlimmer. Er müsste den Satz ja einfach so beenden, wer morgens fleißig aufsteht, aber nicht weiterkommt, der wird es jetzt bald noch schwerer haben, weil wir uns da was bei der Pflegeversicherung haben einfallen lassen.
Also die Sätze, die hier kamen, sind alle komplett ins Leere gelaufen. Er möchte den Armen den Transfer in Zug zumuten. Er möchte die ganzen Splitting, Ehegattensplitting mit Versicherungs-Privilegien nehmen. Er möchte an die Rente ran. Und die Unternehmer kriegen halt so einen kleinen Appell. Also er würde sich schon wünschen, wenn es da mal was gibt. Und es gibt Vermögen. Das hat er im Grunde gesagt.
Es gibt es ja.
Mehr ist nicht. Oh, jetzt Wohnen. Großes Thema. Ein kleiner Clip zum Wohnen.
Die Mietkosten in den deutschen Städten sind in den letzten Jahren oftmals explodiert. Dafür brauchen wir vor allem mehr Wohnraum. Und ich will deswegen, dass auch der Bund zukünftig Wohnungen im großen Stil bauen kann. Ich schlage davor die Gründung einer staatlichen Wohnungsbaugesellschaft vor. Und außerdem sage ich ja auch sehr klar, müssen wir an die Standards ran. Die Standards müssen runter, damit Bauen günstiger wird.
Ja, Baustandard E wie einfach kommt nie. Weil die Leute wollen schon Geld verdienen mit dem Hausbau. Ja, natürlich. Es gibt nicht nur die Käufer des Hauses, es gibt auch die Hersteller. Also diesen Clip finde ich besonders ärgerlich, weil er hier so über vermeintlich richtige Wege der Staat muss jetzt auch mal bauen. Ich habe mich ja auch selber dafür ausgesprochen zu sagen, es gibt nicht nur privates Bauen und dann sozial verträgliches Bauen, sondern der Staat selbst baut bitte. Nur was ich überhaupt gar nicht will, ist, dass hier in Frankfurt irgendein Haus gebaut wird, bei dem der Bund zuständig ist. Also in Berlin, irgendwer sitzt, der aber auch für die Häuser in Düsseldorf und Münster und Ulm. Das macht ja gar keinen Sinn. Dieser eine Fall, den wir hier in Frankfurt unternehmen, den wir wirklich sehr leiden, den hat ja Collen Müller auch gerade angesprochen. 1914 baut der Staat das königliche Polizeipräsidium hier in Frankfurt. Und bis 2002 sitzt da auch die Polizei drin, zieht dann aus. So 2002, vor 24 Jahren, beginnt der Leerstand. Zwölf Jahre lang Verfall. Es gibt dann schon so die ersten Lost Places Dokumentationen und so. Im Hinterhof wird ein Kino eingerichtet in den Sommertagen, wie man das halt so macht. Es gibt aber null Plan, irgendwas zu machen. 2018, das Gebäude und die Fläche gehört dem Land Hessen, also nachdem man 16 Jahre langer Brach liegen lassen, mitten in Frankfurt, eine Minute vor dem Hauptbahnhof, verkauft dann das Land Hessen an einen Düsseldorfer Investor. Gute Idee, ja. Für 200 und so weiter Millionen. Was bedeutet, okay, die sind jetzt krass investiert, so gehen natürlich Pleite. Weil Verwerfungen, wie auch immer, das ganze Ding geht Bankrott. So, 2026, der Insevanzverwalter sucht halt einen Investor. Das Land sagt aber, auf gar keinen Fall darf die Stadt Frankfurt das kaufen. Was ich eh schon mal crazy finde, weil dann einfach der Staat dem Staat was abkauft, also das verstehe ich sowieso nicht, kann aber einfach über eignen. Aber nein, es muss jetzt ein Investor gefunden werden, der irgendwas mit dem Grundstück macht. Und natürlich noch den Invens, also den ehemaligen Eigentümer, der jetzt pleite ist, auszahlen, weil es stehen ja 200 Millionen im Raum. Hätte der Staat, also das Land einfach gesagt, okay, ich bin Ministerpräsident Boris Rhein, die Frankfurter haben mich bei einer Oberbürgermeisterin schon mal nicht gewählt, aber Schwamm drüber. Nein, ist nicht. Das muss alles in allen Himmelsrichtungen durch private und öffentliche Hände gehen, außer die Stadt. Die darf da nichts mitbestimmen. Und jetzt kommt als nächstes der Finanzminister im 680 Kilometer entfernten Berlin und sagt, ich richte bei mir mal so eine kleine Ecke ein, von da aus betreuen wir dann das Polizeipräsidium in Frankfurt und bauen dann da irgendwas. Das ergibt alles überhaupt keinen Sinn. Ich finde es einfach nicht gut. Das ist wirklich schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Gebt einfach den Städten ihre Grundstücke fertig ist, dass das hier jetzt seit einem Vierteljahrhundert in der teuersten Gegend Europas brach liegt. Es ist nicht zu vermitteln. Naja, schließlich, jetzt kommt seine Steuerkriminalität. Es ist wirklich, man glaubt es nicht. Wir hören uns das mal an.
Und schließlich, und das will ich als Finanzminister deutlich sagen, ich verachte Steuerkriminalität.
So, ich verachte auch Steuerkriminalität. Ich finde Cum-Ex ist ein Megaskandal. Ich finde 100 Milliarden, Steuervermeidung, Megaskandal. Ich finde es auch skandalös, dass der Staat sagt, für Kapitalerträge, wo jemand nicht arbeitet, gilt man einfach pauschal so nur die Hälfte des typischen Einkommenssteuersatzes. Finde ich auch skandalös. Dass man Vermögenssteuer, ach so, wir sollten jetzt die Grundstücke aufwerten, also teurer machen, sodass wir mehr Geld einnehmen. Nee, das machen wir mal nicht. Liegt auch brach, ja. Das ist alles skandalös. Jetzt hören wir mal, was er skandalös findet.
Wer sich auf Kosten der Allgemeinheit bereichert, muss mit konsequentem Handeln rechnen. Ich habe vor einigen Wochen drastische Maßnahmen gegen die organisierte Kriminalität vorgestellt. Aber ich werde jetzt zeitnah mit einem sehr umfassenden Aktionsplan gegen Steuerbetrug an die Öffentlichkeit gehen und wir werden eine härtere Gangart, eine andere Gangart gegen dieses kriminelle Verhalten einlegen.
So, Steuerkriminalität.
Hat er jetzt irgendwas gesagt?
Ja, ich kann, also man muss es alles rausschälen aus dieser Rede. Ja, ich versuche das jetzt mal weiter drauf verwiesen. Er hat Anfang des Jahres und so weiter gegen organisierte Kriminalität. Das stimmt. Es ist ein Aktionsplan gegen organisierte Kriminalität vorgestellt worden. Der Folgendes beinhaltet 434 Überprüfungen in Barbershops und Friseursalons, ob da auch regulär gearbeitet wird. Es kam zu 194 Strafverfahren. Es gab 2025 sehr viele Zoll-Ratschen in Nagelstudios und bei der Kosmetik und in der Gastronomie.
Ich hätte mich jetzt auch nicht gewundert, wenn du noch Shisha-Bars sagst.
Genau, ja, so ungefähr. Die Finanzkontrolle Schwarzarbeit, die er hier angesprochen hat, mit seiner großen Initiative gegen organisierte Kriminalität, hat also 2025 675 Millionen hinterzogene Steuern eingetrieben. Unberührt davon bleibt das 18-mal so hohe Steuervermeidung oder Raub, Steuerraub Cum-Ex.
Da gilt ja die alte Daumenregel, Faustregel, wenn man von Millionen redet auf Bundesebene, spielt es keine Rolle.
Genau, das ist dann alles diffus, Millionen, Milliarden, was auch immer. Ach so, da liegt also zwischen 1 Milliarde und 1 Million, da liegt eine Milliarde Unterschied. Konzernsteuervermeidung, Bundesrechnungshof, kommen mit diesen 100 Milliarden. Also der Bundesrechnungshof, das ist nicht hier die FDP-Klitsch oder so, sondern es ist der Bundesrechnungshof. Diese 100 Milliarden, also 50 mal so viel wie seine komische OK Nagelstudio oder auch nicht. Und dass die Konzerne grundsätzlich, wie das Handelsblatt schreibt, 75 bis 125 Milliarden im so ein bisschen Steuer optimieren, spielt ja auch keine Rolle. Hören wir also das Finale unseres Vier-Landsministers.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, lassen Sie mich das sagen. Ich glaube an unser Land. Ich glaube an die Vernunft und die Kräfte der Menschen, die hier leben. Wir haben in diesem Land alles, was wir brauchen, um aus dieser schwierigen Phase rauszukommen und uns rauszuarbeiten. Wenn wir bereit sind, uns zu verändern und wenn wir heute Entscheidungen treffen, die sich morgen auszahlen, dann werden wir in einem starken Land leben. Ich hoffe, dass ich mit meinem Impuls und meiner Rede und meinen Gedanken dafür einen Aufschlag gemacht habe für die Reformdebatte, die jetzt in den kommenden Wochen vor uns liegen wird. Und ich kann Ihnen nur sagen, ich möchte, dass wir Lösungen finden, die unser Land voranbringen, die unser Land stark halten, unser Land stärker machen. Und ich freue mich jetzt auf die Debatte mit Ihnen. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja, super.
Dreimal stark gesagt und wir halten fest ein starkes Land mit vielen geschwächten Bürgern.
Ja, also es ist wirklich grotesk. Wir können ja diese Bilanz ziehen, diese Rede gegen 35 Minuten. Sie handelt 25 Minuten lang von Zwangsmaßnahmen gegen die untere Hälfte. Und zwei Minuten lang, er würde sich wünschen und Vermögen gibt. Ja, also E-Garten-Splitting abschaffen, Mitversicherung abschaffen, an die Rente ran. Nicht gespielt, Befristung ausweiten. Ich erinnere an die große Rede von Martin Schulz zum Thema Arbeit in Bielefeld, wo sie ihm im Hintergrund noch die Gewerke einmal in Figuren aufgebaut haben, wo es hieß, zu lange und so weiter. Sachgrundlose Befristung darf es nicht mehr geben. So, er kommt jetzt mit, wir sollten es überall wie bei den Start-ups machen. Das ist voll toll. Man denkt sich so, ja, also es gibt durchaus Länder, die haben so grundsätzlich gar keinen Kündigungsschutz, nur da fällt man halt nicht ins Bodenlose. Und das ist aber in Deutschland so ein bisschen anders. Steuerkriminalität, naja gut, man geht dagegen Nagelstudios vor. An die Ersparnisse wollen wir ran, weil wir müssen ja die Forschung finanzieren. Und ja, für die Unternehmen halt, ja, er schafft schon also ein bisschen reformieren, Übergewinne abschöpfen, die man vorher gezahlt hat, also den Unternehmen. Und er würde sich halt wünschen, dass auch die Unternehmer mal ein bisschen mehr an Heimat denken.
Die SPD ist ja ein großer Freund der 5-Prozent-Hürde und will die ja eigentlich am liebsten auch in der EU haben. Ich denke, die sind auf einem guten Weg bald unter diese 5-Prozent-Hürde zugelangen.
Also die SPD ist tot einfach. So braucht man sie nicht.
Das kann ich sicher auch alleine machen. Also ich würde auch für jeden, wenn die nächsten Kommunalwahlen anstehen, Landtagswahlen usw. anstehen, ich hätte das eigentlich auch schon sagen sollen, jetzt für Rheinland-Pfalz-Wahl zum Beispiel. Also Rheinland-Pfalz wurde ja auch 100 Jahre von der SPD regiert, sage ich mal, also sehr lange zumindest, mit König Kurt und Marlo Dreyer und dann Alexander Schweizer jetzt. Die hätten eine Plakatkampagne, da muss man sich dann was trauen, da muss man mal mutig sein, machen sollen, mit dem Kopf von Lars Klingbeil drauf schreiben, wir haben mit dem nichts zu tun, wir regieren in Mainz. Das wäre die Kampagne gewesen, SPD Berlin haben wir nichts mit zu tun, Bundesregierung haben wir nichts mit zu tun, wir sind hier die Rheinland-Pfalz-SPD. Absolut. Und auch nicht dann nochmal Pistorios nach Rheinland-Pfalz holen, dieser ganze Unsinn. Man hätte sich ganz davon abspalten müssen, hätte möglicherweise damit erfolgreich sein können. Und dann hätte man wirklich die Bundes-SPD unter Druck gesetzt. Aber so gibt es da natürlich nichts.
Ja, ich habe natürlich mit Amüsement, weil ehrlich gesagt, man kann sich ja nicht mehr ganz so blöd verkaufen lassen, auch genau diese Diskussion gesehen, nach den Wahlen in Baden-Württemberg und Rheinland-Pfalz. Also die Grünchefin sitzt da und sagt, der Sieg von Cem Özdemir ist sehr gut für ihn persönlich und für uns als Partei. Also man muss sie überhaupt erst mal wieder einvernehmen. Und genau dasselbe Torsten Frei dann in Rheinland-Pfalz. Also der Herr Schnieder, das ist ganz toll für ihn, dass er das geschafft hat und das ist auch gut für die CDU. Also man muss die Leute immer wieder daran erinnern, dass es so ist. Und ich möchte meinen Vorschlag jetzt strapazieren. Ich habe ja gesagt, die kommunalen SPD sollen einfach die KSBD gründen. Die kümmerer, also die kompetenten Kümmerer in der Kommune halten. Nur diesmal würde ich sagen, nennt euch einfach nur Karl. Lasst das mit der SPD komplett sein. Diese Verknüpfung darf nicht weiter so stattfinden, außer man macht eine Paukenschlag-Emanzipation. Also man sagt einfach, sorry Lars, aber wir haben noch keinen Nachfolger. Du musst trotzdem schon mal gehen.
Ja genau, das wäre ja auch mal interessant.
Das wäre eigentlich mein Weg. Lieber vakant, weil es einfach, Lars Klingbeil füllt die Lücke an der SPD-Spitze mit der CDU. Dann lieber vakant, dann lieber ne Lücke.
Die einzigen, die darunter leiden, sind die in der Tagesthemen. Die wissen dann nicht so genau, wie ihn grad einladen, aber das hält man ja aus.
Da wir gerade in Stimmung sind, zwei Clips aus der Aussprache. Die BDI-Geschäftsführerin wird vorgestellt.
Und ich möchte beginnen mit Tanja Göner, Hauptgeschäftsführerin des BDIs.
So, wir dürfen alle ran, was sie sagt.
Ich bin nicht hundertprozentig davon überzeugt, dass die Gerechtigkeitsdiskussion, die dann immer leicht klassenkämpferische Züge beinhaltet, der richtige Angang ist.
Es ist einfach so schön, nach 35 Minuten totalem Zugeständnis gegenüber dem Kapital jetzt nochmal sagen, aber bitte keinen Klassenkampf.
Jetzt keinen Klassenkampf. Okay, es gibt hier einen sehr langen Clip, den will ich nochmal kurz andeuten. Der ist wirklich super interessant. Da ist nämlich jemand, wir können mal kurz anspielen.
Ja, Felix Appel mein Name. Ich bin aus Bayern. Ich hoffe, das wird mir jetzt nicht zum Nachteil ausgelegt.
Blabla.
Fragen nicht, aber drei Anmerkungen. Einmal als Mitarbeiter der Verwaltung seit 18 Jahren.
So, er stellt hier Folgendes vor. Ich referiere mal in meinen Worten und dann hören wir das Finale. Er arbeitet in der IT, sagt dann auch kurz, ich habe mich hier dem Staat verschrieben. Ich bin so ein bisschen in der Verwaltung, aber ich könnte auch auf dem freien Markt einfach 200.000 Euro kassieren. Und dann wäre es das so. Das Produkt, das er den Kommunen anbietet, ist, ich kalkuliere für euch die Pflegekosten durch. Im Sinne von, ja, aber da ist ja auch ein Return on Investment drin. So, und da habe ich wieder gedacht, das kann doch nicht sein, dass man 2026, und das höre ich aber gerade überall, sei es im Sport oder in den großen Autofirmen, das einfach, das einfachste, also die haben nicht mal eine BWL-Logik. Da wird aus dem Bauch heraus entschieden und am Ende des Jahres wird einfach mal ein Kontostand nachgeschaut. Aber da gibt es gar keine Erwartungshaltung, was bringt hier irgendwas und so. Und er, sein großer Aufschlag ist, in die Kommunen zu gehen und zu sagen, wir haben eine Software für euch, da könnt ihr das durchrechnen. Wenn ihr jetzt ein Pflegeheim baut, wie dann so die Synergien sind und so. Und da kommt nämlich am Ende was raus. Das ist nicht nur die Baukosten am Anfang. Und er suchte händeringend nach Investoren, weil nämlich alle Risikokapital geben oder was auch immer, weil die dann sagen, ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es für diese Software einen Markt gibt. Aber dann denke ich mir, ja, dafür muss es keinen Markt geben. Der Staat hat bitte die Aufgabe, sich, und wenn jemand freiwillig kommt, ist das sehr gut, ihm zu sagen, ja, zeig uns mal diese Software. Es reicht am Anfang, wenn es ein Google-Spreadsheet ist. Das ist völlig absurd. Und er macht am Ende folgende Bemerkung. Mal gucken, ob ich jetzt an die richtige Stelle gesprungen bin.
Und jetzt noch die abschließende Bitte als Sohn einer Pflegefachkraft der Caritas. Schauen Sie mal auf Facebook und gucken Sie sich die Pflegegruppen an. Es gibt Gruppen, die da heißen Hilfe, ich bin pflegender Angehöriger, mit 50.000 Personen, die sich gegenseitig austauschen als pflegende Angehörige und sich versuchen, gegenseitig zu helfen. Warum machen Sie es auf Facebook? Weil Sie keine Alternative haben. Also bitte aus dieser Warte kümmern Sie sich darum, den Menschen, die dieses System und dieses Land ohnehin schon am Laufen halten, auch einen Raum und eine Möglichkeit zu geben, sich gegenseitig selbst zu helfen.
Ja, also wenn Deutschland so brach liegt, dass die Kommunen keine Return-on-Investment-Kalkulation machen, sondern immer nur Ausgaben sehen, vor denen sie zurückschrecken und denen ihnen dann auch vom Land direkt aus der Hand geschlagen werden, und wir ein Pflegesystem haben, bei dem nicht nur 85 Prozent der Pflege zu Hause im privaten Dachgeschoss stattfindet, fernab von jeglicher staatliche Unterstützung, sondern selbst dort der Wissenstransfer einfach Facebook-Gruppen ist. Was mache ich? Mein Vater hat heute schon wieder um sich geschlagen und isst die Suppe nicht. Was tue ich? Ja, ich gehe zu Facebook und gucke mal bei anderen, wie die das so machen. Das ist das Pflegesystem in Deutschland. Wirklich, das ist alles viel schlimmer noch als ein Irankrieg. Das ist wirklich gruselig.
Wir möchten etwas ankündigen. Man kann uns ja nicht nur in der CASE live erleben, viermal im Jahr, sondern es wird auch wieder einen großen Sommersalon geben. Dann sind wir wo?
Im Saalbau Bornheim. Falls man aus Versehen zur CASE geht und rechtzeitig dran ist, geht man einfach eine Viertelstunde rüber. Also sozusagen im gleichen Stadtgebiet. Aber da ist natürlich mehr Platz.
Ja, am 22. August werden wir beide dort die Bühne betreten. Die Themen stehen natürlich noch nicht fest.
Wir sind ja aktuell, wir machen Nachrichten dann.
Ja, wir werden sehen, was irgendwas schon anfällt. Wir freuen uns immer sehr darauf, weil das ein gut klimatisierter Ort ist.
Das stimmt.
Das ist wichtig im August. Und wir haben davor und danach dann natürlich auch Gelegenheit, mit euch ins Gespräch zu kommen. Am 22. August also. Und die Karten kann man ab sofort buchen. Diese findet man am besten wie?
Also grundsätzlich findet man alles immer sehr leicht über neuezwanziger.de. Da versuche ich, dass alles gleich ersichtlich ist. Aber natürlich auch hier in der Podcastbeschreibung.
Das heißt, es gibt ein Saalticketing. Man kann da sich konkret Plätze anklicken.
Man schickt keine E-Mail, man klickt auf den Link und dann kann man sich einen Platz aussuchen.
Ganz richtig. Und dieser Salon, wie natürlich auch alle Salons, die schon aufgenommen wurden, gibt es dann auch für die Salonisten wieder zu hören. Der vergangene Salon, da haben wir ja auch übrigens sehr ausführlich über den Irankrieg gesprochen. Dann aus der Perspektive von Gauck und Krupalla und andere Themen hatten wir noch. Du hast auch Hollywood und AI mitgebracht. Wer das also jetzt vom März noch hören will, kann das auch ganz einfach tun mit einem Abo bei Apple, Patreon oder Steady. Das findet man dann auch alles auf der Homepage oder in der Beschreibung. Jetzt kommen wir zu einem Thema, das nahtlos anschließt an das, was Lars Klingbeil uns vorstellt. Denn wenn wir hören, dass das ja mit der Rente vielleicht doch mal gekürzt gehört oder noch gar nicht schlimm genug ist, wir brauchen da Zumutungen und auch weitere Zumutungen, dann ist man doch auf sich allein gestellt. Und so sah ich vor wenigen Tagen auf der Seite tagesschau.de, und zwar direkt ganz oben auf der Startseite die Frage, wie viel Geld braucht man eigentlich für den Ruhestand? Lilly-Marie Hilscher und Joscha Balitz haben sich diesem Thema angenommen. Das ist so ein Format, da sitzt eine moderate Ruherin da, spricht direkt in die Kamera. Dazu gibt es dann ein paar Einspieler, beziehungsweise Grafiken. Ein Experte wird noch interviewt, aber es geht ziemlich frontal zu. Wir bekommen hier also erklärt, worauf es ankommt. Und ich habe das mir angesehen damals, weil es mich selbst interessiert hat. Ich habe mir gedacht, ja, würde mich auch mal interessieren.
Wie viel Geld du brauchst.
Wie viel Geld brauche ich? Und dann habe ich etwas ganz Interessantes erlebt, nämlich selten war, na ich muss anders anfangen, unter Ideologie meint man ja in der Regel, dass die Wirklichkeit unter so ein Schleier gelegt wird. Man kommt nicht so richtig an die Wirklichkeit ran und dann kommen wir und sagen, hier sind mal die echten Zahlen. Wie ist es denn wirklich mit der Migration oder so? Hier ist es aber ein neuer Fall. Nämlich die Wahrheit wird gesagt. Ich habe auch diese Rechenbeispiele zum Teil auch nachgerechnet und ergänzt noch mal für mich. Aber trotzdem ist da Ideologie en masse. Und dem müssen wir uns jetzt widmen.
Du willst in Rente nicht jeden Euro zweimal umdrehen und dein Leben einfach genießen. Reisen, Hobbys, halt einfach keinen Stress. Aber Leute, habt ihr schon mal an eure Pflege gedacht? Da kommt ziemlich schnell die Frage auf, wie viel Geld ist in der Rente eigentlich genug?
Ja, also wenn diese Frage im Raum steht, dann geht es bei 4.000 Euro im Monat los und endet bei ungefähr 10.000 Euro im Monat.
Wir hören uns erstmal die Faustformel an. Wie viel brauchst du überhaupt als Rentner?
Und da gibt es eine Faustformel von zum Beispiel die Stiftung Warentest, dass du im Ruhestand ungefähr 80% von deinem letzten Nettogehalt brauchst, damit du deinen Lebensstandard halten kannst.
Es gibt noch eine Faustformel, und zwar in die Waschmaschine, die nur so viele Sachen reintun, dass die Faust noch mit reinpasst.
Ja, diese Faustformel ergibt dann Sinn, wenn man ja weiß, naja es fallen dann zum Beispiel Rentenbeträge weg, die man zahlen muss, da man ja dann in Rente sich befindet. Das ist auch immer die Idee, dass man dann nicht ganz so viel Geld braucht. Jetzt wissen wir aber ja von sehr vielen Rentnern, beziehungsweise wir wissen von sehr vielen Arbeitnehmern, dass die ja so schon zu wenig haben. Deswegen hat man ja dieses Aufstockungssystem. Das heißt, dieses 80 Prozent gilt dann eh eigentlich nur schon für die, die jetzt relativ gut dastehen und eigentlich auch noch eine ordentliche Rente erhalten könnten.
Es gibt ja zwei Werte. Das eine ist die, also das ist grundsätzlich Rentenniveau. Das liegt ja in Deutschland, wie wir wissen, unter 50 Prozent. Das ist ja dramatisch.
Dazu kommen wir gleich.
Genau. Und dann gibt es ja diese Ersatzquote, also dieses Konkrete, was sie jetzt meint, zum wirklich eigenen Gehalt und so. Und da liegen wir in Deutschland ja bei 65 Prozent. Und das müsste gar nicht sein. Also in Österreich über 80, Niederlande 100. Also merkt man gar nicht, dass man Rente ist, außer dass man mehr Zeit hat. Dänemark ähnlich. Also wir sind in Deutschland wirklich sehr schlecht dran. Dass ich jetzt hier 80 nennt, ist schon mutig. Denn daraus könnte man ja auch wieder Forderungen ableiten im Sinne von, es sollten schon 80 sein.
Naja, es sollten schon 80 sein. Die Frage ist nur, woher soll das Geld kommen? Das gibt dir ja schon mal nicht, Lars Klingbeil. Das haben wir gelernt.
Nee, der will ja ran an die Rente.
Ein Beispiel.
Kurzes Beispiel. Du verdienst am Ende deines Berufslebens 2500 Euro netto im Monat. 80 Prozent davon sind 2000 Euro. Und das halt pro Monat. Und wenn es gut läuft, 20 oder 30 Jahre lang. Wenn man das jetzt mal hochrechnet, kommt man schnell auf eine Summe im hohen sechsstelligen Bereich, die du dann für die Rente brauchst. Und das finde ich schon echt krass viel.
Ja, wenn man 45 Jahre lang für 2500 Euro arbeitet, dann ist das auch ganz schön viel halt in der Summe. Das ist halt wie es ist. Das ist Mathematik.
Das gesetzliche Rentenniveau liegt gerade neu festgelegt bis 2031 bei ungefähr 48 Prozent.
Jenigen, die aber in den gesetzlichen Renten einzahlen, die bekommen so als Faustregel 50 Prozent ihres letzten Nettogehaltes, Protogehaltes, das spielt da gar nicht so die größere Rolle, aber ungefähr die Größenordnung, die Hälfte bekomme ich dann als Rente auf mein Konto ausgezahlt.
Das heißt, man bekommt nicht ja 80 Prozent ausgezahlt, sondern bekommt nur die Hälfte von dem letzten Gehalt, dann merkt man, da fehlt also einiges. Wir sprechen hier von der Rentenlücke.
Zur Renteninfo. Deine Rente steigt voraussichtlich weiter, weil Renten an die Löhne gekoppelt sind. Die Deutsche Rentenversicherung rechnet mit ein oder zwei Prozent Rentensteigerungen pro Jahr. Der Mittelwert daraus, also 1,7 Prozent, gilt laut Finanztipp als realistisch. Zusätzliche Einnahmen wie private Rente, Betriebsrente oder Mieteinnahmen ziehst du von der Lücke ab. Und nicht vergessen sollte man auch die Inflation.
Wenn ich mir als junger Mensch Gedanken mache, bin beispielsweise 25, überlege also, wie viel Euro ich zur Seite legen möchte, um für die Rente vorzusagen, dann habe ich noch 40, 45 Jahre, bis ich in die Rente eintrete. Und die Inflation frisst natürlich Kaufkraft auf.
Was muss man jetzt also beachten, wenn wir jetzt mal wirklich konkret werden? Alle können ja mitrechnen, wie viel Geld braucht man. Da haben wir ein weiteres Beispiel.
Machen wir das Ganze mal mit konkreten Zahlen fest. Wir nehmen das vereinfachte Durchschnittsgehalt von 4500 Euro brutto im Monat. Das entspricht ungefähr 3000 Euro netto. Unser Rechtwert, 80 Prozent davon, sind 2400 Euro Bedarf im Alter.
Heißt aber auch, die andere Hälfte verdient die ja gerade gar nicht. Die andere Hälfte? Die andere Hälfte der Bevölkerung verdient ja gar nicht so viel.
Ach so, ja.
So, jetzt kommt die Rechnung.
Jetzt erfinden wir eine Person. Wir nennen sie Sophia. Sophia geht in 30 Jahren in Rente. Wenn wir mit zwei Prozent Inflation pro Jahr rechnen, bräuchte Sophia in 30 Jahren nicht mehr 2400 Euro, sondern 4347 Euro netto, um sich genau so viel leisten zu können wie heute.
Woher holt Sophia sich das Geld? Nun, sie könnte es anlegen. Zum Beispiel ETFs.
Jetzt zur gesetzlichen Rente. Durchschnittliche Altersrente nach mindestens 35 Beitragsjahren 1692 Euro brutto. Davon bleiben ca. 1400 Euro netto übrig. Wenn wir diese Rente mit einer jährlichen Rentensteigerung von 1,7 Prozent berechnen, macht es in 30 Jahren eine monatliche Bruttorente von 2806 Euro. Netto sind es 2026 Euro.
Ungewöhnlich viele Zahlen für dieses Programm.
Ja, sehr viele Zahlen, aber wir schaffen uns da gleich Klarheit. Nur der Redlichkeit halber will ich sie alle so nennen. Also diese… Sophia hat jetzt folgende Rentenlücke.
Sophias Rechnung zum Rentenstart. 4347 Euro Bedarf minus 2026 Euro Rente macht also 2.321 Euro Rentenlücke pro Monat. Und wichtig, bei 2% Inflation und nur 1,7% Rentensteigerung wird diese Lücke mit jedem Jahr in Rente tendenziell noch größer.
Klingt dramatisch bis hierhin?
Nein, keine Sorge, die Moderatorin spricht dir Mut zu.
Und ja, das ist machbar. Denn beim langfristigen Sparen wirkt der Zinseszinseffekt. Erträge erzeugen neue Erträge und das Vermögen wächst immer schneller. Je länger dein Anlagehorizont, desto eher kannst du in Anlagen mit höheren Renditechancen investieren, wie zum Beispiel Aktien oder ETFs und eben trotz Schwankungen. Jetzt aber zur großen Frage. Wie viel Kapital braucht man eigentlich? Da gibt es eine Zahl, die man benutzen kann, den sogenannten Rentenfaktor.
Der Rentenfaktor, der liegt bei 25. Was ist damit jetzt gemeint?
Versicherungen rechnen in vielen Angeboten mit einem Rentenfaktor von 25. Und im Grunde sagt der, dass du für je 10.000 Euro Kapital 25 Euro Rente pro Monat bekommst. Das sind 300 Euro im Jahr. Also ungefähr 3 Prozent als rechnerische Auszahlungsrate.
Das heißt, wenn du 10.000 Euro hast, dann bekommst du diese 25 Euro pro Monat ausgezahlt. Das schließt natürlich nicht deine Rentenlücke. Kannst nicht sagen, ich habe 10.000 Euro gespart, damit schließe ich meine Rentenlücke. Das reicht nicht aus.
Also um auf die Lücke von 2.000 Euro zu kommen, bräuchte ich ja dann 700.000 Euro oder was?
Ich merke, du kannst sehr gut im Kopf rechnen. Wir nähern uns dem aber schrittweise. Also die Frage ist hier wirklich ja gar nicht mehr, was läuft eigentlich falsch, dass das so ist, sondern man wird einfach gesagt, das ist das Naturgesetz, wenn man so möchte. Aber wie können wir uns jetzt nochmal individuell absichern, um doch dieses hohe Rentenniveau zu bekommen? Ja, wie könnte das möglich sein? Und dann wird jetzt also natürlich ein individueller Weg eingeschlagen. Wie viel benötigt Sophia?
Deine monatliche Rentenlücke mal 12 multipliziert mit dem Rentenfaktor 25 ergibt den Kapitalbedarf. Nach der Logik können wir auch Sophias Rechnung machen. Rentenlücke von 2.321 Euro pro Monat mal 12 macht 27.852 Euro pro Jahr. Und das mal 25 sind 696.300 Euro Kapitalbedarf. Rund 700.000 Euro, um diese Lücke zu schließen.
Ich kann wirklich sehr gut rechnen.
Perfekt ausgerechnet. Also diese 25 sind für 25 Jahre. Also man geht dann davon aus, man geht in Rente und lebt dann noch 25 Jahre.
Ich habe das mal grob überschlagen aus einer Rechnung, die ich vor 20 Jahren oder so gemacht habe. Bei einem normalen Zinssatz und ich möchte 10.000 Euro im Monat haben, wie viel Geld brauche ich? Und es waren dann so zweieinhalb Millionen oder so. Dann habe ich das einfach durch fünf geteilt und kam auf 700.000.
Wow, sehr, sehr gut. Aber jetzt nicht den Mut verlieren.
Erst mal ganz wichtig, um ein bisschen Druck rauszunehmen. Du musst diese riesigen Summen nicht alleine zusammensparen. Im Optimalfall hast du noch jahrzehntelang Zeit und lässt dir vom Kapitalmarkt, von Renditen und vom Zinseszinseffekt helfen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob mir der Kapitalmarkt jetzt gerade, es jagt ja eine Krise die nächste und dann kommt noch Kloot und sagt es eh alles anders.
Ja und ob der Kapitalmarkt nicht gerade dafür sorgt, dass dein Lohn so niedrig ist, damit die Aktienkurse steigen.
Das stimmt.
Denn da gibt es ja offenbar einen Zusammenhang. Das ist ja immer, wenn so eine Nachrichten ist, heißt es klingt wahnsinnig zynisch, aber Konzern XY hat Leute entlassen und der Börsenkurs ist nach oben gegangen. Nein, das ist der ökonomische Zusammenhang. Was ich sehr schön finde, ist damit bist du nicht allein. Und dann denkt man, ach so, da kommt jetzt Lars Klingbeil und hilft weiter.
Nein.
Du bist natürlich allein mit dem Kapitalmarkt.
Beim Thema Rente und Kapitalmarkt sind wir alle nicht alleine, weil das große Ziel von Friedrich Merz ist ja von 40 Millionen Leuten monatlich Einzahlung zu machen. Was bedeutet, in den Finanzmärkten dieser Welt, die eh schon auf Anlagesuche sind, man weiß ja gar nicht mehr wohin mit dem Geld, möchte ja Friedrich Merz, dass der ganze deutsche Staat als einer der größten Akteure überhaupt hinzutritt.
Ja.
Du bist nicht allein.
Naja.
Aber das ist nicht die Rettung.
Nee, das ist nicht die Rettung. Also man sägt ja auch immer am eigenen Ast dabei. Jetzt rechnen wir die Situation für Sophia mal durch.
Jetzt rechnen wir das gleich mal konkret für Sophia durch und nehmen dafür eine konservative Rendite von 6 Prozent pro Jahr. Dafür kann man zum Beispiel einen ETF-Sparplanrechner nutzen. Und dann schauen wir, wie viel müsste Sophia monatlich investieren, um ihre Rentenlücke zu schließen? Wir rechnen mit 30 Jahren Laufzeit.
Jetzt werden sich manche fragen, warum 6 Prozent nun. Man kann auf langen Horizont sagen, es sind etwa so 6 Prozent, wenn man vor allem auch noch die Inflation dann berücksichtigt. Also kann man da so bei real 6 Prozent vielleicht ankommen.
Das ist das Gabor Steingart-Thema.
Das ist das Thema, was wir alle schon kennen. Wie viel Geld braucht man aber dann jetzt? Also wie viel Geld muss man jetzt monatlich sparen, um an diese 700.000 zu kommen, die Stefan im Kopf errechnet hat?
Beispiel 1. 100 Euro pro Monat, kein Startkapital. Eingezahlt 36.000 Euro. Endkapital 97.451 Euro. Das Geld ist also fast verdreifacht. Gut, aber noch weit weg von Sophias Ziel.
600.000 fehlen noch. Kommt man also nicht mit weiter. Erhöhnen wir den Betrag.
Beispiel Nummer 2. 200 Euro monatlich und 10.000 Euro Startkapital. Eingezahlt hat Sophia dann also 82.000 Euro. Mit Rendite ist das Endkapital 252.338 Euro. Schon über eine Viertelmillion Euro.
Drücken wir mal die Daumen, dass jedes Jahr 6 Prozent ist.
Aber immer noch weit entfernt von 700.000.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
450.000 noch entfernt. Wie wäre es denn, wenn man 30 Jahre lang es schafft, 500 Euro abzugeben von dem Einkommen? Das ist ja schon eine gewaltige Summe plus noch ein Startkapital.
Kommen wir zum Beispiel Nummer drei. 500 Euro monatlich plus 20.000 Euro Startkapital. Eingezahlt hat sie über 30 Jahre 200.000 Euro. Endkapital sind dann 602.126 Euro. Damit ist Sophias Rentenlücke von rund 696.000 Euro fast geschlossen. Es fehlen noch ungefähr 94.000 Euro.
Warum sagt sie fast geschlossen, wenn noch fast 200.000 Euro fehlen? Das verstehe ich nicht. Das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich zu reinstem Alarmismus führen, dass man sagt, 500 Euro müsste man haben, damit das geht. 500 Euro jeden Monat weglegen, 30 Jahre lang und natürlich dann auch noch hoffen, dass das mit den Kapitalmärkten sich genauso entwickelt, wie das jetzt in der Vergangenheit der Fall war.
Ja, also wenn du dann in der kleinen biografischen Lücke, in der du dich mitversicherst, das auch nicht mehr kannst, also dir da auch nochmal 275 Euro in diesem Zeitraum fehlen und sowieso die Rampe des Transfers sofort als Entzug verdeutlicht wird, dann würde ich sagen, das könnten bei den Einstiegsniveaus, die wir haben und so 5 Prozent der Leute leisten über 36 Jahre, oder was sie da hatten.
Und die machen das, die gucken sich auch wahrscheinlich das Video gar nicht extra an, sondern die wissen das eh.
Und die haben dann einfach nur Inflation zurückgerechnet, 2400 Euro im Monat später.
Ja.
Jaja, also das ist ja...
Absurd.
Es ist wirklich absurd. Und das finde ich das Interessante, die Zahlen stimmen ja, die sie nennt.
Aber sie haben es mal durchgerechnet.
Sie rechnen es durch, es stimmt alles. Also ich brauche jetzt nicht hier kommen, da müssen wir mal einen Faktencheck machen. Und trotzdem ist die ideologische Verschleierung maximal.
Aber in der Hinsicht ist die Aufklärung über, was bedeuten 500 Euro im Monat, die du aufbringen musst, sind dann für die Zuschauer und für mich auch sehr viel drastischer als jetzt im Vergleich zu 800 Milliarden Sonderverbögen.
Ja, ganz genau.
Da wird es dann nämlich grenzlich.
Nämlich den Leuten zuzuhoben, wenn ihr auf das Rentenniveau kommen wollt, wenn ihr wie Sophia gerne die Ansprüche dann hättet, müsst ihr 500 Euro und wir haben aber jetzt ja schon gehört, es fehlen ja 94.000 Euro, selbst wenn man 500 Euro jeden Monat spart.
Dann kommt in einem Halbsatz noch die Besteuerung von Kapitalerträgen, lassen wir an der Stelle erstmal weg.
Warum lässt man das weg? Man kann ja sich genau diese ETF-Rechner im Internet ansehen und kann das einfach anklicken, dass das bitte mit drin ist. Habe ich dann auch mal gemacht, habe mir also Sophias Fall genommen, diese 700.000 und habe dann einmal gefragt, wie viel brauche ich dann? 30 Jahre, Startkapital 20.000, 6% Rendite plus das, was dann besteuert wird. Das kommt nicht auf alles Kapitalerträge. Da gibt es eine Sonderregelung bei ETFs zum Beispiel. Je nachdem, wie viel Aktien drin sind, das ist ja bei ETF der Fall, gibt es da auch eine gewisse Vergünstigung. Aber man kommt, ich muss die Rechnung jetzt nicht in allen Kleinigkeiten hier ausführen, man kommt auf folgenden Betrag. Also um wirklich die Rentenlücke von Sophia zu schließen und die Steuer zu berücksichtigen, müsste sie 30 Jahre lang 670 Euro zahlen. Dann wäre erst dieses Niveau erreicht. Plus 20.000 Euro Startkapital.
Wie realistisch ist das?
Gar nicht.
Auch hier würde ich wieder sagen, die Leute, die diesen Beitrag gemacht haben, das ist doch auch für die nicht realistisch. Das ist doch absurd. Weiter heißt es da.
Wenn du selbst überlegen willst, wie viel du sparen kannst, hilft als grobe Orientierung die 50-30-20-Regel. 50 Prozent für Fixkosten, 30 für persönliche Ausgaben und 20 Prozent fürs Sparen.
Nein, diese Regel hilft nicht. Wenn die 670 Euro 20 Prozent ausmachen sollen, in einer Stadt wie Frankfurt bezahlt die Hälfte der Leute die Hälfte ihres Einkommens nur fürs Wohnen. Also es ist nur ein Fixkosten. Hinzu kommen dann alle anderen Sachen, liebe Damen und Herren. Und dann sollen 20 Prozent 670 Euro sein. Das geht nicht.
Nee, kann nicht gehen.
Also das ist ja dann, wenn man das Bruttodurchschnittsgehalt als Netto ausgezahlt kriegt, dann geht das. Aber dann liegt man in den Top 20 Prozent.
Weiter oben noch.
Also das ist.
Man liegt noch deutlich weiter oben. Also 670 Euro abzugeben, dann ist man irgendwo bei den oberen 10, 5 Prozent.
Also oberstehendezentil oder wie es heißt, also die Top 10 Prozent Deziel Marke sind 7.800 Euro Netto im Monat.
Nee, nee.
Brutto. Ja, 4.400 Brutto ist Median und dann ja, ja, geht nicht auf. Musste einfach 1000 Euro mehr machen.
Ja genau, wie so ein Influenz. Wer war das nochmal? Ah, Jeremy Fracrets, der hat das auch mal so durchgerechnet. Vor allem kommt ihnen dann, gibt es ja noch mehr Kosten.
Und die Pflege kann ich drehen.
Vor allen Dingen, ich muss noch mal gerade sagen mit diesen 20-Prozent-Regelungen. Also erstmal, wie viel man sparen kann, das muss man ja erstmal selbst nachvollziehen an den Kosten, die man so hat. Das ist ja so eine Regelung 50, 30, 20. Die gilt eben für diese oberen 5% oder oberen 7%. Die können sich mit so einer Regelung irgendwie behelfen. Die meisten Leute verkonsumieren ihr Einkommen und dann können sie gucken, ob sie noch etwas davon abknapfen können. Aber für die stellt sich nicht die Frage, ob sie 20% irgendwo hinschieben. Klar, wenn man 10.000 im Monat hat, dann kann man das alles so lustig machen. Jetzt ist ja diese Rentenlücke vielleicht geschlossen mit den von mir errechneten 670 Euro pro Monat. Aber da könnte ja noch was kommen.
Und die Pflege kann nicht richtig teuer werden. Stand 2025 liegt der durchschnittliche Eigenanteil für einen Pflegeheimplatz im ersten Jahr bei 3.128 Euro pro Monat. Monat! Und das ist nur der Durchschnitt.
Ja, da sagt sie dazu, dass das mit Einkommen nicht zu machen ist, sondern nur mit Vermögen. Und sei es das verpflegte Eigenheim der Eltern?
Nein. Aber das kannst du auch noch sparen mit dem ETF dann.
Bundesweiten Caritas Erhebung. Die haben nämlich rausgefunden, dass Pflegebedürftige im Schnitt ungefähr 25 Monate in stationären Pflegeeinrichtungen verbringen. Wenn man mal 25 Monate mal 3.108 Euro nimmt, sind es rund 77.700 Euro. Das heißt also, es lohnt sich für die eigene Altersvorsorge mindestens rund 80.000 Euro zusätzlich für einen möglichen Pflegefall mitzudenken. Besser etwas mehr, weil natürlich kann Pflege auch länger dauern.
Das heißt, du brauchst am Ende 800.000 Euro, um Rentenlücke zu schließen und die Pflege. Und dann bist du, glaube ich, irgendwann so bei etwa 800 Euro, die du im Monat nochmal so extra sparen musst, angekommen.
Fehlt eigentlich nur noch so ein expliziter Satz, dass die 25 Monate dann beendet werden durch Tod. Aber es kann schlecht laufen, dann lebst du länger noch.
Ja, kommen wir zu dem Fazit, lass dich nicht entmutigen.
Du kannst dich nicht mehr darauf verlassen, dass die gesetzliche Rente alleine reicht. Aber die gute Nachricht ist, du hast es zu großen Teilen selbst in der Hand. Trotzdem in der Rente auch für nichts verzichten zu müssen. Mit kostengünstigen ETFs als Basis, optional ergänzt durch Dividendenstrategien oder andere Bausteine, kannst du dir über Jahrzehnte systematisch Vermögen aufbauen.
Ja, gegen Armut hilft ganz einfach, reich werden. Das können wir hier auch nur weitergeben. Das ist sehr gut. Wie kann das sein? Also wie kann es sein, dass man alle Zahlen hat, Zahlen, die mich jetzt auch nochmal schockiert haben? Ich war auch echt nochmal überrascht über einzelne Details, wie teuer es dann im Ganzen ist, was da auf einen zukommt. Wenn man all das so gründlich recherchiert hat, dass man dann zu einer solchen ideologischen Schlussfolgerung kommen kann, ist es mir ein Rätsel.
Also das Fernsehen funktioniert ja so, dass du erstens ausführst, was sich die Programmredaktion ausgedacht hat und dass du zweitens ganz ernst nimmst, was du an deiner Journalistenausbildung lernst, nämlich dass ich da gar keine Rolle spiele. Ich rede hier nur. Ich spreche nur den Text. So, und dann rechnest du halt Sachen durch und sprichst sie halt ein.
Ja.
Das war's.
Kommen wir nun zu jemandem, dem es finanziell besser geht, nämlich Oliver Pocher. Ich erlaube mir einen ganz kurzen Disclaimer, weil ich jetzt gleich über das Geschäftsmodell von Oliver Pocher reden will und auch zeigen will, wie er ein hoch interessantes Phänomen ist, um den neuen Medienmarkt zu verstehen, um den Medienwandel zu begreifen. Wir blicken immer sehr viel nach Amerika, nach so provokanten YouTubern und Twitch-Streamern und was die da so alles machen und wie verrückt das ist. Wir haben aber auch jemanden, den wir eigentlich mal genauer unter die Lupe nehmen können, um zu sehen, wie funktioniert das eigentlich, ein solches Business. Und der Disclaimer ist nur der, dass ich natürlich hier nicht Oliver Pocher in dem Sinne loben möchte. Ich will ja nur sagen, dass er offenbar was verstanden hat, was andere nicht verstanden haben. Ich will vor allem auch nochmal unterstreichen, dass ich weder politisch mit ihm auf einer Wellenlänge bin, noch finde ich es gut, wie er über Frauen des Öfteren gesprochen hat. Nur das als Disclaimer. Es war auch für mich nicht leicht, drei Stunden Podcast mit ihm zu hören. Er war bei Tom Junkersdorf im Tomorrow Podcast zu Gast. Es war aber für mich deshalb interessanter, überhaupt anzuklicken, weil da schon stand, das erste Mal redet er über Business. Das machte er sonst nicht. Meine Vorstellung von Oliver Pocher war die, der ist offenbar nicht mehr erfolgreich im Fernsehen, bekommt da keine tollen Angebote mehr, deswegen treut er jetzt in den sozialen Medien herum. Das war so meine Kurzanalyse, die aber ziemlich falsch ist. Oliver Pocher verrät zwar keine Zahlen, aber er hat eine eigene App aufgelegt, die funktioniert so, dass dort Zusatzinhalte zu erleben sind, die er produziert mit seinem Team zusammen. Ob das eine Gelofarin-Parodie ist, Interviews mit dem Wendler oder seiner Frau Laura, also der Wendlerfrau Laura, was auch immer, bis hin zu einem Pornodreh, den er in Las Vegas besucht hat oder in Los Angeles. Er macht also Inhalte, die im Prinzip so funktionieren, wie das auch bei Bild Plus ist. Also da, wo es dann nochmal so richtig ins Eingemachte geht, da kann man dann dafür zahlen. Er ist ja jemand, der sowohl bei RTL war, als dann auch als Podcaster bei RTL und Podimo. Er ist jemand, der sehr erfolgreich war, mit Harald Schmidt ja auch eine Zeit lang. Das war allerdings nicht besonders erfolgreich, diese Show zusammenmachte. Jedenfalls hat er da so ein neues Business gegründet. Und was man auch dort in dem Interview erfährt, ist, dass es da auch so eine große Agenturstruktur gibt, wo Künstler mit unter Vertrag sind. Das heißt, er scheint sehr im Business zu sein und versteht sehr viel vom Business. Wie hoch die Aufrufzahlen jetzt dieser Apps sind, ist mir nicht so klar. Aber er hat da doch zumindest, wenn man sich diese viralen Hits ansieht, sehr viel richtig gemacht. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, das macht er gut, sondern ich sage, es scheint zu funktionieren, weil ich zum Beispiel Oliver Pocher auch laufend sehe bei mir in der Timeline, aber nicht seinen direkten Content. Ja, ich folge jetzt nicht Oliver Pocher, so schlimm ist es noch nicht. Aber ich sehe natürlich ganz viele Leute, die laufend auf ihn reagieren, weil er wieder irgendwas gesagt hat, wo er besser vielleicht hätte nichts zu sagen sollen. Tom Junkersdorf interviewt ihn also jetzt hier, wir hören mal rein.
So Zeilen lese so von wegen, ja super Quote für Joko und Klaas, keine Ahnung, 20% Marktanteil und dann schaust du rein und siehst, haben sie aber auch nicht mehr. Und dann siehst du 1,5 Millionen Zuschauer.
Auch nicht mehr. Es sind eher 1.900.980.020%, haben die schon lange nicht mehr. Es ist viel, viel weniger. Also die absoluten Zahlen sind, und das ist von der GfK hochgerechnet, erschreckend wenig. Also ProSieben macht im Regelfall fünf Tage die Woche gar nicht mehr über eine Million Zuschauer. Nee, die das überhaupt gucken. In der Primetime.
Das Fernsehen ist für ihn ziemlich tot. Geld nicht nur für ProSieben, sondern auch für RTL.
Also auch bei RTL ist ja genau dasselbe, ist ja auch ein Trauerspiel. Die haben ja auch selten nur noch irgendwie über 1,5 Millionen Zuschauer. Also es gibt Wer wird Millionär? Das gucken halt 2,5-3 Millionen am Montag. Bauer sucht Frau, wird noch irgendwie ein bisschen konsumiert. Und dann wird es aber und Let's Dance, also Ninja Warrior, 1,2, 1,3 Millionen und auch...
Ninja Warrior ist das einzige von dem, was er hier nennt, was bei mir regelmäßig läuft, weil ich ja neunjährigen zu Hause habe. Da jetzt im Keller auch eigene Sachen so rumbauen.
Ich dachte, dass du jetzt auch da dich bald abbewerbst.
Ja, es ist eine interessante Sendung, weil das Production-Ratio ist jetzt nicht so hoch im Vergleich zu aus der Sicht der 100.000 Mark-Show, was die damals da abgerissen haben.
Man mietet der Turnhalle im Prinzip und lässt die da machen.
Für mich ist das Fernsehen und ich gucke nichts sowieso in diesen Vorabend oder wie das heißt. Also First Dates, das sind Kameras in dem Restaurant und Leute reden halt und essen dabei.
Das ist Bock, ja.
Genau. Dinner, also man fährt irgendwo hin und jemand kocht. Das ist einfach nur anwesende Kamera. Also eigentlich so voyeurisch, aber in dem positiven Sinne, voyeurisch Fernsehen. Also einfach, das kostet auch nichts mehr. Von daher würde ich sagen, eine Million Zuschauer sind da gar nicht so wenig.
Na ja.
Bei Joko und Klaasen läuft natürlich ein anderes Kosten.
Vox hat es ja immer verstanden, sehr effizient zu produzieren. Auch dieses ganze perfekte Dinner und ähnliche Formate, die Shopping Queen, das sind ja keine teuren Formate.
Das sind eigentlich gar keine Formate. Die sind einfach nur abgefilmte Sachen.
Ja, da kommt halt ein Team mit und irgendwas passiert. Aber wir reden ja jetzt hier von Shows, die tatsächlich relativ viel kosten. Also so etwas wie Let's Dance. Da werden Stars einfach drei Monate lang in Köln, im Savoy oder was weiß ich wo untergebracht und müssen üben. Und weiß ich nicht was. Man hat dort eine Band, eine Jury. Das ist alles sehr, sehr aufwendig. Und wenn dann, wie Pocher auch da sagt, der Erfolg gar nicht so groß ist, beziehungsweise die Quote sehr schnell schon unter drei Millionen, dann kommt bei Let's Dance, dann fragt man sich schon, funktioniert das für Werbepartner? Er redet sehr ausführlich, das habe ich jetzt nicht alles mitgebracht, darüber, dass diese Ermittlung, der Marktanteil ja immer noch über diese 4000 Geräte, die irgendwo in Deutschland aufgestellt sind, funktioniert. Womit man dann so hochrechnen will, wie hoch die Quote ist und wer was, wie lange geguckt hat. Dabei, muss man sagen, haben wir ja heute ganz andere Tools durch die Digitalisierung und die nutzt er. Also, dass er dann ganz anderer Weise seinen möglichen Werbepartner vorlegen kann, wen er wie lange erreicht, verglichen mit dem, was dann ein Fernsehsender sagen kann, ja, wir sind gestern in der Quote so und so gestiegen. Das ist dann gar nicht mehr so zeitgemäß. Vor allem finde ich ja hier auch noch interessant, dass er ja bis vor kurzem im Fernsehen war, aber dann doch sieht, obwohl es für ihn ja ganz gut läuft, das funktioniert nicht mehr so. Und was wir ja gerade bei RTL gut erleben können oder überhaupt im Fernsehen gut erleben können, ist, dass es ja fast keine neuen Gesichter mehr gibt. Also, du guckst RTL und hier wurde es schon genannt.
Keine.
Wer wird Millionär? Günther Jauch geht auf die 70 zu.
Ja, also ich finde, ich sehe es ja immer nur so in Hotels oder so. Ich schalte den Fernseher ein. Ich sehe ausschließlich Gesichter, die ich aus meiner Kindheit kenne.
Aus deiner Schulzeit kenne.
Frauke Ludewig. Frauke Ludewig. Dann irgendwo sitzt der Hohäcker rum und löst ein Rätsel.
Katja Burkhardt.
Es ist alles dasselbe. Es ist, als ob die Zeit stehengeblieben ist.
Ja, ja, man hat auch den Eindruck, muss ich mich gleich auf eine HY vorbereiten, dass ich morgen um neun in die Schule oder wann. Und das ist ja durchgängig so. Und das zeigt natürlich sehr viel, also dass auch diese Rettungsversuche gemacht werden, mit Gottschalk bis zum geht dich mehr bei RTL, dass man Jan Hofer zu RTL holt. Nur noch ältere Gesichter. Pocher noch mal über ProSieben.
Also wenn da so ne Tilumischke-Docke läuft oder Jänke oder so mit so vier, 500.000 Zuschauern gemessen am Montag, das ist eigentlich, das ist egal. Und also Stefan Raab oder wenn irgendwelche Markteinkeile kommen, 14 bis 49, hat er 70.000 Zuschauer dann um 23.15. Da sag ich ja dann auch immer, das macht ne Story von mir in einer Stunde schon, die das gesehen haben. Dann kann ich ja sagen, das haben wirklich 70.000 in der ersten Stunde gesehen und dann geht das irgendwie bei 400, 500.000 oder 300.000 oder wie auch immer hört das dann auf. Ein Reel, was ich mache, das merke ich dann ja auch. Wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt nach einem Dschungelcamp irgendwie so ein Gil Ofarim parodiere, dann haben so die größten Reels 6, 7, 8 Millionen Aufrufe im Social Media.
Ja, aber er profitiert ja noch voll davon, dass der Herr Hegemann, weil er selber das Fernsehgesicht war, dass Leute glauben, das was er jetzt gerade macht, ist irgendwie so tonangebend. Also gucke ich mir den Scherz auch kurz an.
Ja, er geht, er hat aber genau diesen Schritt erkannt, dass er jetzt nicht mehr den Sender braucht, sondern selbst zum Sender wird. Bei Stefan Raab ist es genau umgekehrt, über den spricht er oder sagen wir lästert er ausführlich.
Und bei Stefan ist jetzt der Punkt, man hätte sich nur mal seine Vita anschauen müssen, warum das keine seiner Sendungen, die er produziert hat in den letzten 20 Jahren, jemals wirklich funktioniert hat. Und das ist immer nur das Ding des Jahres, so eine Höhle der Löwenkopie nicht funktioniert, obwohl da Joko drin saß und Dings und Lena Gerke. Dann hat er mit Teddy eine Show um die Gongshow gemacht, mit Teddy eine Show, wie man gegen Teddy antritt. Heddis, Eisfußball, Eisfootball, täglich frisch geröstet. Also die Liste der Flops ist immens, nichts hat funktioniert. Und dann sagt man, ja, machen wir, finde ich gut. Aber sie wollten einfach Stefan Raab.
Ja, Sie haben jetzt Stefan Raab bekommen.
Ich kenne ja keine Einzelne, die diese Sendung, wann hat Stefan Raab solche Sendungen gemacht?
Na ja, der hat ja als er aufgehört hat auch weiter produziert. Und auch während er ja selbst seine Sendung machte, hatte der auch andere Sachen produziert.
Reinmachen Stefan Raab, habe ich ja auch schon erklärt, hat es gemacht aus, weil er Jörg Rabosch es zeigen wollte, damals sich ja getrennt hat, dann mit Bunny Jai zusammengegangen ist, dann bei Bunny Jai sich mit denen überworfen hat. Er wollte gegen Sebastian Puff-Puff, mit dem er sich da wirklich gezofft hat, auch hinter den Kulissen, gegen TV total, deswegen auf den Sendeplatz. Er wollte gegen ProSieben gehen.
Comeback als Racheakt, so meint er, sei das zu verstehen.
Das hat ja jeder gesehen. Die erste Sendung haben wir auch gesehen. Ich gehe im Büro, das war...
Ja, und das Comeback sah dann so aus, Pocher schildert es.
Und sehr sinnbildlich für Stefans Karriere ist diese Treppe. Also er kommt ganz oben an und das war der Höhepunkt eines Comebacks. Und dann kam der langsame, lange Abstieg auf dieser Treppe, genau wie es dann da gewesen ist. Da war nichts Neues dabei. Da sind dann sie. Ich glaube, Chiago war noch kurz dabei. Das war das modernste, was es gab. Sonst war es nur Helge Schneider, Sido, alles nichts Neues. Auch Social Media, ich meine, der macht ein Video, wie er wieder zurückkommt. Marketing strategisch sensationell am 1. April. Alle wissen nicht, April-Shirts oder ernsthaft. Mit einem Video, das irgendwie 60, 66 Millionen Views hat. Und dann hast du diese Followerzahlen, dann machst du aus deinem Instagram-Account gar nichts und denkst dir, alter, weißt du nicht, wie Social Media funktioniert? Du hast doch Kinder. Lass es dir doch von denen mal erklären.
Das ist ja so etwas, was Oliver Pocher macht, dass er auf all diesen Plattformen präsent ist. Und damit ist er ja jemand, der sich ja so löst von diesem klassischen Fernsehsystem. Jemand, der sich auch herausbegibt aus der Logik der Fernsehmacher. Und weil er jetzt ja auch auf diesem Antibog-Trip so ist, begibt er sich aus allem raus, wo die Compliance-Abteilung sagen würde, lasst mal lieber. Er sagt dann bei Loll, da müssen erst, also dieses LOL-Format von Amazon, da müssen dann erst deutsche Anwälte, dann amerikanische Anwälte drüber blicken. Dem entzieht er sich, macht also das, was die Influencer und die Content-Creator machen, nutzt sein Fernsehgesicht dafür und auch seine Erfahrung, die er da hat, dass er das in dieser Weise machen kann. Er zeigt aber damit ja eigentlich sehr gut, dass er versteht, wie man sich so herausbewegen kann aus diesem so festgefahrenen System. Und ich meine, wir haben jetzt ja gerade aus dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen auch wieder so eine interessante Meldung bekommen, dass dort bei Funk Alexander Prinz, also der dunkle Parabelritter, gekündigt hat, weil er sagte, ich halte das hier nicht mehr aus. Die wollen so viele extra Fakten, Schecks und was weiß ich, alles, bis ich überhaupt mal was rausbringen kann. Das macht er nicht mehr mit. Über Medien hat er ein langes Interview dazugegeben. Das ist etwas, was wir jetzt immer mehr sehen werden, weil diese Entwicklung, das Privatfernsehen läuft sich ziemlich tot. Das andere ist auch völlig mutlos und verängstigt. Jetzt kommt hinzu, dass Pocher nicht einfach sagte, ich mache mal eine eigene Comedy-Sendung, sondern die Art, wie er provoziert, die Art, wie er uns auch empört und auch zu Recht empört. Das will ich gleich hinzufügen. Sorgt natürlich in der Logik, die er dort internalisiert hat. Und das ist die Logik der Plattform, dass Engagement das Entscheidende ist, dafür, dass er eine extreme Reichweite aufbauen kann. Für mich ist Oliver Pocher heute wesentlich mehr präsent als zu Fernsehzeiten.
Ich sehe den nie und ich hänge echt viel.
Naja, also ich meine jetzt, wenn man sich in diesem bisschen Boulevard-Ding rumtummelt. Du folgst ja den Seriösern und sagst, du teilst ja Videos von Christine Lagarde. Aber wenn du jetzt, ja...
Naja, ich habe auch eine verspielte Seite auf Instagram. Das bietet sich ja sehr an, aber...
Aber wenn du jetzt wirklich sagst, ich bin in diesem Reality-TV, in dem Bereich, wo Heino Brigitte Nielsen küsst oder so, ja, dann ist das da, wo Oliver Pocher ständig in Erscheinung tritt. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist heute mehr als vor zehn Jahren, als er vielleicht einfach eine feste Fernsehsendlerin hatte, wo man ihn dann einmal die Woche sehen konnte. Da ich nie RTL geguckt habe, habe ich den nicht gesehen. Heute eine ganz andere Präsenz. Woran liegt das? Naja, das kann man jetzt ganz gut hier nachvollziehen, wie er da arbeitet. Pocher hatte mit seiner, äh, jetzt Ex-Frau oder von der lebt er getrennt, Amira, ja einen Podcast bei RTL und der wanderte dann zu Podimo. Er beschreibt das erstmal so, also so ein Couple Podcast.
Und dann ist der Vertrag bei RTL ausgelaufen und die haben dann auch sehr zügig, als es auf den allen Plattformen waren. Wir sind sofort da auf eins geschossen bei Spotify, Apple, überall. Wir waren so mit Drosten Podcast und so waren wir da gleich ganz vorne. Und nach zwei Folgen hat RTL auch gesagt, packen wir doch exklusiv bei uns mal auf die Plattform und nicht mehr bei den anderen. Haben auch schnell reagiert. Und dann nach zwei Jahren war die Frage, wie sieht es aus? Wie geht es weiter? Und RTL hat dann eine gewisse Arroganz auch gehabt und hier und das und Mitsprache und da und wie sieht es denn aus? Podimo hat uns ein Angebot gemacht. Wir sind hingegangen, haben gesagt, das bietet uns Podimo. Match das und wir bleiben aufgrund, dass wir das mit euch gestartet haben, bei euch. Das hat der RTL so nicht gesehen und du druckst es rum und dann ist das wie einer freien Marktwirtschaft. Dann sagst du ja gut, alles klar.
Da ist er noch in dem System, wenn es die einen nicht machen, dann machen wir es bei den anderen. Ist also dann noch nicht zu der App übergegangen. Aber es kommt ja dann zu der Trennung von Amira. Das hast du wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, dass die sich getrennt haben.
Dass er danach viel lästert, habe ich immer wieder über Bande erfahren.
So, sehr gut. Das ist das richtige Stichwort, weshalb ja auch dann so viel Kritik von feministischer Seite kommt. Ich kenne mich überhaupt in diesen ganzen Äußerungen, die er da irgendwo trifft, nicht aus. Was er wo gesagt hat, weil ich das eigentlich so handelt habe, wenn ich ihn irgendwo sehe, dann klicke ich es nicht an. Das war jetzt mit diesem Podcast eine Ausnahme, weil mich wirklich dieses Geschäftsmodell interessiert hat. Aber du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, von Simon David Tresla und Ole Liebel. Die haben in ihrem Podcast mal über diese Lux-Maxing-Leute gesprochen, die wie Clavicula und andere, die permanent streamen oder auf irgendwelchen Events auftreten. Und andere Leute, das ist, glaube ich, das Wort Mocken. Also, dass man, dass man, man mockt jemand im Sinne von, du verspottest ihn, du machst, du machst dich über den lustig, du stellst dich als der bessere dar. Und dass diese dauerhafte Provokation auch so ausgelegt ist, dass es kein entlarvendes Interview geben kann. Ja, mit dem, da war ja auch die New York Times, hat ja mit ihm gesprochen, dann lässt er ja nochmal selbst eine Kamera mitlaufen. Das heißt, er sagt nicht, ich gebe euch ein Interview, sondern er sagt, ich bringe aber auch mein Team mit, dann ich verwerte das auch nochmal. Und diese permanenten Provokationen, bis dahin, dass Clavicula wohl jemanden mit dem Auto überfahren hat und sich dabei filmen ließ und dann das Gesicht dabei nicht verzog, um zu zeigen, ich bin so stark und eisern, dass ich selbst das Schlimmste tue. Dass also diese extremen, damit aber viral gehenden Hits jetzt das Prinzip geworden sind, mit dem man die ganze Zeit seine Reichweite steigern kann, ist etwas, was man jetzt in abgeschwächter Form, natürlich im Boulevard, im Reality-TV überall finden kann. Also das ist ja nur die extremste Ausprägung dessen. Und wenn wir jetzt hören, wie Oliver Pocher seine Trennung mit Amira verarbeitet hat, dann müssen wir erst einmal einen Schritt zurück gehen und uns erinnern an die It Girls, wo du jetzt eben sagst, wie du früher als Kind an Fernseh geguckt hast, was Frauke Ludewig anmoderiert hat. Dann war ja da so etwas, dass Jenny Elvers irgendeine Affäre hatte oder Nattel ist nicht mehr mit Bohlen zusammen und jetzt mit Ralf Siegel. Die hatten ja folgendes Problem. Die waren zwar jeden Tag in der Bild und bei RTL, aber davon haben die ja nichts gehabt, außer dass sie vielleicht auf eine Gala eingeladen werden und irgendeinen Moderationsjob haben oder vielleicht vom Playboy angerufen werden.
Die haben schon immer Home-Stories angeboten, für die sind natürlich gute Gagen.
Da haben sie schon mal was Geld bekommen, aber das hielt sich in Grenzen. Sie hatten das nicht so richtig in der Hand. Anders funktioniert das bei Oliver Pocher seit seiner App. Er sagte, naja, ich habe ja hier meinen Content. Pocher über diese Trennung.
Also als es die Trennung von Amira und mir gab, die relativ öffentlichkeitswirksam ja dann geworden ist, hat die BILD-Zeitung jeden Tag zwei Artikel rausgehauen. Ich weiß, dass die damit hunderttausende von Euros verdient haben über BILD Plus Abos, die die Leute da reihenweise abgeschlossen haben. Und wir sind da einfach ein Geldfaktor.
Folgende Überlegungen jetzt für Pocher?
Wer sagt jetzt was? Wer hat das? Wer ist hier? Was ist da? Wie geht das weiter und so? Dann gehe ich doch auf Tour. Also gehen wir damit raus. Dann habe ich gesagt, wir gehen jetzt auf Tour. Wann denn? So schnell wie es geht. Und dann ist von Trennung bis zur Tour drei Monate. Bis zum ersten Termin. Wir haben die Hallen sofort gebucht, sind aufgetreten, haben gesagt, welche Teilen gibt es? Mir ist scheißegal. Ich kann heute in Hamburg spielen, morgen in München, danach in Dresden und dann wieder in Hamburg. Wo ist frei? Wo können wir spielen? Und dann habe ich das halt gemacht und dann haben wir die Tour gespielt und haben damit, klar, aus der tragischen Situation aber trotzdem was gemacht. Was euch nach Hause setzt, nämlich über die Boulevardpresse aufregen.
Ich glaube, wir machen uns zu viel Gedanken über die Inhalte, wenn wir auftreten.
Also Inhalte sind generell hinderlich, wenn man Geld verdienen will. Das sieht man hier ganz deutlich.
Wir sollten auch einfach auftreten und sagen, wir denken uns irgendwas aus.
Wir könnten sagen, dass wir uns gezopft haben oder wir zoffen uns auf der Bühne und dann sagen wir, das ist der letzte Auftritt.
Du hast Sushi gegessen. Das wollen die Leute auch wissen.
Dann machen wir eine Woche später wieder, dass wir doch wieder auftreten. Ja, es ist alles so schräg. Jetzt wird das dann wieder aufgenommen und wieder verwertet für die App, wo man dann hinter die Paywall gehen kann, um diesen Streit weiter zu erleben. Zwischenzeitlich kam dann in diesem Couple-Podcast die Ex-Frau Sandy Meyer-Wölden zurück. Sandy Meyer-Wölden ist aber jetzt auch wieder weg und wurde durch Pietro Lombardi ersetzt. Du erinnerst dich, der Deutschland sucht den Superstar? Ich erinnere mich, der auch jetzt geschieden ist oder wieder neu. Ich weiß es nicht. Jedenfalls haben die Herren viel zu bereden dann auch nochmal. Wir hören auch da mal, wie er das schildert.
Wie hart ist es für Sandy jetzt, ihr habt ein Zusammenbusiness gemacht, ihr habt ja den Podcast zusammen gemacht, sie ist ja dann eingesprungen, ihr wart bei Podimo und wart super bezahlt und jetzt sagst du, ok, du machst eine andere Entscheidung, du holst das Ganze in deine eigene Company, du gründest deine eigene App, du gründest deinen eigenen Pocher-Club, der Podcast kommt da rein und du hast Pedro Lombardi, der bei dir im Keller wohnt und du...
Der wohnt bei ihm.
Also, es war kein Scherz, ok.
Nein, nein.
Du sagst, hey, wir machen das zusammen, aber das bedeutet doch für sie dann auch, dass sie raus ist aus dem Business. Ist das etwas, was du auch trennen kannst?
Ja, also ich kann das sehr gut trennen, sie dann irgendwann nicht, weil dann irgendwann natürlich dann auf dem Konto es anders aussieht als vorher und dann werden die Mädels wieder freundlicher und dann kommt ja, ach Mensch, wie sieht es denn aus? Oder so irgendwie. Ja gut, alles klar. Dann schauen wir uns das an und dann wehren wir ab, ob das irgendwie auch, ich verteile keine Geschenke.
Richtig guter Podcast-Content jetzt, da Collien Fernandes mit Schusssicherer Weste in Berlin und das auch nochmal betont und so weiter, dass man sagt, übrigens morgen kommt die neue Ausgabe, sie kam wieder angekrochen, sie braucht Geld.
Ja, so redet er.
Freut euch auf den Content. Ja, das ist genau, was ich sehen will.
Ja, aber ich habe dir ja gesagt, eben zu dem Fall Collien, wie dort die Kommentarspalten vollgesaut werden. Anders kann man es ja gar nicht ausdrücken. Und das sind alles potenzielle Abonnenten für eine solche App, wo der sagt, der redet mal noch tacheles mit den Weibern.
Also hier kann man aber vielleicht diese Zäsur mal machen. Das sind alles Jungs in den Podcasts machen für Jungs. Richtig erfolgreich, zum Beispiel auf Instagram, gegen die er ja konkurriert, sind aber wirklich Frauen.
Auch?
Allein, weil es über den Körper läuft und das Visuelle.
Aber er ist extrem erfolgreich bei Instagram.
Ja, aber ich sag dir, in der Fläche ist das Phänomen, Frauen machen Content für Frauen und Männer. Und Männer machen Content für eine spezielle Art von Männern. Also ich bin noch nicht ganz so... Das stimmt.
Nur, er braucht ja gar nicht mehr die Fläche. Also er muss ja nicht von acht Millionen Menschen, die am Samstagabend zuschauen, geliebt werden, sondern für ihn wird das erreichen, wenn einige Hunderttausend diese App abonnieren und er zugleich noch ein weiteres Netzwerk aufmachen kann. Das scheint ja zu funktionieren. Ich kenne seine Zahlen nicht, aber wenn er sagt, er geht dann monatelang auf Tournee damit, wo er noch mal seine Beziehung erklärt und entsprechend über die Frauen redet, mit denen er zusammen war, dann würde man ja denken, gibt es da irgendwie auch nur 100 Menschen, die so irre sind, sich das anzusehen? Nein, es gibt offenbar 10.000, die da hin pilgern.
In meinem Hinterkopf ist halt die Frage, warum diese Frauen nicht einen eigenen Podcast machen.
Meine Frage ist, wieso geht man überhaupt in eine Beziehung mit Oli Pocher?
Ja, das ist natürlich, aber rein unter diesen Business-Gesichtspunkten.
Ja, das ist das Interessante. Oliver Pocher beschreibt ja jetzt hier keine Zauberrei, sondern er macht ja etwas, was sowieso auf der Hand liegt. Nur ist interessant, dass sehr viele sich ja offenbar aus dieser Logik nicht herauslösen können und dann doch wieder aus dem Fernseher. Ich kenne jetzt auch aus dem seriöseren Spektrum natürlich Leute aus dem Fernsehen oder generell aus einem öffentlichen Mediensystem, die keine Vorstellung davon haben, dass man vielleicht auch mal was machen kann, wo nicht ein Sender dabei ist oder wo man nicht noch fünf Fördervereine mit drin hat und sieben Stiftungen, mit denen man sich alle noch mal ins Benehmen setzen muss. Das will ich ja nur damit sagen, damit wir aber diese Pocher-Logik verstehen. Also das geht ja einmal jetzt hier mit und gegen die Ex-Frauen, je nachdem wie das so gerade ist. Aus allem wird ein Geschäft gemacht und ein Publikum ist da, dass dieses Geschäft auch sehen will bzw. diesen permanenten Rabatz braucht. Man hat ja auch offenbar ein sehr armes Leben, wenn man sich die ganze Zeit dafür interessiert. Aber wir sehen das ja auch. Das ist ja nochmal Reality-TV auf ein neues Level gehoben. Bei Reality-TV ist ja noch so, da müsste Pocher so drei Wochen in so ein Haus gehen, dann bekommt er aber auch nur 100.000 Euro. Warum nicht gleich Abonnenten einsammeln und das ganz auf die eigene Marke beziehen?
Diese Einschaltquoten allerdings extrem.
Genau. Aber die nutzt er ja wiederum für Reactions und all das. Oder er ist dann dort zu Gast, um nochmal in der Schlussrunde jemanden zu beschimpfen. Ein Beef hat er auch mit Christian Wolf. Kennst du den? Die machen so auch so ein Männer-Investment-Podcast, wo sie aber auch, sagen wir, politische Inhalte so verhandeln, wie man das jetzt so von Neurechts tut. Die würden natürlich immer sagen, wir sind weder rechts noch links. Aber du weißt ja, was das bedeutet.
Wir geben keine Wahlempfehlungen ab.
Nein, nein.
Wir sagen einfach nur, Deutschland schafft sich ab. Diese ganzen Ausländer, das war damals nicht so.
So genau so etwa. Christian Wolf ist der Mitgründer oder Gründer von Bitpanda. Das ist so Krypto. Mit dem hat Pocher Beef wegen irgendeinem Kleinkram, ich habe es überhaupt nicht herausgefunden, was da jetzt genau los ist. Jedenfalls folgende Überlegung dann von Pocher.
Und das hat er aber immer so rausgearbeitet und dann ging es so hin und her. So und dann sollte es auch Zusammenführungen geben, wo ich mich auch nicht versteckt habe, aber die er dann immer so absagt, um dann den Grund bei mir zu suchen. Also ganz konkret ging es dann einfach darum, er wollte dann irgendwie, er hat dann immer seine Podcasts, er will immer sich in Podcasts treffen. Ich finde das schweinelangweilig, in einem Podcast zu treffen. Ich sage, wenn wir machen Entertainment auf der Bühne, dann lass es mit Publikum machen oder irgendwie größer.
Das heißt, die haben einen Streit um irgendwelche Nichtigkeiten. Das geht bis dahin, dass der Oliver Pocher sagt, du hältst dein Neugeborenes falsch. Und der sagt, nee, das ist aber so und so. Das zieht ein solches Publikum an, dass man in Erwägung ziehen kann, eine Live-Show draus zu machen.
Ja, du brauchst halt Unterhaltung, die fesselnd ist, aber für die...
Für den Inhalt.
Genau, weil du trotzdem nichts verpasst, wenn.
Ja, ja.
Dann, da gibt es so einen Sweetspot.
Man muss dabei bleiben, aber es ist auch völlig nichtig.
Ich meine, der Sweetspot für die grundsätzliche Unterhaltung, das ist ja schon mal hier auch in einem eigenen Kapitel thematisiert, ist, dieses Video gefällt mir, na doch nicht, nächstes, also drei Sekunden quasi. Und du gibst alle drei Sekunden irgendeinem Content eine neue Chance und das Kreuz hat einfach stundenlang durch. Das ist im Grunde der innerliche Anspruch.
Beziehungsweise, wenn man es dann, die machen ja auch lange Strecke, lange Podcasts, in denen sie dann ja auch in irgendwelchen ganz langen Ausführungen erklären, warum der eine dies gesagt hat und das gesagt hat, oder so Statements-Videos, also das haben wir ja auch ganz viel jetzt. Wir haben ja bei vielen, die Content produzieren, auch kurzen Content produzieren, zugleich Videos, in denen sie sich vor eine Kamera setzen und sagen, hey Leute, ich muss jetzt echt mal mit euch reden, es wird ein bisschen dauern, aber es war folgendermaßen, dann reden die einfach 80 Minuten durch, um irgendeinen Zusammenhang darzustellen, bei dem man gar nicht weiß, warum sollte den irgendjemand konsumieren, und dann guckt man danach, ach nee, es hat eine Million Aufrufe, und es gibt schon 70 Reaction-Videos, und am Ende kommt noch mal Rezo und sagt, ja, wir müssen das noch mal so und so sehen.
Das ist alles für ein Publikum, das ansonsten kein Schwein ruft mich an, singt?
Ja, aber ein Publikum, das offenbar nicht unerheblich ist.
Jetzt haben wir schon gehört, dieser Christian Wolf will einfach sagen, aber guck mal, wenn du 670 Euro im Monat abgeben musst an dein späteres Ich, dann bleibt als Unterhaltung nur das übrig.
Nur Oliver Pocher, ja. Die Idee für die Show war jetzt folgende.
Lass uns eine Show machen, und als wir mit Günther Jauch den Jahresrückblick hatten, hatten wir die Option, Pocher ist auch mit Jauch befreundet.
Ja, natürlich.
Und als wir mit Günther Jauch den Jahresrückblick hatten, hatten wir die Option, im Admiralspalast auch noch einen Tag länger zu spielen. Und er wollte unbedingt Ben ungeskriptet, weil er da irgendwie auch mit involviert ist bei diesem Podcast. Ich weiß nicht, als Geldgeber oder wie auch immer oder so.
Damit er sich ein Mikrofon kaufen kann oder was? Warum hat man da Geld gegeben?
Naja, ich weiß ja nicht. Ich war ja bei Ben. Der hat natürlich eine vernünftige Ausstattung, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man dort in einem Luxus-Fernsehstudio ist, sondern man ist ja einfach mit ihm allein in einem Raum. Mehr ist ja nicht. Was ich aber ja doch gesehen habe, ist, wie viral solche Videos gehen. Und die Frage ist ja, wie kommt man eigentlich mit einem Podcast? Wir machen diesen Podcast jetzt schon echt lang. Und wir machen ja keine Werbung oder so für uns im Sinne von, wir buchen keine Ads. Aber wenn du jetzt jemanden hast, der investiert vielleicht in dich und sagt, ich gebe da mal jeden Monat 20.000 Euro aus, dass dieser Podcast überall angezeigt wird, das kann natürlich schon ein Ausstieg sein. Also ich bin, weiß nicht, ob das bei Ben jetzt so ist. Ich sehe nur, dass einige Podcasts so schnell eine große Präsenz in den Medien erreichen, wo ich mich dann frage, das kann doch jetzt nicht mit fünf Interviews gelungen sein.
Ja, also ich referiere kurz einen Clip. Ich will hier nicht zwischenspielen, aber du hast ja auch die Doppelgänger. Und der eine von den beiden hat 120.000 Klicks gekauft, und zwar bei YouTube selbst.
Ah, das habe ich auch gehört, ja. Das war interessant.
Der Preis für diese 120.000 Views waren 300 Euro. Also du lädst es bei YouTube hoch und sagst, auf dieser Hochladen-Formular-Seite bitte ich hier Klicks, hier mein Budget. Und dann wird das halt einfach ausgespielt und hat 120.000 Klicks.
Philipp Klöckler hat das Experiment gemacht.
So, wenn wir ein Video sehen mit 120.000 Klicks, finden wir das grundsätzlich viel. Was bedeutet, wenn du jetzt sagst, da kommen Leute ganz schön schnell hoch, ja, das ist halt einfach All-in-Strategie, da wird einfach alles gemacht. Und dann zahlt man auch mal 300 Euro zehnmal, damit die ersten zehn Videos 100.000 Views haben. Und dann ist das elfte Video quasi so ein Selbstläufer. Weil die Leute allein dadurch, dass sie sehen, ah ja, okay, muss ich jetzt kurz reingucken. So, und das sind halt einfach so wie hier bei Pocher auch, ja. Also ich finde es sehr gut für ihn, denn er hat Kinder, wie auch immer, er braucht Geld, also ganz normal einfach, dass man das monetarisiert. Nur wir beide insbesondere. Und deswegen leiden wir auch, wenn Alexander Kluge stirbt und so. Wir verbinden doch damit irgendwas. Also das ist ja nicht einfach nur Wasser.
Ja, aber das ist genau das, wovon sich ja Pocher einfach löst. Man würde ja sagen, das mache ich nicht über meine Ex-Frau da. Ich mache nicht dies, ich mache nicht das. Oliver Pocher tritt ja auch, hat dann gesagt, ich hole jetzt mal wieder Xavier Naidoo auf die Bühne. Er ist derjenige, der bei RTL als erstes das Aufgriff mit dem Wendler, als der dann sagte, ich haue jetzt nach Amerika ab, Deutschland wird zu Diktatur und so weiter. Er ist aber auch dann der erste, wieder der mit dem Wendler das Interview hinter der Paywall macht. Und da agiert ja Pocher oder agieren auch die aus den USA, die eben genannten, die agieren ja eigentlich wirklich den Algorithmen entsprechend, denn den Algorithmen selbst ist es egal, was der Inhalt ist. Wichtig ist das Engagement und das ist hier einfach auf die Spitze getrieben. Wenn ich da irgendeinen Streit mit irgendeinem Investor oder sonst was habe, dann kann ich natürlich mich mit dem im Podcast austauschen. Da sagt er aber, das ist ja langweilig. Man könnte auch sagen, das produziert keine Clips und all das, weshalb er folgendes vorschlägt.
Da habe ich gesagt, dann lass uns doch den Ben nehmen und der kann das ja gerne auch hosten oder moderieren oder wie auch immer. Dann lass uns da im Admiralspalast treffen. Dann haben wir da Publikum und dann zeichnen wir das auf. Das könnt ihr gerne auswerten und wir werten das bei uns aus. Everybody wins. Was ist mit den ganzen Leuten? Da habe ich gesagt, wir können Hälfte der Hälfte von den Karten machen.
Das heißt, das wird alles rein dieser Logik unterworfen. Und dann ist natürlich vollkommen egal, also da steht ja auch niemand für irgendwas. Also ich weiß bei diesem Konflikt Christian Wolf und Pocher überhaupt nicht, über was sollten die streiten. Wenn man jetzt noch das Argument hätte, der Linke trifft den Rechten und streitet, dann kann man noch über Sinn und Umsehen diskutieren. Aber hier geht es ja nur noch darum, dass irgendwas passiert als Boxkampfersatz oder so.
Genau. Wir haben ja zuletzt Bibis Buch da gelesen. Und das ist ja auch eine mediale Geschichte einer jungen Frau, die inhaltlich einfach richtig leer gelaufen ist. Ja. Und dann plötzlich so ein Sinneswandel hat im Sinne von, ah ja, irgendwann habe ich gemerkt, das bedeutet mir alles gar nichts und so. Hier bei Pocher würde es mich auch nicht wundern, wenn dann irgendwann so Lebensphasen erreicht sind, wo man dann so ein bisschen reflexiv wird, auch wenn jetzt Marc Andresen sagt, das darf man nicht.
Aber der ist schon 48, ne?
Ja, aber ich meine jetzt schon so mit…
Kann man ja schon mal ins Grübeln kommen vielleicht?
Also mit 48 stößt man ja dann so ans dritte Trimester der Erwerbsbiografie und plötzlich stellt man fest, dass irgendwas fehlt. Man kann es aber nicht genau greifen. Und dann, also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn er auch noch so ein Hin zum Sinn… Wenn er der erste Mann ist, der dann so…
Ja, er kommt ja aus einer Zeugen Jehovas Familie, er ist ja jemand, der sich da eher so etwas rausgelöst hat. Von daher kann ich es mir nicht so vorstellen. Wir sehen ja auch durchaus Protagonisten. Wir sehen aber Protagonisten in dem Spiel, die ja auch so einfach weitermachen. Also Dieter Bohlen oder Heino, das sind ja schon Akteure, die da ähnlich drauf sind. Bei Pocher ist das einfach nur in der Logik der Algorithmen gedacht, des Marketings gedacht. Das ist eigentlich das Faszinierende daran, dass er es hier so ganz klar ausspricht, was bei anderen vielleicht dann so mal gesucht werden muss. Wie gehen die das an? Er spricht das aus. Dann auch noch mal bezogen auf diesen Christian Wolf, der dann versucht seine, er stellt so Proteinshakes wohl auch her.
Ah, daher, ja.
Ja.
Moa und so, oder?
Moa, irgendwas mit Moa, genau. Und da versucht er dann jetzt auch mit Olli Pocher wieder zu foppen.
Also ich würde auch sofort irgendwie in dem Moment, wo Christian Wolf kommt und sagt, er lasst uns doch hier irgendwie so einen Pulver auf die Bühne bringen oder irgendwas anderes, würde ich ja sogar noch sagen, ist doch lustig. Win-win. Lasst doch Christian Moa irgendwie ein Produkt rausbringen oder ein Riegel oder irgendwas anderes oder ein lustigen Spot. Er fängt ja auch an, meine ganzen Ex-Frauen oder Leute im Umfeld werbetechnisch einzudecken. Also Amira macht das dann. Er denkt dann immer, das wird mich ärgern oder so. Es ist fantastisch. Er finanziert sie mit. Sie kann jeden Cent gebrauchen. Top. Bitte weitermachen. Nicht aufkündigen. Wayne und Annemarie Carpendale. Das ist halt wirklich das Proteinpulver des Fernsehens irgendwie. Das ist einfach genauso geschmackssicher wie das Zeug irgendwie. Fantastisch. Die stehen da, machen das.
Ich finde, er findet sich zu geil darin, so explizit sagen zu können, dass er sein Publikum eigentlich weder kennt noch kennenlernen möchte, eigentlich verachtet und ist alles egal.
Das ist aber das Erstaunliche. Das findest du ja bei Clavicula und bei all denen auch.
Überall, das finde ich auch bei Trump und Merz.
Ja, das ist ja das Erstaunliche. Es gab doch jetzt diese Doku über, die hat er auch ohne Liebe gesprochen, von Netflix, wo diese Manfluencer da gezeigt werden, und dann wird das so getan, wir entlarven die. Aber nein, die sagen das ja alle so frei heraus, dass es genau so ist. Und das ist also ein Publikum, das einwilligt in das, was Pocher hier ausdrücklich sagt, nämlich ihr interessiert mich in dem Sinn nicht. Ihr seid die Deppen, die draufklicken, die irgendwelche Proteinshakes nehmen, wenn sie hingestellt werden, was auch immer. Und ihr kommt jetzt auch noch auf die App. Das finde ich interessant, dass also dieser offen zur Schau getragene Zynismus bei dem Publikum nicht eine abschreckende Wirkung hat. Denn normalerweise hätte man früher diesen Pakt eingegangen, wie bei den Volksmusikern, die gesagt haben, wenn man sie getroffen hätte nach drei Bier. Ich hasse diese Musik. Ich würde eigentlich lieber mal gern die Rolling Stones spielen. Aber ich muss leider jetzt hier im Trachtenanzug über die Bühne jodeln. Aber da, die Oma will es halt so. Und dann haben sie aber ihrem Publikum immer suggeriert, wir sind eine Familie und ich liebe euch so. Und Pocher und viele andere, deswegen habe ich ihn ja hier so als Symptom rausgegriffen, machen das genau nicht mehr. Und trotzdem, oder gerade weil sie es nicht mehr machen, finden sie ein Publikum. Also dieser Zynismus, Trump sagt seinen Wählern, eigentlich, ich bin hier der reichste Mann und so weiter. Was habe ich mit euch zu tun? Und zugleich sagt er, kommt zu mir, ich bin euer Mann.
Über Bande ist er aber doch wieder abhängig davon, dass sein Publikum halt so drauf ist. Weil nur so kann er dem was vorspielen. Das einzige, was er für sich dann rausziehen kann, ist eben Geld.
Ja, ja, nichts anderes.
Aber diese Flapsigkeit, mit der er hier, ja, dann machen wir halt Proteinshakes noch auf der Bühne und mischen die und so und hier und da. Und es ist doch toll, dass die alle quer finanzieren, da muss ich nicht so viel. Also das ist einfach, ich sehe hier, das könnte man sich so als Bild zeigen, so ein Typ, der auf der einen Seite ganz oben ist, aber die ganze Zeit so mit dem Kopf schon unter Wasser und dann Proteinshakes jetzt, los, ran, ran, ran, das Wasser steigt schon wieder.
Naja, es funktioniert.
Ich sehe alles unter Wasser, das ist einfach emotional komplett unter Wasser.
Ja, emotional, aber offenbar nicht ökonomisch.
Ich habe das Buch von Julia Anders gelesen und sehr ernst genommen und sie sagt, am Ende ist der Zustand der Welt so ein bisschen egal, wenn es mit der Emotion nicht hinhaut. Das glaube ich gerne. Einen Ballon suchen und so weiter.
Das glaube ich gerne.
Er geht hier, finde ich, hart in Kredit mit sich selber.
Ja, nein, er setzt sich dieser Manege da aus, dass er sich dann da manchmal über und die Fans Leute lustig macht. Da würde ich sagen, ich würde also, wo ich das mache, würde mir wahrscheinlich noch das andere eher...
Ich meine, überleg mal, es gibt jetzt so viele Bücher, die dir sagen, Selbstverwirklichung, selbstverwirklichung, auf der anderen Seite ist dieses, nee, du musst Resonanz mit der Welt aufbauen und so. Und hier ist jemand, der hat gar keine Selbstverwirklichung, Ansprüche auch mehr. Der ist stolz darauf zu sagen, die suchen da so Resonanz, also biete ich das einfach.
Der Erfolg gibt ihm recht, dass es für ihn sein einziges ist.
Der finanzielle Erfolg.
Genau, es ist nur der finanzielle.
Aber er ist doch komplett lost. Also es ist ja wirklich auch traurig zu hören.
Ja, es ist traurig zu hören, aber das Interessante ist doch, dass das funktioniert und dass wir offenbar eine Gesellschaft haben, die genau diese Inhalte haben möchte. Denn das Interessante ist ja, sie lassen sich ja von ihm beschimpfen. Er sagte, in diesem Podcast, nee, in einem anderen Podcast war er noch so, deshalb war er dann noch in so einem Business-Ding, da sagt er ja in Deutschland so mit Work-Life-Balances, also diesen ganzen März spricht, übernimmt er völlig. Um dann noch mal zu sagen, er will eigentlich kein Vermieter sein, weil das könnte ja schwierig werden mit den ganzen Mietnomaden. Okay, das wäre ja eine Position, die man einnimmt. Und dann sagt er ja, wenn man es wirklich leicht im Leben haben will, dann muss man Angestellter und Mieter werden. So ist sein Blick auf die Welt. Da sind diese Schlafschafe, die mich die ganze Zeit klicken und noch hinter die Paywall gehen für mich und Amira und weiß ich nicht wen. Aber das sind die, die es zunächst gebracht haben. Die sind Mieter und Angestellte, die denken ja gar nicht für sich selbst. Und dieser zynische Blick auf die Welt, den artikuliert er ganz offen.
Ich mache jetzt ein vulgäres, psychologisches Fazit aus meiner Sicht, um das für mich abzuschließen und nie wieder über Paranach zu denken. Harald Schmitt hat ihm damals seinem Publikum zum Fraß vorgeworfen. Und das war für ihn ein großer Erfolg im Sinne von er steht mit Harald Schmitt auf der Bühne. Dann hat er irgendwann festgestellt, Mist, für mich ist nur Erfolg denkbar, wenn ich mich zum Fraß vorwerfe. Eine Konfrontation, wie Harald Schmitt das gemacht hat mit seinem Publikum, wäre für ihn völlig undenkbar. Weil, dann müsste er irgendwann anfangen, inhaltlich zu und so weiter, ja. Also hat er aus dieser Kränkung, ich wurde dem Publikum zum Fraß vorgeworfen, gesagt, ich mach das jetzt selber. Ich werf mich selber dem Publikum zum Fraß vor. Und alles, was hier von ihm so stolz verkündet wird, dann machen wir hier Dings da und zum Glück bezahlt er meine Frauen, wie auch immer, das ist im Grunde dieses Eingeständnis, außer Resonanz mit dem Publik herstellen, ausschließlich über Bekanntheit, ist nicht im Angebot, aber das mache ich jetzt all in. Und dieser ganze Stolz ist diese vulgäre Selbstbehauptung, dass das programmatisch wäre, während er gleichzeitig nicht anders kann, als sich ausschließlich darüber zu profilieren und auch darüber zu freuen, dass das halt einen finanziellen Ertrag bringt.
Ja.
So und damit haben wir hier eine Medienbiografie, die sich sehr durchlegt auf seine persönliche Biografie offenbar.
Die ist todtraurig.
Die nur finanziell ihren Wert sich selbst erklärt. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt, sorry, aber...
Dabei ist es exakt die Logik, nicht nur der Algorithmen, sondern generell die Logik der Quote. Alles, was Klicks bringt, ist gut, ist okay.
Das ist die Meritocracy Trap auf einer anderen Art.
Es gibt keine andere Währung als die. Jeder Mensch würde sagen, ich bin gerade nicht stolz, dass meine Ehe zu Bruch gegangen ist. Ja, finde ich jetzt gerade, ist alles gerade schwierig, auch wegen der Kinder und so etwas. Und er sagt, ich bin stolz darauf, dass ich danach sofort eine Tournee mache. Weil nur zählt, ich habe ausverkaufte Säle gehabt und meine Reals zu dem Thema erreichen noch mehr, als die Bildzeitung schafft. Letzter Clip dazu. Wie geht ihr überhaupt damit um, genau mit dem, was du da jetzt auch beschrieben hast?
Also ich habe in gewisser Form da auch Glück. Das ist genetisch einfach so, dass ich nicht groß am Zweifeln bin oder irgendwie da auch mit Depressionen oder irgendwelchen anderen Erkrankungen zu tun habe, was bei ganz vielen in der Branche so ist. Oder Leute, die es dann irgendwie mit Drogen und Alkohol in irgendeiner Art und Weise kompensieren. Also das ist bei mir glücklicherweise nicht der Fall. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, im Nachgang muss man auch sagen, dass ich auch als Zeuge Jehovas groß geworden bin. Also es ist irgendwie so eine Schule, dass du auch Sachen gemacht hast, die nicht unbedingt du machen wolltest. Dass du auch da Sachen hinterfragt hast, dich irgendwie durchsetzen musstest. Und das schafft eine gewisse Resilienz irgendwie auch, dass dir viele Sachen einfach dann auch egal sind. Also wenn du als Kind irgendwie mit dem Wachtturm in der Fußgängerzone stehst oder da von Haus zu Haus gehst oder auch dreimal die Woche irgendwie diese Zusammenkünfte besuchst, also da machen dir viele Sachen nichts aus.
Du wirst beschimpft, verlacht mit dem Wachtturm in der Hand. Und dann sagst du, dann kann ich das auf der Bühne machen und dann verdiene ich auch noch Geld damit.
Ihnen sind genau die Sachen egal, von denen ich sage, okay, kein Problem, aber bitte im Medienbetrieb bleiben. Jetzt keine politische Karriere anstreben.
Und das ist ja das Ding, dass die immer mehr über das Politische reden. Irgendwann geht das dann darüber hinaus, wer hat mit wem und wer ist die Neue an seiner Seite. Sondern dann geht das dann in so politische Programmatiken. Insofern kann man nur hoffen, dass er viel Erfolg mit der App hat, damit er nicht auf Ideen kommt.
Ja, hier nicht auf Ideen kommen, aber es ist in Deutschland auch schwierig, das umzumünzen.
Kommen wir noch zum Iran. Es ist ja doch ein bisschen eigenartig. Wir hören jetzt doch immer mehr sehr, sehr kritische Stimmen, auch aus Deutschland, auch aus der deutschen Medienlandschaft. Wenn da noch einige Anfangs sagten, na ja, aber wir müssen jetzt doch auch sehen, dass endlich Frauenrechte im Iran gelten sollten. Und man sich schon so dachte, ach so, und Donald Trump ist der richtige Mann für so was. Das ist jedenfalls ein bisschen anders geworden, nicht überall. Aber wir sind eigentlich diese Leute, die wirklich diesen Trump-Kurs absolut unterstützen. Wir haben ja in den USA viele radikalisierte Christen, die durchaus sagen, wir müssen jetzt an der Seite von Israel den Iran bekämpfen, denn der Iran ist quasi der Antichrist oder was auch immer. Wir haben diese Auseinandersetzung gehabt mit Taka Carlson und wie heißt er nochmal, der da vorgeführt wurde, der auch so ein sehr christlich…
Ted Cruz.
Ted Cruz, der sich immer auf die Bibel beruft.
Ja, aber der Iran selber ist ja nicht der Antichrist, sondern es droht in diesen Momenten, so der Antichrist als weltweites Regime durchzubrechen. Vorher war es das Klima. Hier beim Iran ist die Argumentation noch ein bisschen unscharf, aber ich finde es schon erstaunlich, dass es doch einige Stimmen gibt, die sagen, die Iran ist schon ganz blöd, aber man hört so zwischen den Zeilen, es ist gut, dass man jemanden Trump die Stirn bietet.
Ja, das gibt es aber jetzt ja nicht bei diesen Leuten, die Trump da unterstützen. Genau, ich rede jetzt über diese auch sehr christliche Seite, also christliche Anführungszeichen dann. Ich habe einen Beitrag geschickt bekommen von KTV, also vom katholischen Fernsehen.
Das gibt es?
Ja, das gibt es. Dort ist Pater Dr. Karl Wallner zu Gast. Das ist nicht irgendwer, sondern der ist seit September 2016 der Missio-Nationaldirektor für Österreich. Missio ist ja das große Hilfswerk. Er ist ja der Nationaldirektor. Er ist auch sonst eine bekannte Persönlichkeit, hat auch Management betrieben, wohl für oder Marketing für so eine christliche Chor. Ich glaube, so Mönche waren, dass die da gesungen haben. Die sind auch bei Wettendass war er da auch mal. Kann man alles in der Wikipedia nachlesen. Jedenfalls, dieser Dr. Karl Wallner, dieser Pater wird interviewt zum Iran. Er sagt da Folgendes.
Also in dem Thema, ich bin Mönch, ich bin Priester, ich bin katholischer Priester und ich liebe Jesus Christus, der Fürst des Friedens ist. Ich bin absolut für Diplomatie und für Verhandlung und dass die internationalen Gemeinschaften hier eingeschaltet werden. Es gibt aber von Churchill das Wort, also wenn du den Kopf im Maul des Tigers hast, kannst du mit ihm nicht verhandeln. Was wir im Nahen Osten, was wir im Iran dort eben jetzt hatten seit 1979, das war immer schon Eskalation eines apokalyptischen Islamismus, der gegen den Westen gestanden ist. Das Tod für Amerika galt im ganzen Westen und letztlich auch dem Christentum, weil es eine islamistische politische Ideologie der Überlegenheit ist und das Hass ist auf alles andere, was wir hier haben.
Ja, aber das entbindet jetzt trotzdem nicht von, wenn er sich so an Jesus Christus...
Wir müssen jetzt in einen religiösen Kampf, weil das Christentum bedroht ist...
.eine Pausentaste ist in ihrer eigenen Überzeugung und sie müssen es dann anderen erklären, dass sie da kurz Pause gedrückt haben oder?
Es ist jedenfalls sehr gegen das, was Papst Leo fordert, nämlich mehr Diplomatie, denn da ist jetzt gar keine Zeit mehr für.
Sich selbst jetzt eben durch ballistische Waffen so zu immunisieren, dass sie dann im Hintergrund in Ruhe hätten, die Atombombe entwickeln können. Also was da geschehen ist, ist immer schon Eskalation. Deshalb kann man nicht sprechen, dass jetzt eben dieser Krieg, der ein Befreiungsschlag für das iranische Volk jetzt eben ist und dass solches empfunden wird von den Iranern. Wir müssen auf die hören, dass das jetzt eben eine Eskalation sein kann. Nein, es ist eine Deeskalation, die gerade dort jetzt eben geschieht. Leider nur möglich jetzt mit kriegerischen Mitteln.
Momentchen, also das, was jetzt gerade passiert, ist eine Deeskalation.
Detanjao und Trump deeskalieren.
Das ist gerade eine Deeskalation der Gefahr. Und wir hatten ja einen ganz kurzen Moment, wo Friedrich Merz am Tag der Rückkehr aus Washington auch meinte, Frau Wellner, es gibt doch einen Zeitpunkt, an dem es zu spät ist. Und dann fragt uns keiner, was mit dem Völkerrecht ist. Also lieber jetzt die Atomwaffen beseitigen. Wir wissen, das iranische Atomwaffenprogramm in der Form, wie es uns heute retrospektiv ausgelegt wird, ist im Grunde, Collien Paul erklärt, was sind Verdichtungswaffen vor der UN, das ist der Irak und so weiter. Es war eh die Frage, wer hält es wie lange durch? Friedrich Merz hat es einen Tag durchgehalten. Der Wadepool ist so ein bisschen hartnäckiger, aber auch schwammiger in seinen Ausführungen.
Gestern wurde ja Friedrich Merz auch nochmal von Paul Ronzheimer in der Bild-Zeitung kritisiert.
Dafür?
Dass das doch unser Krieg ist, da müssen wir jetzt schon mal da uns, wie er, Ronzheimer formuliert es so, dass Merz den Scholz-Feder wiederholt. Und ich denke dann immer, okay, dann scheint ja Merz mal was richtig zu machen, wenn er es wie Scholz macht.
Ja, von wann ist das hier? Karl Wallner, wann hat er das gesagt?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ah ja, gut, das ist ja dann schon eine Weile her.
Oder zehn Tagen irgendwie so. Also es ist schon aktuell.
Also ich bin mal gespannt, ob uns das jetzt nochmal tagesaktuell begegnet, dass jemand nochmal vor der Atomwaffe Irans warnt und so.
Er ist bestimmt immer noch dabei.
So brutal im Nazi-Art werden jetzt schon massakrieren, wenn die die Atombombe hätten. Dann Gnade der Welt.
Gnade der Welt, da müssen wir jetzt aufpassen. Denn hier wird ja der Iran vorgestellt als ein Regime, das nur diese Atombombe will, um dann die Welt auszulöschen. Dass sie das aus einem strategischen Unterfangen heraus wollen, um genau nicht mehr so in dieser Weise angegriffen zu werden. Das ist ja eine Rationalität, die dahinter liegt, weil er schildert das ja jetzt so, als sei das der Endkampf zwischen Islam und Christentum oder so. Das ist ja unsinnig.
Ja, aber so läuft der Atomwaffendiskurs zu diesen ganzen Sperrverträgen und so weiter, dass jeder weitere, der Atomwaffen hat, sie hat, um andere anzugreifen. Und die bisherigen haben Bestandsschutz und ein Verteidigungsgesichtspunkt. Dann wird der Schutzschirm aufgespart.
Gewiss, gewiss. Er macht dann einen kleinen Werbeblock.
Ich bin ja nicht neutral. Ich kann ja nicht neutral sein. Wir haben bei MISIO aufgebaut seit vielen Jahren eben ein Zentrum für Perser, die zu Christus finden. Das sind sehr viele. Wir haben eigene Informationen dazu. Das ist die Mutter Gotteskönigin von Persien. Hannanias nennen wir das Ganze. Wir können es gerne auch andocken, wenn ihr Leute habt aus dem Iran, die sich dafür interessieren, jetzt eben Christen zu werden. Das ist eine sehr, sehr großartige Sache.
Ja, vielleicht könnten die beiden, also er und Ted Cruz, schon mal missionieren gehen.
Also die Perser dürfen gerne zu uns flüchten, aber sie müssen dann schon das Bekenntnis für Jesus ablegen. Die dürfen nicht als Perser kommen.
Mit solchen Nazi-Ideologien kannst du eben jetzt nicht eine gerechte Verhandlung entführen. Da gibt es keine Diplomatie, die irgendeine Chance hat, jetzt eben auch erfolgt. Die sind nur auf Macht und auf Terror aus. Also ich habe mich immer auch beim Heiligen Vater, Rückkehr zur Diplomatie, zu welcher Diplomatie, seit 1979 funktioniert das nicht.
Seit 1979 nicht und jetzt nach 47 Jahren unsere Retter, Netanyahu und Trump. Es muss leider sein.
So schrecklich es ist, dass dort Menschen jetzt eben sterben durch diese Angriffe und so weiter. Und übrigens ja auch Soldaten, die auf der Seite Isar ist und Amerikas jetzt eben kämpfen. Aber hier geht es um ein Gut, das uns allen eben jetzt, dass wir alle brauchen, nämlich Friede und Sicherheit.
Aber so kannst du, ich meine, man kann das ein bisschen paraphrasieren und dann kann man so eine Kolumne morgen in der Welt erscheinen lassen. Wäre kein Problem.
Nur die iranische Bevölkerung kriegt halt auch mit, dass jetzt nicht nur das iranische Regime gegen sie vorgeht, sondern dass jetzt auch wahllos und vielleicht sogar gezielt, man weiß es ja gar nicht, von Amerika aus diese Schulen da beschossen werden.
Weilner kennt alle Iraner.
Weil ich hier Partei bin durch die Menschen aus dem Iran, die das Recht haben, hier an erster Stelle gehört zu werden. Und nicht sich als Europäer oder auch als theologischer Theoretiker so zurückzusetzen und sagen, und das und das und das wäre doch so schön. Also das ist Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen mit rosaroten Brillen. Es funktioniert leider nicht, weil dämonische Mächte eben hier seit Jahren agieren.
Wir kämpfen gegen dämonische Mächte, ein Dämon, der muss besiegt werden. Was hier auch wiederkehrt, was wir schon im Zuge des Krieges in der Ukraine oft gehört haben, die Iraner, die Ukrainer. Es gibt immer hier Leute, die ganz genau wissen oder drei Freunde haben von dort, wodurch sie so unterrichtet sind, dass sie immer für alle sprechen können. Ja, ich würde auch mal gerne, ich spreche hier für ganz Deutschland sagen oder so. Zum Schluss noch Danke. Danke an wen eigentlich? Er dankt dem lieben Gott, aber es klingt eher schon so, als müsste er dann den lieben Gott Trump meinen.
Dem iranischen Volk noch einmal, dass wirklich Gott dankt auf den Knien. Wir haben Rosenkranz gebetet jetzt als Dank, dass hier zumindest eine neue Situation eröffnet wird.
Auf den Knien danken wir Donald Trump. Jetzt kann man sagen, gut, da habe ich doch irgendetwas ganz Obskures rausgesucht. Wer sieht sich schon KTV an? Stimmt. Ich glaube aber, dass es diese Strömungen in der Trump-Administration gibt und dass es die mitunter auch hier stärker gibt, als man denkt. Also die diese religiöse Komponente noch mit dabei haben. Ich glaube auch, dass die Kirchen in Deutschland sich ja, zwar für den Frieden aussprechen, aber doch auch in gewisser Weise zögerlich da sind. Also gar nicht so sehr das Verurteilen, wie sie das bei anderen Kriegen tun. Dann habe ich gedacht, na ja, das erinnert doch vielleicht auch ein bisschen an das, was man in Die Anstalt erleben konnte. Also Die Anstalt ist ja eigentlich dafür bekannt, genau solche kleinen außenpolitische Amokläufe zu kritisieren. Also eigentlich schon erwartbar zu kritisieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Sendung gesehen hast, aber da gab es auch etwas sehr Eigenartiges. Also wie heißt der Uthoff, also der Moderator und seine Kollegin. Ich kenne die Anstalt auch nicht so richtig mehr, deswegen weiß ich gar nicht mehr, wer da so ist. Also die beiden, die immer dabei sind, hatten jetzt noch hinzugenommen eine, wie es dann immer so heißt, iranische Stimme. Also man nimmt eine Person, die aus dem Iran kommt, in Jugend- oder Kindertagen hergekommen sind. Und dann ist das quasi die Stimme, bei der man immer sagt, ja, eine Stimme. Und wir sehen ja, haben wir gerade, als wir in Frankfurt der Obermann wieder in der Demonstration, von einigen Iranern gesehen, die auch Amerika und Israel-Flaggen in der Hand haben. Das ist dann eine Position, die es da auch gibt. Die will ja auch niemand denen absprechen. Nur das ist eben eine Position. Das ist nicht das iranische Volk, das wir dann da sehen. Jedenfalls ist diese Comedian dann dort, Nege Amiri heißt die. Und sie spricht jetzt zwischen den beiden stehend. Ich will das Szenario beschreiben. Und wenn die anderen jetzt immer noch so einhaken im klassischen Sinne, wie die Anstalt das tun würde eigentlich und sagen, na ja, aber Trump und so weiter, wie wir das hier auch tun, wird sie jetzt diesen Krieg uns rationalisieren. Vielleicht dir dann auch.
Was ist denn deine Meinung?
Meine Meinung? Leute, es geht hier doch nicht um meine Meinung. Und es geht auch nicht um unsere Meinung. Wir stehen hier in der Freiheit, ja. Es geht um die Meinung der Menschen, die sich gerade nicht äußern können, weil das Internet abgeschaltet wurde und weil das Regime denen mit dem Tod droht. Die brauchen jetzt unsere Solidarität und Empathie.
Ja, Empathie. Jetzt ist so. Ich könnte meine Gefühle ja viel besser ausdrücken, wenn die da im Iran Frau, Leben, Freiheit rufen würden und nicht Trump, I love you.
Ja gut, bei den Protesten im Januar wurde ja auch oft Chavid Shah gerufen. Das war ihnen, meine ich, auch nicht recht. Welcher Hilferuf würde denn ihren revolutionären Ansprüchen genügen?
Also, Uthoff ist der, der noch so scheinbar Kontra gibt, aber nur, um die Position dann aufzulösen. So, jetzt müssen wir aber.
Ja, und was so viele nicht verstehen. Reza Pahlavi ist gerade der große Hoffnungsträger für Iraner. Aber gefällt euch ja auch nicht, ne? Habt ihr vielleicht einen besseren Vorschlag?
Reza Pahlavi ist doch nur für einige Leute im Iran ein Hoffnungsträger. Also, dass das jetzt einfach so gesagt wird, dass es jetzt der Hoffnungsträger für den Iran, was geht da vor sich?
Ja, also, ich sehe das ja wie folgt, wie auch schon in Gaza und so. Es gibt halt immer eine Partei mehr, also die Bevölkerung, die wird natürlich über einen Kamm gezogen. Und in solchen Auseinandersetzungen hat man ja dann dieses Phänomen, Donald Trump macht dort im Sinne dieses Missionars aus Österreich, oder wie nennen wir ihn? Pater, Pater Dr. Karl. Und sagt dann, naja, der befreit ja gerade für uns, nicht nur das Iranische, die iranische Bevölkerung, sondern auch uns von diesem dämonischen Regime. Was ja bedeutet, das iranische Regime sieht sich gerade angegriffen, weil sie das Volk befreien und jemand kommt, um das Volk zu befreien. Zu ihrem Nachteil, das finden sie nicht gut. Also finden sie ihr Volk eigentlich scheiße, weil nur deswegen gibt es ja diesen Krieg. Trump macht diesen Angriff und ruft dann auf, liebe Leute, jetzt ergreift die Macht, ich schieße euch den Weg frei. Und dann zwei Wochen später, sie machen es nicht. Der Krieg dauert immer länger und so weiter. Also fängt dann Trump auch so ein bisschen an, die iranische Bevölkerung zu hassen. Die haben mich im Stich gelassen. Also das ist jetzt Ihr Originalgedanke von Donald Trump, behaupte ich mal. Er sieht sich gerade vom iranischen Volk im Stich gelassen und muss jetzt deswegen plötzlich Inflationspolitik. Am Ende kommt noch ein Inflation Reduction Act, an dem er nicht vorbeikommt. Wäre auch eine witzige Sache. So und irgendwo da positionieren sich gerade alle. Und das iranische Volk wird sowieso immer so im Großen und Ganzen. Das ist die Schwungmasse für alles einfach.
Und hier ruft man aus dem Fernsehen dem auch nochmal irgendwas zu.
Eigentlich nicht. Ich finde es gar nicht gut.
Ja und das macht die Sache auch nicht besser, nur weil da jemand ist, die aus dem Iran kommt.
Ja das ist so als würde Höcke für uns auf Mallorca angesprochen. Ach, Sie sind Deutscher. Erklären Sie uns mal kurz.
Ja oder auch, das wäre genauso auch, wenn man sagen würde, hier ist irgendein ein grüner Politiker, der jetzt für das deutsche Volk steht. Dann würde ich ja auch sagen, nee, aber ich habe eigentlich mit Jammer zu mir gar nicht viel zu tun.
Also Michel Friedmann sagt ja immer, jeder ist jemand.
Ja.
Und hier ist gerade nicht jeder jemand.
Ja, das ist ganz absurd. Es geht noch weiter.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch einen besseren Befreier als der liebe Herr Trump.
Ja, sorry. Aber wenn ein faschistoider Sexualstraftäter das islamistische Patriarchat angreift, dann stößt Satire auch mal an die Grenzen der Leistungsfähigkeit.
Das Publikum noch auf diese Pointen geeicht.
Na gut, da war gerade eine Lücke, da muss man klatschen.
Reagiert aber noch auf diese Uthoff-Pointe, aber die wird jetzt natürlich sofort relativiert. Also so kann man nicht mehr sprechen.
Okay.
Und ich habe ja den Eindruck, dass das passiert, weil jetzt so ein Generationenwechsel in Redaktionen stattfindet. Es sind einfach viele, die nicht viel Ahnung, aber viel Meinung und viel so moralisches Sentiment haben, dass sie sagen, wir müssen, ich habe eine iranische Stimme gehört und die hat gesagt, dass das und das ist, dann muss das jetzt so sein, deswegen können wir das jetzt nicht gerade kritisieren.
Ja, Alexander Kluge ist leider tot jetzt.
Ja, da bringt keiner mehr den Krieg ins Stolpern.
Euer Hauptproblem ist also, dass hier die Falschen wohl ausversehen das Richtige tun könnten.
Trump will ja gar nicht das Richtige tun. Das ist ja nicht sein Kriegsinteresse. Das könnte ein Side-Effekt sein in bestem Umstände, aber das ist ja schon alles verpufft. Aber das ist ja gar nicht sein Kriegsinteresse. Es ist auch gar nicht sein Kriegsinteresse, dass da nachher ein liberaler, starker Iran entsteht. Also ich weiß gar nicht, woher diese Vorstellungen immer kommen.
Also in Amerika ist die Triebfehler gerade, dass der Richtige das Falsche tut. Also genau rumgedreht.
Probleme können sich die Iraner im Iran gar nicht erlauben.
Genau, Herr Utthoff, ich meine, wenn ihnen jemand eine Pistole an den Kopf fällt, dann sind sie doch auch froh über jeden, der den Täter überwältigt, oder?
Dieses Argument haben wir auch schon eine Million mal gehört.
Lieber Herr Nymon. Und selbst wenn deine Freundin schießt oder nicht?
Wenn ihre Freundin bedroht wird, Herr Nymon, werden sie dann das und das tun.
Verstehe ich das richtig. Ihr findet es ja schon gut, dass Frau Minnet tot ist. Ja, klar. Aber dann müsst ihr dir doch die Angriffe gut finden.
Nicht, wenn dabei so offenkundig Völkerrecht gebrochen wird.
Aha, das heißt also, du begrüßt das Ergebnis einer Tat, die du eigentlich verursacht hast?
Ja, da bin ich ganz konsequent.
Ja, Herr Utthoff, ich glaube, uns allen wäre es lieber gewesen, wenn der Muller beim Fensterputzen aus dem Palast gestürzt wäre und die ganze Führungsspitze gleich hinterher.
Es muss doch irgendwie beides möglich sein. Also Solidarität mit dem iranischen Volk.
Das den Wunsch hat, dass das Regime stürzt.
Genau und Achtung, das Völkerrecht.
Das den Sturz des Regimes von außen verbietet.
Wir brauchen das Völkerrecht jetzt auch in einer linken Satire-Sendung nicht mehr.
Na also, geht doch.
Jetzt bin ich aber wirklich sehr gespannt, wie du praktisch beides miteinander verwinden möchtest.
Ja, das ist ja nun ganz einfach. Ja, da macht dann das iranische Volk einen Aufstand von von innen.
Natürlich, ja.
Also dieses Dilemma, das da angesprochen wird, ist natürlich ein Dilemma. Aber wir können es ja nicht lösen, indem wir sagen, genau deswegen geht Trump jetzt da rein und befreit dieses Volk. Es ist kein Befreiungskrieg. Und es gibt auch in der Geschichte nicht das Beispiel für eine solche Befreiung. Das ist Unsinn. Es wird nur dieses Dilemma so hingestellt, als müsste man es selbst jetzt lösen, als müsste man jetzt quasi in den Kopf von Trump und Netanyahu reinkrabbeln, um dann zu sagen, genau, so in diese Richtung gehen wir und dann ist alles befreit. Und dann ist das Muller-Regime einfach weg mit den 150.000 Leuten revolutionsgeraden.
Und dann kommt wieder von außen niemand zu Hilfe, so wie im Januar, als das Regime in wenigen Tagen zehntausende Zivilisten getötet hat. War das etwa auch nicht völkerrechtswidrig? Steht auch nicht im Völkerrecht, dass man genau bei solchen Verbrechen von außen angreifen kann?
Völkerrecht, das fühlt sich ja inzwischen immer so ein bisschen an wie ein Tinder-Date. Alles kann, nichts muss.
Ja, aber es kann doch keine Lösung sein, dass zwei kriegsgeile Regierungschefs von außen ein Land angreifen und dann erst am ersten Tag eine Mädchenschule bombardieren.
Krieg ist keine Lösung. Ich weiß. Aber dieses Regime führt Krieg gegen die eigene Bevölkerung und Stellvertreterkriege in den Nachbarländern. Viele haben Angst vor den Bomben, ja. Aber noch mehr haben Angst, dass keine Bomben mehr fallen, weil sie sich davor fürchten, wieder mit dem Regime alleingelassen zu werden.
Sie werden ja jetzt gerade mit dem Regime und mit den Bomben alleingelassen. Ja.
Mulas haben furchtbare Rache gesporn. Jetzt ist es zu spät aufzuhören. Zum ersten Mal haben die unschuldigen Menschen überhaupt eine Hoffnung, dieses Regime loszuwerden.
Das passiert jetzt, wir hören jetzt mal auf damit. Das ist jetzt einfach linke Satire heute, dass man den Krieg von Trump und Netanyahu rechtfertigt. Jetzt müssen wir durchgreifen, was ja im Grunde genommen, wenn man es ernst sind, bedeutet, lieber Friedrich Merz, lieber Herr Wadephul, das ist ab sofort Ihr Krieg. Bitte entsenden Sie Bundeswehrsoldaten dahin, denn wie Pater Wallner sagt, wir müssen die Welt vor Dämonen befreien und wie hier die Comedian Amiri sagt, wir müssen die iranischen Frauen befreien und die warten nur auf mehr Bomben, damit dann endlich ein liberal-demokratisches Regime geführt von Reza Pahlavi in Iran entsteht. Da darf man ja sehr gespannt drauf sein.
Naja, also die Denke hier ist ja, wie soll ich sagen, ich mache jetzt einen Bogenschlag, der klingt ein bisschen absurd und so, aber der ist glaube ich, also für mich ist er jetzt gerade super wichtig. Man versucht ja immer eine logische, vor allem vermittelbare, nachvollziehbare Aufklärung irgendwie, sich so aus den Rippen zu leiern, die dann möglichst für vieles funktioniert. Und hier sind wir aber in Matthäus, würde Alexander Kluge dann sagen, in dem es halt einfach historisch zugeht. Also man hat es im Grunde mit Einzelfällen zu tun. So, und einer meiner größten Erfahrungen jetzt in den letzten Monaten war, deswegen aber das will ich jetzt hier nur kurz anschneiden. Wir haben diese politische Lage, die alle so ein bisschen schwierig. Und hier und da, und wen soll ich denn jetzt wählen? Und auch das Wählen ist wieder nur so eine, ja, da muss ich jetzt mit sehr vielen, was weiß ich, 800.000 Leute in Frankfurt und die sollen jetzt aus 20 Parteien auswählen. Und ich muss mich da zuordnen, wie auch immer, ist ja alles schwierig. Während man gleichzeitig privat, also für die, die diese Erfahrung machen, einfach feststellen, 70, 80 Prozent der Sachen, die mich wirklich nerven, weil sie sinnloser Arbeit und so weiter, kann ich durch KI wirklich weg automatisieren. So, was aber bedeutet, ich finde dafür eine Lösung, die ich nicht ergoogeln kann und die es auch noch nicht gibt, sondern ich muss sie halt wirklich ganz individuell entwickeln. Und dann habe ich zum Beispiel ein Kalender, in dem Leute nachgucken können, wann habe ich denn Zeit? Ja, und müssen nicht mehr direkt mich und ich muss dann E-Mails schreiben und so weiter. Solche Kleinigkeiten oder solche Skriptausarbeitung, wie jetzt hier zu Lars Klingbeil. So, nichts davon kann ich für einen anderen Fall nochmal reproduzieren, weil das war jetzt spezifisch auf Lars Klingbeil, will eine Rede halten, ich will Informationen aus meinen Büchern zusammentragen, aus meinem ganzen demografischen Fundus, wie auch immer, und es muss halt passen. So, das war jetzt eine Einmalsache, die jetzt nicht nochmal wiederholt werden kann, wie was anderes, sondern muss ich wieder von Null anfangen. Nur, ich kann halt noch von Null anfangen, weil ich jetzt einfach Handlungsmöglichkeiten habe. So ist das hier auch. Also, dieses den Krieg ins Stolpern bringen, muss man sich jetzt genau anschauen, was ist denn gerade die Sachlage? Also, den Iran-Krieg kriegen wir nicht so ins Stolpern gebracht wie den Ukraine-Krieg, weil das sind halt zwei verschiedene Sachen. So, und genauso kann man jetzt nicht sagen, ja, aber beim Iran ist das jetzt wirklich so gut, dass die da einen Regime-Change anstreben, weil das hat ja damals in, also beim Arabischen Frühling auch nicht funktioniert. Dann sag ich, ja, das war ja auch woanders und wannanders und überhaupt und so. Nur diese Einzelfall-Sensibilität.
Aber du hältst ja auch nicht den Regime-Change für tatsächlich jetzt intendiert von Trump oder Netanyahu in einer Weise, wie es hier beschrieben wird.
Das sind ja inhaltliche Fragen, die man jetzt ganz einfach abwimmeln kann, indem man einfach sagt, naja, wir hören ja, wie Donald Trump darüber redet. Also, wenn es wirklich stimmt, dass der Präzedenzfall wie Nezuehla, ich mach mal kurz einen Regime-Change und dann, ah ja, und dann hab ich einfach die Vizepräsidentin und nennet mir das Öl und das war meine Rationalität. Fertig, Punkt, so, ja. Dass man hier einfach, und Trump jetzt selber nicht weiter weiß. Also, Trump ist derjenige, der es alles veranstaltet. Der uns sagt, es ist ein Regime-Change, weil wir haben ja alle getötet, während die Nachrichtenlage ist, der neue Comenie heißt auch Comenie. So. Also, wenn es die handelnden zentralen Protagonisten nicht unter einen Nenner kriegen, warum wir? Wir können das durchaus ausbreiten.
Wie kann es sein, dass man da solche Intentionen aufbaut?
Sie versuchen ja zumindest drei Leute, die so hin und her durchlaufen zu lassen. Hätten sie sich dieses Finale da gespart, wäre das ja vielleicht sogar ein guter Versuch gewesen.
Aber sie wollen natürlich jetzt diese Position. Sie tritt ja dann auch extra, also die iranische oder aus dem Iran stammte Comedien tritt ja dann extra noch mal einen Schritt vor, um das zu sagen, die anderen sollen dann nicht mehr eingreifen, um zu sagen, jetzt ist es an der Zeit. Und dass das in dieser Weise in einer satire Sendung wie Die Anstalt stattfindet, finde ich schon skandalös. Dass da irgendein Pater ein bisschen, sagen wir, merkwürdig ist, okay, aber dass das da soweit ist und das ist wieder so eine Stimmung, dass jetzt gerade, glaube ich, so unter jungen Journalisten nicht eine geopolitische Gesamtlage gesehen wird und offenbar auch alles nebeneinander hergeht. Wenn Trump etabliert den Faschismus, würden diese jungen Redakteure vermutlich alle sagen, wenn ich sage, na ja, macht mal langsam, dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich schon der Trump- und Faschismus-Verharmlose an einer Person. Zugleich sagen sie aber, jetzt befreit er Trump da die Frauen, weil er ja dafür bekannt ist wiederum, ach nee, ist er nicht, aber trotzdem. Das finde ich einfach so wahnsinnig an diesem Diskurs, wo das ja alles so offen liegt wie nie zuvor. Wir haben ja doch in der Vergangenheit immer solche Interventionen erlebt, solche Kriege erlebt, da wurde besser gelogen. Und dann hätte man sagen können, naja, dann ist man wohl mal reingefallen, aber das kann ja hier eigentlich nicht mehr der Fall sein. Dass es Interessen gibt, auch in dem iranischen Volk, dass Trump da mit seiner Politik erfolgreich ist, das will ich ja da gar nicht bestreiten. Trotzdem ist es völkerrechtswidrig und trotzdem sollten wir uns da nicht involvieren. Und trotzdem wird auch Trump und wird auch Netanyahu nicht dafür sorgen, dass dies jetzt eine liberale Demokratie mit einem starken wirtschaftlichen Iran werden, denn dann wäre das tatsächlich eine Konkurrenz zu dem, was man da gerade ausgebaut hat, nämlich eine ziemliche westliche Hegemonie. Das ist illusorisch, das anzunehmen, also Rationalitäten und Intentionen zu unterstellen, die einfach nicht vorhanden sind.
Ja, also wenn man den Krieg nicht als eigene Entität, so wie Alexander Kluge das vorgestellt hat, also alle Kriegsparteien kämpfen im Grunde gegen den Krieg selbst. So, wenn man das nicht so beobachtet, sondern einfach sagt, nee, ich sehe für mich nur Protagonisten, Trump macht was, Comini, den hat seit drei Wochen keiner gesehen, macht auch irgendetwas, die Revolutionsgarten machen irgendetwas, dann kommt man nicht weiter, denn es kann auf dieser Ebene alles gleichzeitig wahr sein. Ich habe heute Morgen Carlo Masalla gehört, der im Table-Media-Podcast auf die Frage hin, ja, was sollte Trump jetzt im besten Fall machen, und sagte, ein Sieg erklären und aufhören. Und ich denke mir so, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr gute Idee irgendwie, das würde sehr viel Stabilität für uns bedeuten. Im Iran würde halt das Regime sich wieder revitalisieren und sagen, okay, beim nächsten Mal müssen wir noch besser vorbereitet sein, wir haben hier noch eine Million Störfaktoren, dann findet Massmord statt oder so. Gleichzeitig könnte es einfach sein, dass morgen herauskommt, Khomeini ist seit drei Wochen tot, da wurde einfach erklärt, niemand hat ihn gesehen und sonst im Regime ist auch wirklich niemand mehr da. Es ist gerade ein freies Kräftespiel von wie auch immer und im besten Falle hat jetzt auch die NATO durch eigene Aufklärung herausgefunden, wir sollten jetzt einfach nach Teheran fahren. Es ist jetzt gerade kein großer Widerstand zu besetzen und dann gelingt das irgendwie wie auch immer. Also Carlo Masalla's Idee von einfach Sieg erklären und gehen war genau das Falsche. Ist alles möglich.
Naja, das zweite ist deutlich weniger möglich.
Wir wissen gar nichts über das iranische Regime. Die Revolutionsgarten schießen wild um sich, das sehen wir. Aber über das iranische Regime, also dass es da noch eine Führungsspitze gibt.
Weil die offenbar ziemlich erfolgreiche Militärschläge da ausüben.
Nein, nein, nein, der Iran funktioniert ja anders. Die Hälfte des Irans sind die Revolutionsgarten.
Ja, nur sieht man ja jetzt gerade nicht einen sonderlich geschwächten Iran. Also es ist ja doch erstaunlich, welche militärischen Kapazitäten dieses Land hat, mehr als man offenbar erwartet hat.
Ja, das ist klar.
So, und das sorgt ja für eine entsprechende Stärke. Und wir sehen ja auch, dass nach innen gerade die Repressionen so zugenommen haben, dass natürlich die Leute jetzt aus guten Gründen keine Proteste organisieren.
Wenn das stattfindet, brauchst du in Teheran kein zentrales Regime des Handlungs, was es Befehle gibt. Das wäre genauso gut, einfach so möglich, denn da sind Leute, die verteidigen ihre Profite. Die Revolutionsgarde besitzt die Hälfte dieses Landes. Das ist kurz vor kommunistischer Partei. Da gibt es seine kleinen Profite und so weiter.
Und die geben das jetzt nicht aus der Hand, dass das so wird, wie das jetzt hier beschrieben wird, dass es einfach noch so ein Endkampf, der zu führen ist. Und dann ist der Iran befreit. Danach sieht momentan nichts aus. Von daher würde ich sagen, so furchtbar das klingt, wird Karl Omar Salah da dichter an der Wirklichkeit sein. Was ich ja einfach empörend finde, ist, dass wir jetzt aus einer satire Sendung plötzlich eine Rationalität unterstellt bekommen, wo ich sage, ja, aber die ist doch gar nicht gegeben. Also das ist ja das Eigenartige. Also dass man das, also der Donald Trump interessiert sich doch nicht dafür, ob irgendwo Aufstände niedergeschlagen werden und das ist dann sein Kriegsgrund. Das ist doch einfach nicht sein Kriegsgrund. Dann kann ich ja immer noch sagen, dass ist alles ganz furchtbar und man müsste schauen, wie man die Zivilbevölkerung unterstützt. Möglicherweise ist genau auch diese Sanktionspolitik, die es gab, gerade hinderlich, um in Iran liberale Kräfte zu stärken. Denn die Sanktionen treffen ja immer alle. Es ist eine besonders harte Waffe, die die Zivilbevölkerung trifft. Während sich natürlich die Mullahs selbst und ihre Gefolgsleute noch mal in anderer Weise über Wasser halten können, kann man alles diskutieren. Aber ich glaube, was absolut falsch ist, ist Donald Trump Rationalität zu unterstellen. In einer Weise, als sei er derjenige, der sich aufgrund der Proteste im Iran gesagt hat, da muss ich eingreifen. Wenn das so wäre, dann müsste Trump erst mal noch wo ganz anders überall eingreifen und dann auch vielleicht einen Krieg gegen sich selbst führen, weil er auch Proteste niedersteigt. Nicht so brutal wie im Iran selbstredend, aber er ist ja gerade jemand, der eine Entdemokratisierung vornimmt. Und dass man das hier beides so parallel laufen lässt und glaubt, dass wir es hier mit jemandem zu tun haben, der da befreien will, finde ich wirklich absurd und auch erschreckend eigentlich, dass das so in der Mitte verbreitet wird. Also bei dem ZDF da verbreitet wird.
Ja, aber also ich rede auch viel mit Leuten und so. Ich weiß nicht, wo die im Fernsehen, also wie die drauf kommen, dass es da für ein Publikum gibt.
Na ja gut, das ist ja etwas, was wir hier schon sehr lange beobachten. Ein Großteil der Bevölkerung findet eigentlich den Kurs von Olaf Scholz gut. Wenn man die Zeitung aufschlägt, dann liest man da drinnen, Scholz zögert, zaudert, macht sonst was. So ist Deutschland nicht gewappnet und wir schmiegen uns an Putin an und was weiß ich. Die Bevölkerung hat das ja auch nie so gesehen. Also die Großteil, das ist ja wie schon so häufig dann die öffentliche und die veröffentlichte Meinung, die klaffen da ganz stark auseinander.
Selbst die Anstalt macht glaube ich nur für ihre Programmchefs in der solche Sendung.
Für die Programmchefs und dass nicht am nächsten Tag ein böser Tweet von Paul Ronzheimer kommt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Gut, wir reisen auf den Salon hin. Wir lesen Peters Sotadeik. Wir haben schon mal von ihm ein Buch gelesen, nämlich das Buch über Europa. Jetzt hat er schon schnell wieder nachgelegt. Das Buch heißt Der Fürst und seine Erben über große Männer im Zeitalter.
Ein tolles Format, irgendwie so ein schönes, weiches Buch. Ich kauf jetzt wieder echte Bücher.
Ah ja, ich bin ganz verblüfft.
Weißt du warum? Nein. Ich blätter sie einmal durch, damit sind sie abgescannt und dann ist meins. Jeff Bezos sagt mir nicht mehr, dass ich nur 10% meines E-Books exportieren darf, sondern.
Ach, das ist so, ja. Aha, okay.
Ich hab's jetzt selber. Okay.
Vom Sündenfall zum Absturz in den Staat, so heißt hier ein Kapitel. Wir sind sehr gespannt. Wir werden das lesen, aber das nicht allein, sondern wir lesen auch Was das Valley Herrschen nennt von Adrian Daub. Er kennt sich im Silicon Valley sehr gut aus, hat jetzt ein zweites Buch vorgelegt. Wer unsere Besprechung zu Was das Valley Denken nennt, und ich glaube, die ist sehr zeitlos, hören will, kann das auch im Salon Archiv finden. Dieses Archiv ist also für alle, die den Salon abonniert haben, dann zugänglich. Der Salon ist abonnierbar über Steady, Apple und Patreon. Am besten ist es, man geht einfach auf die Neuen Zwanziger Seite.
Wir haben eine eigene App.
Eine eigene App nicht, aber eine eigene Seite.
Nein, der App ist eine Seite.
Okay.
Wir können natürlich noch mal einen richtigen Appwrapper drumbauen, und die dann im Appstore vertreiben. Aber da müssten wir Appstore-AGBs unterschreiben. Und sind wir Oliver Pocher oder was?
Nee, das sind wir nicht. Gott sei Dank sind wir das nicht. Hast du schon eine Idee, was du sonst noch liest? Ich will es mir noch offen halten.
Es gibt ein sehr dickes Buch über Kybernetik und Kontrolle oder so.
Von Anna Verena Nostov.
Richtig. Das liegt parat. Es ist allerdings sehr dick. Mal sehen.
Gut. Diese beiden Bücher jedenfalls werden wir lesen dann im Salon. Und wir hören uns dann im neuen Monat.
So ist es.